98
next danny coulson the founder and first
commander of the fbi's hostage rescue
team talks about the book he co-wrote
titled no heroes
inside the fbi secret counter terror
force mr colson's book offers an inside
account of how his team handled some
high-profile cases including the
oklahoma city bombing
he spoke at the tattered covered
bookstore in
more fun denver you guys participate um
probably if you've ever had a contact
with the fbi they probably come to
interview you right i mean maybe you've
been contacted by the fbi
and now's your chance you can you can
talk to me you can ask questions
i've had you will not ask a question i
haven't heard before i promise you i've
been beaten up by some of the best
people in the country
and i enjoy that i enjoy the the
negative and you know the bureau has
good things about it and some things
that people aren't too happy about some
things i'm not too happy about that we
did
and i don't have any problem talking
about them i wrote about them in the
book and i'm very candid about the
things we were successful in and the
things we weren't and i tell you why i
think we weren't successful and we have
some things that
that we would wish had never occurred
like things that happened on april 19th
i'll tell you a little bit about how the
book got started my wife
um happens to be my very best friend
she encouraged me to write this book
and i she'd heard the stories about the
fbi agents before and certainly the hrt
operators people get to know the book if
you borrow the book or whatever and
she thought that nobody ever captured
what agents are all about they all think
were these automatons like you see us in
the movies you ever see the bruce willis
movies here see what he does to us oh my
god we look horrible in those movies i
gave a speech one time out in portland
oregon where i was the commander and
one of the guys in the back room raised
his hand said boy bruce willis really
makes you guys look stupid i said you're
right and when your daughter gets
kidnapped call bruce don't call me
and that sort of puts things in focus
but we're used to that and
part of the part of the problem i think
the bureau has is this mystique of
secrecy
and we don't and we never tell our story
nobody knows who we are or how we act or
or what uh what type of people we are
i tell you a little bit about the book
um
how it starts and then we can get into
some of the things we cover
um
on april on april 18 1995 i was in
dallas texas and my family just had
arrived from baltimore maryland
i'd been in texas about a year without
my family has happened sometimes we're
an fbi agent and i was the commander of
the division
in texas dallas i had the top half of
the state
and my wife came down on the 18th and
brought her two daughters i hadn't seen
them probably i think three times in a
year and
i was really looking forward to seeing
all of them especially my wife and we
were having breakfast at some friends
house on the 19th and we're watching tv
we're watching or listening tv and we
hear that there'd been explosion in
oklahoma
and my wife gave me that
look
and i said i'm sure it's just a gas main
it's probably nothing and then pretty
soon it said a bomb
and she said uh looked at me so i guess
i'll be building this house by myself
because that's why she was there we're
looking for a contract we bought some
land and we've which we've seen i think
we built a house every two years the
whole time we're married
so
i said no
it's uh it's not my territory that's bob
rix's territory he commands oklahoma and
she said right
and within the bomb went off at 902 and
at 9 15. my pager went off it was the
strategic information operations center
in washington dc and it was the chief of
the terrorism section he said did you
hear and i said yes he said you have to
get to oklahoma as quickly as possible
not only what the weather was like here
but in texas in oklahoma there's a
terrible thunderstorm it lasted really
three days
and i said i'll drive
and i went home i got rid of my clothes
and i got my clothes and and called one
of my agents to bring a particular
pistol that i like to carry and because
i had no idea where we were going or
when i'd ever be home again
and i headed north
from dallas up i-35 and started heading
to oklahoma within
10-15 minutes i received a phone call
from rita braver you guys know rita
braver who she is i think she's with cbs
she's a nationally known correspondent
really good
somehow she conned the fbi operator into
connecting me uh heard to my car and
you know
i was i was shocked and i certainly
didn't want to talk to a reporter
nothing it's you guys obviously but i
just had other things to to try to
contend with and she said danny she said
i figured you were going to oklahoma i
said that's right she said is this
middle eastern terrorist and i said no
it's bubbus
and she was shocked because we just had
what world trade center and uh and the
reason of course in the back of my mind
was april 19th april 19th is a very a
very uh important day to certain members
of the far extreme radical right it was
one of the first battles of the
revolutionary war the csa compound
which is the biggest stroke of disaster
for them um was taken down april 19th of
course waco
and she said to me well is that going to
be the theory of your case i said no
rita that's the way you do cases you
guys develop theories and find the facts
that support it and if a theory doesn't
work out then you come up with a new one
they say we'll find the facts and we'll
develop the theory later and i could be
wrong that was just a it was a wag you
guys know what a wag is a wag wild ass
guess
we're using the fbi all time
so she said okay we run off and i went
on up
when i got to the scene there it was
it was an amazing sight
i've been to to this to i don't know how
many crises in my life i've handled
many many crisis situations and been
involved in the rescue of a couple
hundred hostages
and i was familiar with crisis
management and there's one thing that
always strikes me in a crisis situation
is when you get to the crisis scene
there is a real electricity there
and you can't describe it you can almost
smell it in the air it's almost like you
know how lightning smells in a
thunderstorm this is the way i always
feel at the atlanta prison right which i
had the command of and this and other
situations
it seems to be
a
a mixture of the the despair of the
victims or the hostages the tremendous
energy
of the of the subjects
if it's a hostage situation and also the
energy of who the people who come to
help
the agents the police the rescue people
that come to help
are completely energized and you have
this
you can hear about you can feel it you
can just feel this buzz of energy going
on and there's a big problem with that
uh it helps you initially
when you first get there everybody has
all this energy they can do unbelievable
things they can pick things up and move
things they can just go forever but what
happens then
they all run out of gas
and it generally happens at the same
time
so i walked in the command post and i
saw bob ricks who was the commander
there and he had things going i mean
they were already going 100 miles an
hour and doing things and he said look
around give me some ideas um tell me
what we need to do
so i went around and checked with the
various supervisors and saw that they
really had things under control and i
really didn't offer very much but then i
made a decision he agreed with it and it
was not well received i sent half of
everybody our people home
fifty percent every other person number
off one two one two one two one two one
two twos go home we'll call you tomorrow
because we didn't do that what would
happen we kept working obviously to to
try to rescue the people there which
wasn't our job
but to try to collect the evidence uh
consistent with their rescue attempts
it's going to take a lot of energy we
had a lot of leads we had literally
hundreds of leads in the first half hour
of the case
so but you know it's going to run 24
hours a day it's the greatest mass
murder history country
and so i sent half of them home and they
were really ticked because everybody
wanted to help it was it was like this
giant calling to try to do something to
serve our country and also try to do
something for the victims but i'm a long
time ago i outgrew the need for my
subordinates to like me
that's one of the
the prices of being a commander and you
have to have the courage to make them
uncomfortable and sometimes they don't
like you but they don't pay me
to make people like me at that level i
think generally sort of do but
that's that's one of the curses of
command
so um
i sent him home
and we started the business of going
about trying to find mr mcvay of course
we didn't know who he was at the time
but we knew there was a person out there
and i got this really crazy order from
fbi headquarters the laboratory division
called down and gave an order that we
could not collect any evidence
they wanted to wait to the lab
technicians from fbi headquarters which
as you probably know is the seat of
every bit of good information in the
world they are the smartest people in
the world oh they've never seen a
criminal most of them but they have all
these great ideas and are super smart
much smarter than us so they wanted to
wait till the next day and fly down and
for them to start collecting the
evidence
and i i'm not a very patient person and
if you'll see from the book i am not
patient at all so i picked up the phone
i called a man named thurman who was one
of the section chiefs i said are you
crazy
i said you know what it does here we're
having a thunderstorm and all your
evidence that's not
really big will end up where
in the sewer
i said i tell you what we'll leave you
the big stuff we're taking a little
stuff
so we started collecting and um we
brought in evidence response teams from
all over the country
and and started this process i want to
tell you a story about a woman there
that
i think is a hero we called our book no
heroes but i want to tell you about this
woman
i came from a world that was totally a
testosterone world counterterrorism is a
male deal that's all there is to it like
the nfl there are no women in it they've
had women try out and because of the
rigors of doing it the the strength
requirements i mean they're smarter than
we are they're tougher probably but
there's certain things they can't do so
it's all male and i think you'll be
surprised that there are a lot of
stories in here about women women in the
fbi who make a really a difference and
and uh it's a different fbi than the one
i joined
when i came in uh it was j.d hoover how
many women do you think running the fbi
[ __ ] over this many and there were no
minorities and now the bureau is the the
face of the bureau's chains but let me
tell you about monica monica is a is a
woman who should have been a movie star
she's absolutely beautiful she's the
kind of woman that walks in the room
where just looks
the fbi's gained was hollywood's loss
she was assigned to my office in fort
worth texas
and she
she was on the evidence recovery team
which is a unit of 15 agents that we
send all over the country to gather
evidence at crime scenes they're really
good they're excellent i couldn't do it
they're really good they go to homicides
and these horrible disasters
monica also happened to be seven and a
half months pregnant
and when the order came to go with her
team she ran home and started packing
and pretty soon her supervisor called
her and said you're not going
and she pitched a fit and let me tell
you
agents don't pitch a fit to their
supervisors in the fbi because we kill
them for that not literally but
figuratively they just don't do it fbi
is a very very command and control based
operation always has been hopefully
always will be and she said i'm going he
said no you're not you're not going
because i mean think think about what we
were walking into we're walking into a
building where a lot of people were
killed and a lot of people would not be
recovered for a long period of time
which creates a toxic waste situation it
becomes a terrible environmental hazard
and with probably maybe too much
chivalry he was going to try to look out
after monica and she still pissed to fit
so doing what good fbi agents do not
want to make this woman mad and not
knowing what to do they call me
in my car and i'm driving along and
they're giving this scenario and i and i
said um i'm thinking well she's married
to an fbi agent named matt i said well
let's talk to matt about it and jim
adams says well hell he can't control
her he's got a gun
i said well okay i thought and i thought
about my own wife i mean we have four
kids and she's a really tough person and
and she has all this energy and things i
said oh hell let's bring her up she's
pregnant she's not sick and let's get
her up here but let's be careful what
she does
now think about this this woman i mean
the most important thing in her life is
what her baby
but then she had a calling to go up
there and try to serve to help these
people
and so she promised me she said i'll
i'll just do administrative work
i'll set out leads i'll review teletypes
and i'll just do administrative work she
lied
she she lied to me the first day she's
on the pile
and she's grabbing evidence and she
reaches down she picks up a picture and
it's a picture of a dea agent
and his family sings oh my god
this guy's probably under this pile and
she looks over her shoulder and he was
standing beside her digging too and it
was a great relief for her there's
there's a lot of emotion here people
just don't think i know you guys had the
trial and you heard a lot of it but
they're really human stuff it's really
an issue we're there it's really hard to
experience
on the second day she exacerbated the
situation she went into the crater
pregnant not to hear crawled down the
cradle she's she's sifting um
sand and dirt and gravel and all this
stuff that was the debris from the bomb
trying to find trying to find evidence
of what this bomb was made of
on the third day she went to the morgue
and monica and kathy lumley and another
female agent a couple of guys started
pulling
pieces of the barrels out of the bodies
of the victims and there were pregnant
women there and there were babies and i
stopped her one night in the in the
command post and i pulled her aside and
said saying we have to talk so you okay
and she said yeah i'm okay i said how do
you deal with the babies
she said i deal with the baby's okay
she's but when i have to walk out is
when there's a pregnant woman brought in
because i think about how excited i am
about my own baby and how matt's excited
about the baby our first one
and
and i know that this husband will never
see the baby or his wife again that was
really hard she had to leave during that
that's the only time she ever walked out
but she didn't leave for long she came
back and finished
the people that were that we were
serving
reached out for us in very unusual ways
uh the agents that were in the morgue
doing that they brought in therapy
monkeys
you know the little organ grinder money
monkeys a little long curly they brought
them in from the play with they had a
beauty shop come in
and they set up a beauty shop for their
women i don't think the guys went out
and if they do have to talk to some of
the guys about that but but they did all
these wonderful things for us little
caesars pizza do you all have that here
is that a chain here little caesars
pizza set up a pizza oven in the parking
lot and churned out pizzas 24 hours a
day and you couldn't pay for it
walmart came in and set up this huge
shopping center
inside our fence command post and think
of everything you can buy in walmart
what was there for us
if you ripped your boots or you ripped
your gloves or your goggles got smashed
or or you needed chewing tobacco and i
don't advocate that by the way it's
probably the political record say that
um toothpaste whatever they gave it to
you you couldn't pay for it you could
not buy anything there
i went to cracker barrel one night i i'm
gonna plug cracker bro they were so good
to us when we were there i went there
and i was dirty and dusty and i was hot
and tired and mad and went there with my
partner jim adams and
we ate dinner and this woman came over
and i don't look like an fbi agent i
mean i look like a tunnel rat i'm not
typical fbi guy she came right so you
guys from the fbi
i said yes ma'am she said well the
manager says you can't spend money here
and they wouldn't give us a check so
that's against the law for us
so we had to open up the menu find out
what we paid or should have paid figure
the tax and leave it on the table for
her for a tip but the outpouring of
support for us is something i'm sure
you've never heard about before we even
had women
and
their families bring food to our command
post and bring us food and we'll just
get it back to you
that was a great idea in my case it
wasn't that great of my idea because
shortly after we arrested timothy
mcveigh they sent me across country to
do the case on michael fortier interview
michael
and guess what
i can my clothes never hardly caught up
with me my clothes were always like one
transfer behind me or one jump behind me
and after weeks and weeks i finally
ended up back in maryland on another
terrorism case
and i i got there and all i came back
and i finally had my clothes except for
my underwear
it's very difficult when you've been on
the road for a couple months explain to
your wife why you've lost all your
underwear somebody asked me at one of
these things where's the clothes you've
ever been to being shot i said well a
couple times but this may have been the
closest
um try and i finally convinced her that
there are fbi groupies out there and
they'd steal her underwear that
she didn't believe that and it's not
true
um
i'm trying to think we want to jump to
now um
in the story uh we basically get to hear
in the story and then we leave we leave
oklahoma and we go back many years ago
to a group of assassins that were
preying on the
people in new york city they were called
the black liberation army and they were
a uh i'll see you guys soon
um black racing army was a a group of
terrorists that had broken off from the
black panther party they became the
cleaver faction of the black panther
party and they wanted to establish a
separate black state in the united
states of america
and they thought by killing cops
they could cause an overreaction on the
part of the government and therefore the
black people would rise up and we'd have
a revolution which is the tactic of
terrorists that's what they all tried to
do that's what tim mcveigh tried to do
and we go to that story that story's
called a new kind of killer
these guys would
they'd drive by cops and machine gun
them on the streets they'd walk up to
them and shoot them in the back they
killed a bunch of cops a whole bunch of
cops they killed all over the united
states there are about 40 of them and
a good section of the book is how we
chase down every one of those every one
of those guys and there's a story i want
to tell you about about that which i
think is really the whole tenor of what
the book's about one of the black
liberation army terrorists was a man
named
freddie helton
hilton had killed i've been charged with
murder of a policeman in
atlanta he walked up and asked for
directions when the policeman turned his
head freddy killed him and that was his
coming out party to be a member of the
black liberation army um he was a he's a
it was a very uh young smart really
smart kid good looking kid and we got
some leads on them and they came a time
when uh we thought we could ambush them
in brooklyn with a man named twyman ford
myers myers is the most vicious killer
i've ever known in my entire life and
yeah
72 1972 you were i think you were like
three years old
i remember
so anyway we set this ambush for freddie
and we had a bunch of new york city cops
and a bunch of agents obviously i was a
sniper at the time and i'm inside of a
building up four stories and i've got my
sniper rifle
in case mr hilton says going to his
dance of death which they were very good
at
he showed up
and that made everybody really nervous
because he was a cop killer we had cops
on the street they were out working on
doing the street work they were dressed
like construction workers and he was
walking all around them but we wanted
climbing the most we waited and for
about 10 minutes i had the scope of my
rifle
uh the the reticle on his heart
the whole time and i was i was pumped i
mean i didn't shoot this guy but you
know this is a tense situation of things
we trained to do to make a long story
short mr myers did not show up and there
was a diversion and we were able to
erase him arrest him without any
incident whatsoever
and that's the way it's supposed to be
that's the way these cases are supposed
to be resolved if we can uh we
interviewed him and he wouldn't talk
obviously and we put him in the back
seat of our car and bob mccartney and
bill baker jim murphy and i transported
him and he's in the back seat and he's
really nervous because he's not sure
what's going to happen he says what's
your name
last night i'm danny coulson and bill
baker said i'm bill baker and the other
guys said who we are he said oh i know
you you're close and yeah i know about
you you're baker i know about you we
know who you guys are you know we know
who's chasing us i said well if you know
who we are when you call us
just call us up we don't have to go
through all this stuff
and he's getting pretty pumped up he
thinks he's a tough kid and he says you
don't understand
he said we're at war you're a soldier
i'm a soldier we're at war
and we'll never surrender snow freddie
let me tell you something we're not at
war
you may be at war with your government
your government is not at war with you
because if we were at war you'd have a
great big hole in your chest because i
watched you this morning through the
scope of my rifle
that says a lot about what we try to do
we're not always successful at that
sometimes we fail sometimes we succeed
and what you hear most about is when we
fail that seems to be the nature of what
we do
and then
in the story we go on and do several
several terrorist cases we do the
atlanta prison ride i was a tactical
commander at that and some other things
and then we come back and we come back
to oklahoma and we wrap up the oklahoma
bombing
uh in the middle of our case
um let me tell you a little bit about
about tim mcveigh would like to hear a
story about tim mcveigh
i was gonna
i don't i never read i mean i know a lot
of authors do i mean i might call you up
and ask you to read but i don't ever do
that
but i'll tell i'll just tell you the
story
when we went to perry oklahoma to get
him out of local custody um that was a
very tense thing and let's let's go back
to the emotion of it um i just been in
the nursery
i had walked around the nursery and seen
the little little bloody handprints on
the wall where the kids were cut to
ribbons and you see the handprints
streaked down to the ground and seeing
the gerber baby bottles the baby food
bottles you guys how many have kids
you have children here how many have
ever used gerber baby food how thick are
those bottles
i mean i've got four kids i've dropped a
thousand of them i never broke one
because they're so thick well we found
them smashed like eggshells against the
wall then been blown across the
nursery and
that was hard for me because i had four
kids that all been in nursery schoolers
whatever so when you walk out of the
oval you know you want to catch these
guys i mean we always we're very
aggressive people and we want to solve
our cases but this was like a passion i
mean we had to find these guys anybody
would murder babies
he needs to get caught i mean he's we
got to catch him
but then all of a sudden we find mcvay
in custody
and the on-scene commander says danny
you got to go get them and keep them
alive
well that's the way it should be i mean
that's my job i mean i'm i i've done
dignitary protection all kinds of
tactical things my whole life
but it the emotion of it was was kind of
stark because here we are trying to find
him then once you find him that's our
job to keep him alive that's that's
that's it's the right thing to do
but i mean do you want to throw his butt
out of the helicopter yeah you sure do
but you don't because it's the wrong
thing to do
and when we go up to perry and uh
as we went out to the helicopter pad a
man named dave williams who is the
foremost
bomb expert i think in the whole world
the department of justice has had a
little problem with him but they're
generally wrong and he's generally right
um
he he will disarm any kind of bomb he
got a pipe bomb smoking he'll take it
apart nothing doesn't bother him scares
me i always get my car
but it doesn't bother him he's
absolutely totally fearless so we're
standing outside the helicopter while
the crews are getting the thing ready to
go it's one of my faces hrt helicopter
and i noticed him stand over like this
he
is he is really upset he is just upset
and i asked him a medicine what's
marrying him he said he is terrified of
flying in a helicopter
this is a man who will disarm a nuclear
weapon for i didn't want to get a little
helicopter
so i went over and i put my arm around
him said dave there is nothing to worry
about almost half of all helicopter
rides uh end without crashing
he said thanks a lot then the crew chief
comes out and he says danny our doc as
they call me the bureau doc we're ready
to go
but we don't have time to put the doors
on so i said okay
no problem for me
so we put dave out board on the port
side of the helicopter riding outside
just strapped in and we took off for
that flight to perry uh he was
absolutely terrified we loved it i mean
i
fbi just are brutal to each other if you
have any weakness i mean they you'll
tell the pilot
you know moving around anyway he it he
was scared to death but he did it and
it's okay to be afraid just have to
overcome your fear uh we get to perry
and we get out of the cars and an older
man came up to me i remind me my father
my father's old cowboy
and he had a straw hat on a white
tobacco and he looked i mean he could
have been a colson
he comes up and said are you boys from
the fbi i said yes sir we are he said if
you have a problem with the evidence
just put that boy at the back gate and
we'll deal with it for you i said thank
you i think our case is going to be
pretty strong
but they gave me a clue that we needed
to be pretty careful uh we went inside
and we started meeting with the sheriff
and the prosecutor and the federal judge
i mean sorry the state judge wanted to
keep him because he had some kind of
little
some kind of charge on him a gun charge
or something
and i'm getting pretty nervous because
the longer we're there the more his
confederates if they're already can
start to launch an attack now we've had
fbi agents attacked with law rockets
before i've worked a couple of cases
where terrorists have fired rockets at
our building and it's not unusual to
have law rockets we when i first joined
the fbi guys had knives now they have
law rockets
but i i really was concerned and i asked
the prosecutor said plea get me to see
the judge we need to get out of here and
how many phone calls do you think i got
from fba headquarters
about a bazillion my cell phone ran out
of juice talking on the phone if you got
to me if you got to meet you got
authorization arrest them give you got
them then they they were so the whole
world is waiting for me to get cussing
this guy and so i want to see the judge
and i said your honor i know you have
charges but i cannot i cannot guarantee
his safety i can't protect him in here i
mean this is what i do but i can't do my
job here and i said there's very
possibly good possibility that either a
confederate or an enemy will put a law
rocket through the window of your
courthouse
how quick do you think he signed that
order getting him out of there he's like
we were gone now we used a very i this
is this is probably borders on being
classified what i'm going to tell you
and it deals with the vehicle that we
use to transport timothy mcveigh the
greatest mass murder in the history of
the united states
now you have to promise to keep it
secret
it was the sheriff's wife's minivan
isn't that something
this thing had probably been a bazillion
soccer games and uh but i didn't have a
car i flew in the helicopter so i asked
the sheriff it's the sheriff you got a
you got a car and he said yeah so we we
put uh we had good security but the
minivan was the best thing we had so we
jumped in this van and we headed off
towards the uh
towards the um landing pad outside of
town we had all these escorts and state
cops and jim adams put up a really good
plan to get us out of there and and
these plans basically are dependent upon
speed and that's about about all
um we get out there and and uh
tim started to
let me back up just a minute about timmy
my friend tim
uh when the agents brought him in to
interview him uh they asked him do you
know what this is about he said yeah
it's the thing in oklahoma
and uh he was he was frightened uh he
reminded them about what happened to lee
harvey oswald and jack ruby
you remember what happened there and
he asked us if we could land the
helicopter on the roof of the courthouse
and get him out of there which
tactically was an insane thing to do
stupid
but secondly do you think i'm gonna
listen to him i don't think so and as he
said this and we're discussing it we
that we're all struck with the same
thought i think those people in the
moroc building would like to have an
opportunity to get out of the building
before you blew it up
and now
we have to keep him alive because that's
the thing to do
so we get him the air to the uh little
landing pads a little teeny airport and
uh
we pull up and
and tim starts to to he gets up he
starts to sit up and i grab him sitting
back down and i said you will act like a
gentleman on this ride and we will treat
you like one if you don't you'll be very
sorry i don't want to i don't have a
wrestling match this guy i certainly
don't trying to jump out
i mean janet would kill me he'd be
killed himself and that lead so we put
him in the helicopter we strapped him
down and the helicopter pilot started
climbing for altitude
um fbi helicopter pilots are really good
they are great they are right there with
task force 160 and most of them are
combat pilots and they're excellent and
i had this as i said there i'm thinking
this is the way it's supposed to be
this is what the fbi does best a major
investigation leads all of the united
states we we follow the law we follow
the constitution the people in the
country help us and we catch a great
mass murder and i actually felt real
good i'm thinking this is what i came in
today that's why i joined the fbi and
the helicopter starts to climb
all of a sudden the shutter i mean i can
feel it to this day a shudder went
through me because i thought
his buddies could have a stinger
i mean that stuff is out there stingers
and and and all kinds of guided missiles
are available and why because we gave
them the afghanistan's the afghanistan
sell them back to our criminals so
they're our stingers and i so i pulled
out a sheet of paper and i i jot
that this guy's buddies may have
military ordinance i don't want to sting
her up my ass take evasive action by
this time we're pretty high
and i jim adams the adams gibson the
pilot who wasn't who had flown the hrt
when i commanded that unit and these
guys are crazy all helicopter pilots are
major crazy especially the young
and he rolled that thing over like that
and dove it at the deck and about six
feet he pulls it up and we fly all the
way to tinker air force base about six
feet above the ground jumping over
fences going around trees around barns
now the media was smart they were smart
they stayed up about a thousand feet and
watched us
and uh of course imagine you can imagine
what dave williams was doing he wanted
like this bed uh mcveigh didn't blink
he did not blink he looked straight
ahead i sat right here he sat a little
bit in front of me had agents facing him
in one here he never looked left never
looked right he just looks straight
ahead it makes you wonder what was in
his mind
i don't know i'd like to know i'd like
to be able to open him up and say
but we can only guess and i think maybe
we can talk about that later
we got to we got to tinker
and uh we landed and we were met by a
very unusual contingency it was an fbi
swat team now remember i said when i
joined the fbi it's all white guys okay
no no minorities and women
um the guy that took custody of him was
it was an indian named chuck chony huge
indian guy from oklahoma
um all kinds of minorities there
completely different fbi that i joined
um he had the short wide stocky
commander me
my partner jim adams is a stocky and i
would say very stocky a biker he's a
harley rider says nothing about his
taste in bikes but he's just a rough
looking guy
tom lind
uh a chinese american
picked up take me up and the other guys
took they took tim
and i get in the car and and
um tom had a uh
his load-bearing vest his body arm he
had a ballistic helmet on and a machine
gun across his chest and he said sir get
in the back seat
and then and on his head rest he has a
pair of chopsticks
stuck in the headrest i said when you
think about how these cases go you think
it's all this serious stuff and
everybody's so we are serious but we do
but there is so much levity on these
things just like mash the movie mash all
that humor you're taking during a guy's
heart and you're talking about you know
hot hands who are watching him hot lips
hulayan or something it's just a lot of
joking around
so uh tom turns to me and he said sir
i am oriental and today i feel a little
suicidal i suspect i suggest you buckle
up
and we took off on a ride that was much
more dangerous in the helicopter right
here we're just screaming because again
we don't we want to try to avoid an
ambush
and uh jim adams being the delicate
person he says what what the hell are
these chopsticks for tom he said well i
teach
machine gun schools that's one of my
jobs and my students pass
i give them a set of chopsticks as
motivation i said i got a better idea
you tell them that when they fail they
have to ride in the backseat of your car
i think they'll be a lot more motivated
but this is the kind of things that the
banter that goes back and forth on the
on these types of situations i mean
we're serious about what we do we're
very serious but there's always that
humor that nobody's ever captured before
and i know we capture it in this book
because every day i get two or three
books from fbi agents they mailed them
and said please sign them and send them
back of course they're so cheap they
don't send the postage so i have the
customers costing me money to send these
books but they like the book and it's
really been fun
remember what i said to fred hilton
about you're not at war
you're at war with us we're not with you
that next day the fbi sent me to kingman
arizona
to handle the case on michael fortier
and
they
it's one of these things like uh danny
uh where's your family i said well i
think they're in maryland well then they
won't miss you
so i'm on a plane i'm heading to kingman
i get out there and we did a search on
the
michael fortier's house and we took him
i called him to come out come see me
and we met in a little trailer and it
was a substation of the local sheriff's
office and it was myself and a guy named
bob walsh who commanded our division in
southern california another middle-aged
guy like me and we pulled up three
chairs on wheels and we sat
this close our knees were touching and
we basically kind of whispered to my
call
and he gave me all this philosophical bs
that they they spout about their and
what their beliefs are and we listened
and then you want to have a debate about
the constitution
and i'm a lawyer and i passed the bar
and i was in legal counsel division i
think i know the constitution plus you
know you're a cop you live it every day
you know what the constitution's all
about and he said
he looked at me said you know some
people think the constitution is dead i
said oh it's not dead
i said let me tell you about the
constitution we just arrested tim
mcveigh under the constitution and we're
going to indict him under the
constitution we're going to try him
under the constitution
and we're going to handle his appeals
under the constitution
and um
one day we're going to strap him to a
gurney and we're going to stick a needle
in his arm we're going to execute him
under the constitution we're going to
the same thing to you
just like that
nobody screamed at him nobody yelled on
him it was just here we are there are 10
000 agents that time i told them we'll
put every we'll put all of them on it
we're going to find out everybody's
involved and then we're going to let the
people decide
and they gave me the same argument
some people say we're at war
i said son you may be at war
with your government your government's
not at war with you i mean after all we
were there at the search warrant
hardly an act of war
and that's what this is all about that's
what this book is all about is how do
you deal with terrorists
and you think about it if you if and
we've we've killed a lot of terrorists
sometimes you're forced into it
i mean i've been in this scene where
people were killed in shootouts robert
matthews leader of the order was killed
i was there hrt was not we weren't
deployed at the time but i actually saw
it
i've been around others with their
shootings and i always remember this
about terrorism when the government says
we're going to have a war on terrorism
that's the wrong thing to say it's not a
war what is terrorism terrorism is free
speech coupled with violent crime
if you take away the violence
then it's just free speech and we all
have a right to say we want to it's not
until individuals who have a different
way of looking at the world
engage in violent activity or sometimes
even a white collar crime case if they
want to crash your computer or something
it basically gets violence
so the way to deal with terrorism is to
arrest them if you can
and let who decide you
let the jury decide
if the government kills a terrorist as
sometimes happens
then what do we create
it's called a martyr
but if you arrest him and you put him in
trot in a trial you bring him to denver
or wherever and you let the people
decide it's you the government didn't
decide tim mcveigh's faith they didn't
sign terry nicholson did they no we
presented the case but who decided you
guys
you guys decided
then what do we create then if we try
them
if we try them in for murder and either
convict them or we convict them unless
lesser charge what do we create then
it's called a criminal
and what do we think about criminals we
don't care about them
a good example that's robert matthews
died in a firefight with the fbi
literally a firefight
he's a martyr to their cause
he went to live with odin he was a he
was an odin to see what that is
uh odin the norse god odin
they believe that stuff
um so he's a martyr to their cause a man
who was probably more vicious bruce
carroll pierce was arrested by leon
blakeney
didn't hurt him leon's character in the
book and i did the atlanta riot together
he arrested bruce carroll pierce didn't
fire shot although bruce had
three guns on him and was heavily armed
and vowed never to be taken alive but
when a guy screws an mp5 into your
throat
you rethink that position
um we tried him convicted he was uh the
people convicted him he was sentenced to
240 years in jail and you don't know his
name dude
why because he's a criminal
and that's the way to deal with
terrorism in my view
i've i've seen it happen both ways
the best way to deal with it is is by by
arresting them and putting them in jail
i'd like to see about say about tim
mcbailey tim mcveigh gave a revolution
and nobody can
and that's what this is all about
if the government had acted
inappropriately
then he might have succeeded
when i drove into the com our compound
area in oklahoma after this laborious
trip
and the calls about monica and everybody
else who's calling me one thing struck
me as i got the car there were no
roadblocks except to keep keep people
out of our crime scene we weren't
stopping every car on the road we we had
suspects we stopped interviewed but we
didn't put up roadblocks and we had to
interview everybody we didn't go house
to house and search every house in
oklahoma
we used search warrants to search
residences and and businesses we got
wiretap authority to put bugs and mics
in we went to we used our criminal
justice system do you think that would
happen in other countries you know what
they do in israel when they have
something like that they take a tank and
they bulldoze the home of all the
relatives of the people involved
that's not the way to do it that looks
like what we did at waco
and that's and that's that's the image
that we are dealing with and that's one
of the problems that we're still dealing
with today is that at waco the people
believed that we were acting like an
army i'm not in there i've trained with
every military unit you can imagine well
i took the command of the hostage rescue
team i trained with delta i went to this
navy seal school went to school in
europe with all the counter-terrorist
teams gign gst9
um
i said that i can't think of the name of
spanish geo
own scs too and went to the sas school
went to all those schools they're all
most of them are military gst9 is not
but the others are military or
paramilitary but i was trying to learn
tactics and techniques
but the thing that divides us and i had
the deputy attorney general the united
states asked me what she'd seen us he
said what's the difference between you
guys in delta i said it's very simple
delta is governed by the rules of
warfare we're governed by the
constitution
and when this gets blurred we're in a
lot of trouble we lose the support of
the american people
we lose we lose face and we look stupid
and the fbi only catches people we only
do our job if you cooperate
i was a fugitive hunter for almost 30
years oh actually 31 years
and i i caught 800 fugitives in my
career
and people say oh my gosh how do you
find somebody like that how do you track
down a man in this country overseas how
do you catch them i'll let you in a big
secret somebody tells you where he is
it's that simple
public cooperation if the people don't
cooperate with us we can pack up and go
home and we really suffered in the last
few years over what happened at waco and
what happened even at ruby ridge which
is another whole story but people just
one second i'll get to you because we're
about i'm about to wrap up um
so that's the whole message that's the
message of the book it's an adventure
story
lots of bad guys lots of good guys um
few shootouts
minimal um
but basically it's a story about men and
women who serve their country and about
their families lots of stories about the
kids in here how the kids are affected
by when
you do your thing when i get i married a
girl had three kids i had one we put
these you know that's difficult man i
mean the brady bunch that doesn't happen
i mean they all hate each other and you
know they fought over the dog and whose
dice my dog annoys my dog we had to buy
another dog i mean just all this stuff
and that but i got we got married and
then i left for a year i was smart right
the bureau sent me a way for you so how
did that impact on our family i mean
dramatically and we talk about this kind
of stuff in the book so it's it's not
all cops and robbers it's about kids
it's about family and and where i think
we're going in the next in the next
century and you have a question yes uh
hollywood yeah
did you forget no i kind of remember
hollywood the media tend to distort
the fbi like they do a lot of agencies
and being the fbi's government there's
bureaucracy involved in systematic
problems but
you mentioned about the constitution the
fbi tries to follow but
you have to admit when mistakes are made
or bad judgment like in the atlanta
bombing with jewel
you know that innocent person can get
labeled and it's a hard thing to escape
ruby ridge
is the jurisdiction issue i mean is the
fbi looking to
be more
cautious about that and not to be maybe
so heavy-handed and admit to a mistake
and try to be more open-minded
absolutely and they should i think the
mark of an agency is not does it make
mistakes because we do and i want you to
think a minute what what is the standard
for performance when we're brought into
a very volatile crisis situation think
about and all what you how you how
you're graded at your job and you have a
performance appraisal plan i'm not
asking just think about how do they
grade me the standard performance for
for me
and a crisis situation where people are
pointing guns and rockets and there's
there's emotion and hatred the standard
performance is perfection
if we screw it up
then that's all we hear about and that's
okay with me i volunteered to do that i
i understand that um i know that that
that that guy may kill me or one of my
people or they would i do something else
now but at the time but i also
understand the great there's another
risk to it and that is public opinion um
and criminal investigations i mean i was
investigated for over two years and
exonerate after two years of horrible
investigation that's something we have
to deal with um
the answer to your question is we make
mistakes with jewel that was a stupid
mistake it was stupid we took the word
of a profiler and focused on richard
jewell and the evidence didn't support
us that much the evidence is really weak
and i think we learned a big lesson from
that that was a major mistake now these
profilers are wonderful i write about
them in here they save my life once
they're wonderful but they screw up and
and the measure is what do you do about
it do you correct it
after waco we totally changed the way we
manage a crisis situation if i told you
that our commanders the guys who command
our divisions in the field
that the fbi trained them more in how to
deal with the media than they did with
how to deal with the christ i swear to
god that's true
not all of us i mean i spent my whole
life being trained as a crisis commander
but most of them weren't gene glenn had
never been to crisis management he
didn't have a clue
what was going on
now that's all changed they have special
crisis management schools we even
trained the department of justice
attorneys which i mean that's kind of an
oxymoron that we could no they could
never do it and they don't want them to
do it but it's changed it used to be
that the crisis happened in say denver
that the denver commander was in charge
the director changed that he picked his
best commander if he was in alaska he
came and commanded this that's what
happened in oklahoma bob rex the
commander of oklahoma
wasn't the on-scene commander they
brought me weldon kennedy and two other
commanders in to help we didn't used to
do that that was stupid
at
at waco we had
the hrt
information and the uh negotiators
information going up like stove pipes
they went like that they never went like
that so they never brought these two
these two disciplines together and an
inexperienced commander that has the
hostage rescue team here and the the
negotiators there
um who do you think he's probably going
to lean to
first of all the hrt is like a giant
machine the guys are aggressive they're
smart when they get in man they boom
boom boom everything's set up they've
got they've got communications they can
talk to the world their snipers are out
and all and they look they're very
impressive they can completely take over
for it from you i mean they'll they'll
seize the moment because they their job
is to be ready to go and risk their
lives like now when they hit the ground
and what are what are the hosts
negotiators like
you know they
they stroll in and they never look
excited and they get their little phone
out there's probably only two of them
and they reel it out and they start a
dialogue and they're relaxing because
they're what's their job
the job of a negotiator is to bring the
tension down
from here to here
and one thing to remember about a crisis
is when you have high emotion
logic is where it's on the ground
there's none
so thereby there by their demeanor
they're they try to bring this emotion
down and time does that so they're not
in a hurry
the hrt guys are what they're in a hurry
because somebody may say go and rescue
those hostages they got to be gone see
if all this energy here and this very
relaxed
thing here so the commanders tend to
listen to the tactical guys
and so that's one of the problems at
waco
that that there was not a strong voice
that supported the negotiators not
strong enough some people believe
there's more oh yeah absolutely the
whole the whole way that's gone like
they used to have a meeting with the
tactical guys in a meeting with the
negotiators well i never did that
i love negotiators because you know what
when negotiators do their job nobody
shoots danny
i love those things i mean i i love
those guys
some people didn't feel the same way
but now the philosophy of the fbi is
more like my philosophy was i mean god
talk them out then i can just sit here
and you know do nothing
i mean i jocked up came here got ready
suited up and i got to go home
you know because remember one thing
about fbi agents this comes as a shock
to you when we get shot we don't come
back to life
i know it's hard to believe in the day
of video games
i let my kids play those things because
they have all this violence oh i'm dead
i'm ready to go
there are no restart buttons on cops and
there's no restart buttons on any of
them
so life is very precious and that's the
reason for the motto of the hrt to save
lives that's our job trying to keep
people alive i think it's a lot better
we made mistakes there we made mistakes
at ruby ridge
um
and that's what you're gonna hear about
because people don't care about the good
things
um let's do her she's cute i have a
million questions so you're gonna have
to shut me up now i'll just give you the
book
okay well first off you just said
something this is um personally you just
said you do you do not let your kids
watch video uh or play with video games
no we've never had a nintendo right okay
um no it's not just that i think they
become idiots
that's primarily i mean i mean i live in
a violent world i mean i my kids shoot
they all shoot guns uh one of them was
trying to shoot the fbi academy he can
shoot a gun bearing most agents it's not
that it's just it's the idea that that
that just
violence the for the sake of violence
and i don't say they can't go see a john
wayne movie or something like that but i
i just have a real problem with those
games and kids who and i make my kids
lift weights run they help play sports
uh they're very athletic kids and i
think a lot of it because we've never
had nintendo
but if you have nintendo that's great
it's just not for me
um
okay on some of the personal questions
um loosely loosely sink ships i do have
to take uh say you're never going to out
drink alcohol when you take on with the
fbi do they allow you
no you do uh
i mean most guys in the fbi are irish
you think we're going to pick a place
like that for guys sake
no no but you do have to sign a secrecy
agreement i mean i have secrets i mean
secrets that would spin your head people
tell me things at bars you know because
they were drinking and i guess i won all
kinds of stuff you know what that was
that was that guy who said he was in fbi
thought you were cute
he was impersonating you
okay um now when you when you uh can't
tell your wife what you're doing in
certain situations like that do you have
are your best friends whatever why do
you have a time limit on that is are
there certain things you're never going
to be able to die
um
there are secrets that we things we did
things that i was involved in is either
a commander or an agent or an
administrator but i can never tell
the rest of my life the secret will
never be told
like for instance you leave for two
months and your wife doesn't know what
the hell you're up to
do you
when it comes to because you're
generally
over are you then you're like a certain
time frame yeah
sure i'm acting remember many times um
walking on the on the runway in his air
force base you know trying to catch up
with the c-130 the ramp is still down so
you can still run up into it i'm talking
on my cell phone i said i'm gonna be
late for dinner she says how long is it
about a month that's that kind of stuff
but they get used to it i mean you have
to marry a special kind of person
we deployed at puerto rico for example
one time to do some cuban terrorists who
had again fired a rocket at our people
and i didn't tell her i said i'm going
i'm gonna get sun down i'll see yeah um
okay do you guys use remote viewing
okay can you i like a lot of different
subjects and anything that you want
could expand on or anything
let me tell you about nice talker okay
can we talk about the book big time um
when we were doing a compound down in
arkansas it was a christian identity
compound it was run by a man named jim
ellison and a man named carrie noble and
a guy named richard wayne snell
i won't go into christian identity it's
kind of a perverted type of christianity
that's embraced based on racism
i got a call that the hrt was going to
be deployed to arrest jim ellison he had
law rockets claymore mines machine guns
a tank
night vision gear great communications
they had a shooting range it was as good
as the fbi's these guys were really good
they were living in a fortress on the
shores of bull shoals lake and they said
and you're going to take them out so man
you know impossible mission uh the hr
i'm sorry the commander
of the criminal division sent down an
airplane to help me call night stalker
which i didn't know anything about at
the time and night stalker could open up
about five thousand feet at night you
can't hear it and as it has a thermal
imager on it and through that device and
some other thermal image devices we had
we could actually patrol into their
compound at night
and patrol around their patrols because
they patrol looking for us and night
stalker which incident was run by a
woman she was my link to the ground and
her name was grits and she would say
you've got at 12 o'clock you've got two
guys on a patrol and so we'd go we'd go
to nine o'clock and then go 12 o'clock
and so
and we talk about that that's not
classified anymore we talk about it i
wouldn't the book the fbi proved this
book
they like everything but they approved
it took me two years to get it approved
but there's a lot of things we talk
about a lot of stuff in the book but
there's some yeah there's star wars out
there i can't tell you if i have to kill
you
what is the um
it's kind of a two-fold question what is
the
likelihood of uh increased terrorist
activity from foreign agents
and influences in this country and what
is the fbi and our government doing to
protect us okay we have two forms of
terrorism international which is the
type that blew up the world trade center
and domestic we seem to grow more of our
own than come from overseas um
if i right now i know if i was a
commander of a division in the fbi what
i would be concerned about were there
were terrorists that were coming from
serbia
i wouldn't be concerned so much and i
wouldn't be concerned about the serbians
who live here
and what i would be doing which we did
during the gulf war is go to the serbian
community and say we need two things
you you will not be the subject of any
uh retaliation because of your
nationality because that's a violation
of the law we want you to know that did
you have recourse if some americans want
to threaten you because you're of
serbian extraction or nationality then
we want you know the fbi is here to help
you the other thing is if you're
contacted
by anybody from in serbia and ask you to
do something we don't know about it
because terrorism is a is the is the
tool of weak government
and if they're going to start losing and
getting in trouble then they they're not
going to shoot down our planes
likely
and so i think we're vulnerable to that
we're obviously vulnerable to middle
eastern terrorists we've proven that the
fbi i think we have a good handle on the
on the on the international stuff we
have excellent coverages and performance
and technical and stuff i think we're
pretty good at that with the domestics
we have a problem
because we have the free speech issue
and how do you balance free speech
with uh
intelligence and it's really hard for us
and and we've gotten in trouble for
going the wrong way by investigating
that one time we investigated a group of
quakers for god's sakes that was really
stupid cast a lot of trouble we deserved
it um but it's a balance do we do we
have a handle yeah i think we do
but can we guarantee it no we can't i'll
tell you straight up we can't but i
think it's better to live in a free
society with some risk than it is to
live in an authoritarian society with
less
risk well i agree with that but i
i
i mean even the serbian population that
lives here that has been american that's
if i were watching
cnn and
and seeing that kind of destruction and
a relative called me
i wouldn't be happy with the american
government
no but but but remember this being
unhappy with the american government is
a constitutionally protected activity if
i ask you in this room how many let's
take a test okay let's just take a test
all right okay are you ready for your
test you have to pass this
if you don't pass it you will be
interviewed by ken starr
now that's terrorism okay how many of
you are unhappy with your government in
any way
okay how many of you paid too much taxes
do you pay too much taxes boy i'll raise
both hands okay how many of you have a
view one way or another about the
abortion issue one way or another do you
care okay how many of you believe in a
um a literal in uh interpretation of the
second amendment which is the right to
keep embarrassment do you feel one way
or another about that okay all right
congratulations you have all just taken
the first step necessary to be a
domestic terrorist because that's what
they believe too
they would answer yes the same questions
what's the difference
in their personality similar to
or have a similar trait to
like serial killers that seem to be
have no emotion towards their victims
but are certainly extremely concerned
about their own well-being okay the
basic the basic uh
characteristic of a domestic terrorist
is an inadequate personality tim mcveigh
has it almost everybody i've ever dealt
with and that group has it they don't
like themselves they do not like who
they are they um i interviewed tim
mcveigh's father on the day after i
arrested him had him flown in from
denver a really nice man i had i had so
much empathy for him sitting there and
we're talking about his son the greatest
mass murder in the history i mean if it
had been my son not a gunner again but
can you imagine how he felt he was very
cooperative he helped us but frankly i
could have written a lot of the report
before i ever talked to him because he
said tim was he didn't say it was
inadequate but he described me as being
inadequate tim went to school every day
but never did anything he never did
anything in school he wasn't successful
in school he never participated in
anything like the glee club the band the
choir the
new any all the stuff that our kids do
sports he never did that he just went
he never had an association with a woman
that we know of no no girlfriend that
lasted more than
you know twenty dollars worth nothing
that was meaningful um
and that was him he went uh he did a
pretty good job in the army
but he couldn't sustain it he went
through special forces uh tryouts did
you guys know that
you know how long he lasted
one day
i am an old man i could get through
these two
he he pooped out
so he didn't like himself he wasn't
satisfied with who he was
and then he got caught up in this um
stuff with the turner diaries probably
you've heard about the turner diaries
and sometimes i don't i don't read it
it's not worth it it's trash it's
horrible but he got involved in that and
then he started developing hatred and
some people in the movement think he
wasn't he believed in odin and which is
a very
um
crazy racist type of philosophy and
that's basically most of um muslim like
eric rudolph is a summer type of guy so
they're inadequate they don't like
themselves they have to sign somebody to
hate then they have to act out their
hatred and then if they develop a
religious justification for it
then you've got real problems because
then god's on their side which is very
helpful
you think about i mean having god on
your side if you're terrorists is
wonderful because why gives you a
religious reason to kill somebody
and basically it's minorities oh fbi
guys too they don't like us we're on the
side of the minorities how does that
work
danny o'neil coulson from ireland
is on the side of all the minorities how
does that work
have any idea
you think i'd be on this side wouldn't
you
no i'm not because they believe this is
a zionist controlled government and the
fbi guys that work for the government
are called agents of zog zog
when we when we got into that stuff we
found out about we all went about half
said zoglin
so
anyway that's that's kind of the way it
works and we again we i'm not you know
the book talks about that in great
detail what they believe and why they
believe it um yes sir i think you were
next um the threats that swat teams and
special reaction teams faced in
20 25 years ago are different than they
they face now
and my question is
is hrt evolving to deal with the
chemical nuclear and biological threat
okay
when i came into bureau in
1966
we generally rescued with knives
sometimes revolvers and evolved to the
point where law rockets fully automatic
weapons laser designator well i mean
you know it's out there now and and the
issue then becomes how do we arrest an
army
because we have we have made a decision
our country to allow
people to have their own armies here csa
had it they've crashed they're still out
there you have a right to have an army
but then how do i deal with that
and and that's an issue for us how do
you arrest an army
and
and we talk about how you should do it
first of all you don't do it like the
atf and charge into it and get everybody
killed i mean do other things but yeah
they're keeping up they are keeping up
with with technology and basically what
makes the hrt better is that they train
every day they shoot every day they have
all these unbelievable marksmanship
skills i don't know if you know about
the hrt or not but when they when they
do their training and they go into a
shooting house environment
when they face a target a mannequin or a
paper target there's a live human being
standing right beside that target so if
i'm going to bust into a room and you're
the target
there's a live man or woman standing
beside him because they shoot right past
live people and they're unbelievable
their marksmanship skills are incredible
because they shoot every day
their intelligence gathering capability
is very good so they always i mean you
can get down to the same equipment but
then it gets down to who's the best
agent or who's the best fighter with
regard to kim bio we're not there
i tell you we're not
we're not even close
i mean that's a military deal that's
they're the only people have the
capabilities i mean you might be able to
outfit one fireman or two or three or
four or five i don't think we're there i
think we're close but one thing to
remember about kim bio as a chem bio
becomes more dangerous to the terrorists
sometimes it does to us
if you look at at the sarin gas deal
that went over in japan they had this
whole laboratory and they did all this
stuff all these smart guys and all the
only way they could disperse it was with
a baggie with holes punched into it
so they've really had a hard time coming
up with the delivery
system for kim bio anthrax or any other
stuff and it sounds really horrible and
it is horrible but it's so much easier
uh to go out and make a fertilizer bomb
i could take this row right here three
ladies me i could have the fertilizer
bomb tomorrow made that would protect
down the [ __ ] building it's easy
i'm gonna tell you how to do it but it's
it's really easy so i i think the weapon
of choice choice will be pipe bombs
and fertilizer bombs if they get to it
hopefully
the fact that the two biggest explosions
in the country were solved within a week
is a deterrent
and the fact that the american public
turned against those people
if you blow up a building we ain't gonna
follow you
i think that's a deterrent i'll have to
answer your question that's buzz because
yes sir
do you like to expand on your
intelligence gathering
uh yeah the question was expand on how
we gather intelligence through sources
through live sources which i think are
the very best
through electronic surveillances
we also have the capability to task nsa
the national security agency to
to monitor
everything that seems to move that they
monitor overseas all foreign traffic
regarding terrorism uh i believe the
very best thing we have is live sources
and the bureau is the best in the world
i think in developing live sources
because you you can control them better
and you re and you really know what the
meanings are like you can listen to a
conversation and you get once you get
you know you think you know what
happened but if you talk to the man it
was in the conversation and said this is
what it really meant i think that's
where our country really went um we went
bad under stansfield turner when he was
the director of cia he he just got rid
of all of our sources and wanted to rely
on satellites and mics
and we didn't have a clue
so it's taken the cia a long time to
come back and use live sources again no
are you scratching are you asking a
question well i was wondering when you
said that you had a lot of leads with
the oklahoma city ball i'm sure a lot of
what leads yes
how do you know
how far to take them i guess how do you
know how valid yeah that's your problem
especially with eyewitness
identifications
because because everybody wanted to help
and everybody saw tim mcveigh
and that became a real problem for us so
we had to verify the eyewitness accounts
were things we could absolutely prove
i mean there were people who had him all
over the place and we knew he wasn't
there so sorting through that stuff is
really it's a monumental task and and a
lot of it's done i mean a lot of you
sort out by the computer system we had
full text retrieval in our computer
systems that could verify like places
like we like we knew we had him on
videotape uh at the mcdonald's at the
fbi building uh right across from fbi
building in oklahoma we had a videotape
of the truck being pulled up at a couple
minutes towards 4 9. things like that so
that's a really good question and it's
very very difficult
especially when it's such a you know
that that picture went out all over the
world and you know my my 22 year old son
looks like timmy bay he's tall then he
has a bear haircut you know i told him
god i might grow your hair up
and you know release where i can
so that's that's a very difficult thing
to do and yes
what's your opinion of the
supposed man that was with timothy
mcveigh
john doe number two
um
i really do believe that john doe number
two was there on the second day of the
truck rental uh we found him interviewed
him he had the ball cap he looked like
the guy i really believe that now there
are people in oklahoma um
who believe that he was a middle eastern
terrorist and i don't believe that
first of all you have to understand who
tim mcveigh was and he didn't like
middle eastern people
because they're not of the air and raise
so i don't believe that i really do
think it was
i think that the guy who who um gave the
rent of the truck confused what day that
guy came i do
could could we be wrong about that yeah
yeah let me we have a couple seconds
here how are we doing
okay um let me tell you about another
plot to blow up the robbery do you know
there were two
back in the 80s remember i talked to you
about jim ellison and carrie noble and
peter wayne snail they were going to
blow up them rod building
and they had a plot they were going to
use mortars and they're going to blow it
up with martyrs and a couple of things
intervened we put them in jail
peter wayne snell uh was a vicious
murderer he uh robbed a pawn store and
uh punch-up and he killed the clerk
why do you think he killed him
he was jewish that's okay
it was justification because he was
jewish he wasn't
didn't make any difference he also
killed a black arkansas state trooper
during the course of the csa siege
we used a man from oklahoma a place
called alum city to help us negotiate i
need to throw that in so you can put in
perspective
we put everybody in the csa camp in
prison
okay
peter wayne snell
was executed remember he planned to blow
up the wrong building peter wayne snail
was executed on april 19 1995.
is that a coincidence i don't know
jim ellison who was a commander at csa
who planned to blow up the raw building
lives in a lower city now with robert
millar
tim mcveigh made phone calls to alum
city before the mine
i get called jill's thing about that
is that a conspiracy no is it
coincidence i don't know i don't know
the answer to that
the prosecutors that did the case say
absolutely we got everybody were
absolutely positive i don't know i'm
just an fbi 31 years experience i don't
know they're smarter than me all lawyers
are smarter than me
but that's a coincidence i mean
and you can take this thing forever
kerry noble who was the second in
command to csa who was a friend of peter
weinstein those guys he is absolutely
convinced it came out of a long city
i'm not
i just don't know by the way last week
carrie noble was at my house drinking
coffee on sunday afternoon he went to
jail for seven years and we've become
very close friends scares the daylights
out of my kids every time he comes over
but he's a he's a changed man he now
lectures fb on what it's like to be
chased by the hrt and that kind of stuff
he's really turned his life around it's
kind of interesting he came to my house
one night for a dinner party and uh he
said the he said the blessing over
dinner and i said that's really
interesting i remember about 10 years
ago you were praying for me to die and
now you're praying over my food it's
kind of a kind of a funny twist of faith
yes sir you give quite a bit of time in
your book here to uh another denver uh
personality alan berg yes sir speak
about that a little bit
um alan berg was i mean you probably
know more about him and i do he was a
very controversial in some uh regards a
jewish talk show host who apparently was
really smart
and you what i understand from our
investigation is just to beat the
daylights out of some of these guys he'd
get on there and just ridicule him and
the order murdered him
uh they shot him as he came home one
night is our call with a bag of
groceries and
matthews and let's see um yarborough
and uh as i recall bruce cal pierce
executed now think about these these
guys are aryan
warriors and they walk up and they gun
down a
harmless
jewish talk show host who is armed with
a bag of groceries
now i know warriors
i even know dick marcinko
they ain't warriors
of course they were all they're all
apprehended they're all in jail for it
but um that was a very vicious attack on
a man who was exercising his first
amendment
rights
that case was solved rather rapidly
which was good uh
then perhaps just to kudo your way
i'm very pleased that the bureau
let you put out a book like this this
soon
i think
and i would encourage others uh
that have that type of american
pro-american story
to do that and so you're to be commanded
thank you thank you your supervisors
thank you the rest of that world well it
was not exact without struggle uh we did
fight and um but in the end i got a nice
letter saying uh we approve your book
congratulations go for it but thank you
thank you i appreciate that we have time
for one more question
yes sir um you've already had yours i'll
talk to you afterwards
uh kind of a multi-part question
as a local cop
one of the things i see increasingly is
the federalization of law enforcement
yeah
and i won't blame ruby ridge on the fbi
or i mean a waco and the fbi because
that was an atf debacle
but do you think some of the
uh for lack of a better word the
blunders
the bureau has suffered
where it's gotten a black eye maybe
those incidents would have been better
handled by local law enforcement
absolutely i think so um i think it's a
big mistake to make every crime a
federal crime
i think the fbi does good in certain
areas we where us and the dea do great
in drugs and not talking about the
street level my son's a cop by the way
never wants to be an fbi he'd never be
an fbs he loves being a cop i'm going to
see him tomorrow i can't wait he's out
in portland um but i i completely agree
we do deadbeat dads
you know what the guys that skip out on
their payments can you imagine
i mean
the way they train us i got to go chase
some dead big dads could didn't pay
child support i think they should pay it
but i think that's a state deal
yeah carjacking became a federal crime
because of the death of pamela bassou in
maryland which reached all this thing we
should do carjackings where it's a big
organization and we want to use the
federal statutes on ricoh and some of
the other things hobzac to get really
heavy heavy time but we shouldn't do it
by ourselves we should do it within a
task force and where i like to see us
work is in a violent crime task force
where we have gangs and some of these
gangs are big
and they're very sophisticated
the way the fbi works best is is putting
local cops and fbi agents and let us
finance a task force and let and let the
agents and the cops pick out what we
need to be doing and do it and sometimes
it's good and going to federal court
sometimes just not
but i think we have to work as a team
and get us out of these bs violations we
have absolutely no no nothing to do and
on the ruby ridge we should never been
on ruby ridge
i mean randy weaver's crime a man who'd
never who was not a criminal his crime
was sawing off a shotgun a quarter inch
too short
what kind of effect did that have on the
crime problem in america i don't care
about sawed-off shotguns
but this whole thing on ruby ridge all
the things that happened to all of us
the aftermath blonde haruchi's deal all
that came over a shotgun
that was a quarter inch too short you're
right we should have been doing that and
i frankly don't think there should be an
atf
i don't think they should have i don't
think they should be in existence i'd
like to take the atf agents and bring
them to work with us on drugs and
violent crime and things that matter and
not chase guns
i think in my the way i look at it and
i've got great friends in the atf bill
buford is a man i admire more than
anybody in law enforcement atf agent
arkansas
i'll tell him you shouldn't be you
shouldn't be just chasing guns chase
criminals
that use the guns don't chase guns give
them to us and let's get get rid of them
that way i know we'll never have a waco
okay thank you you guys are a lot of fun
i appreciate it
danny coulson has retired from the fbi
he co-authored this book no heroes with
time magazine correspondent elaine
shannon it was published in march by
pocketbooks a division of simon schuster
free house judiciary committee hearing
on the incident also testifying is then
fbi director william sessions and others
as we said we'll show you attorney
general reno's news conference in just a
moment the attorney general was asked
about this video released thursday by
the fbi which was taken by surveillance
aircraft on april 19 1993 above the
branch davidian complex in waco texas
the radio traffic you're about to hear
reflects the request for and approval of
the use of military rounds to attempt to
penetrate an underground bunker near the
compound
one
relative safety uh utilizing the vehicle
for cover an attempt to get
are you saying he can penetrate the
black covering over the construction on
the uh green side
he thinks he can get his position here
although if you're utilizing track
recover and attempt to penetrate it with
uh military rounds
roger of course if there's a water
underneath it's just going to extinguish
some but we can try it
just simple you can try it
yeah
again this is 1993 surveillance video
released yesterday by the fbi the voices
you heard were those of fbi hostage
rescue team agents during events in waco
texas in april 1993.
in just a moment we'll show you today's
news conference by attorney general
janet reno at which she comments on the
video release and additional new
evidence recently discovered
then we'll take you back to a 1993 house
judiciary committee hearing nine days
after the branch davidian incident at
which the attorney general and then fbi
director william sessions testified
tomorrow at noon eastern will re-air
portions of 1995 waco hearings with
testimony from fbi agents and officials
that will continue in our overnight
schedule saturday night at 2 am
and next tuesday you can see attorney
general reno's testimony at those same
1995 waco hearings
now the eight for pricing information
and to request a tape
in a place called waco david thibodeau
writes about meeting david koresh and
becoming a branch davidian
as one of the few survivors he gives a
first-hand account of the 1993 events
that led up to the fire at the compound
in waco texas
book people and independent bookstore in
austin texas hosted this 80-minute
discussion
okay
well everyone i want to say again thank
you very much for coming tonight we're
very excited to have david thibodeau
here uh he's going to be speaking and
then uh we'll take some of your
questions for about half an hour uh
please help me welcome david thibodeau
[Applause]
i'm used to standing when i do these
things but this this would be a
different form
wow thank you so much all for coming out
it's a pleasure to be here tonight
in the live music capital of the world
austin texas
and i'm very proud to be in austinite
now and uh
it's different when you do i've done
these for the last couple weeks then
quite a few signings and it's just it's
just different when you
see your your your crowd here
from uh from the place that you live so
thank you for coming out i guess i'll
start off at the beginning i'm gonna try
to keep it brief sometimes i tend to get
a little sidetracked because in this
issue
there's so much to cover and one of the
problems
um i guess i'll start with one of the
problems with with the uh with the
trials that occurred in san antonio six
and a half years ago
up to the senator danforth uh
in in inquest that's going to be
occurring on
um
coming up in the next couple months
is the trials in san antonio focused on
the events of february 28th and the batf
attack
and basically they tried the people 11
of them
on
on conspiracy to commit murder charges
which everyone was acquitted of that
charge several of them were found guilty
of a lesser charge of aiding and
abetting voluntary manslaughter but due
to a little snafu
um well the the the jury was given a
94-page rule book that they had to
follow in the trials
i see a lot of people shaking their head
i mean a jury should be able to hear all
the evidence that's the way i view it
and they shouldn't be limited by a
federal judge saying this is what you
have to do when you make your decision
so
they were basically five of them were
found guilty uh of having a well
nine of them were found guilty of having
a firearm during what the the judge
called the commission of a crime for
february 28th and that is when the betf
attacked you had a gun in your hand
basically you went to jail some of them
were in jail for 40 years on a weapons
violation that the jury
felt was thrown out according to the
count 3
aspect of the verdict
so
i have talked to sarah bain the head
jury iv woman that was there that day
at the trials in san antonio and she
said
had we seen all the evidence that we had
seen since the trials that the judge
suppressed from us we would have
acquitted everybody on all charges
so basically right now there's seven
political prisoners some of which have
been under very harsh conditions in in
various institutions throughout the
country um some of them are there for 40
years on a weapons violation that the
jury was thrown out and i think that's a
very important point to make the whole
problems with the trials in san antonio
was the fact that the judge focused only
on february 28th
and my concern is
with the
hearings of danforth he's only going to
focus on the events of april 19th and
what happened at the back of the
building and of course the infrared
videotape that we'll be discussing a
little later
so the big problem that i have is you
can't really understand waco you can't
understand what really happened there
unless you handle it from a to z and you
cover everything in between
because
what the fbi did when they set up their
speaker systems
it was so crass
the light systems
literally the psychological effect
of here's a guy that they say david
kresh
is a person that's very unstable and you
have a bunch of religious wackos is what
we've been called consistently
throughout the course of the 51 days
and
their plan is to play loud music
the sounds of rabbits being slaughtered
tibetans monk chant chanting
um just various taking the phone off the
hook for 48 hours at a time so their
plan was to make us even more unstable
that doesn't make a lot of sense to me
so the point i wanted to make in opening
up is i hope senator danforth former
senator danforth and i hope that um some
of the the civil cases
and the uh senate inquest that's going
to be taking place we'll focus more than
just on april 19th because you'll never
be able to see the big picture unless
you focus on the whole thing from a to z
so with that i'd like to start off by
saying i'm david thibodeau and i grew up
in bangor maine
and ever since i was a little kid and i
first picked up drumsticks i knew what i
wanted to do with my life i wanted to
play music
and so i did everything in my power to
make that dream happen once i graduated
from high school i got a job i started
saving up to go to los angeles i played
in several bands came home from school
every single day and played the drums
and just lived in that little world
literally closing my eyes and seeing
thousands of people in front of me and
just getting off on the rush of what
that would be like every day and that
was my only goal in life setting out in
this whole adventure
and i ended up in hollywood finally and
i graduated from music school
and
over the course of the next six months
or so i was playing in a band out there
and i was had a dead end job i was
working at man's chinese theater at the
gift shop and i had one of those stupid
red smocks on
and i remember one day i was so
frustrated with my life i
i looked up to the heavens
uh or at least i looked up to the
ceiling of man's shiny theater
and i said lord what are you saving me
for you know when can i finally meet the
people that i'm supposed to meet so i
can start my life so i can do what i
want to do instead of being in this rut
and i said you know just please make
this happen i know that i'm here for a
reason i know that i'm not here just
aimlessly walking through life in
hollywood living you know
living with a bunch of guys in a
one-room apartment
and two days later i was late for a band
rehearsal i had my band members with me
and uh i made them literally made them
they didn't want to do it i made them
stop at a guitar center on sunset
boulevard so i could buy some drumsticks
and when i did i walked into the
electronic drum room which i had a very
bad habit of doing they always had a kit
set up and i would always sit down and
play it and there were these two
gentlemen that were standing there
looking at the electronic drum set
and they asked me if i was a drummer
so i was and i sat down i played the
drums for them they said that they would
be interested in perching this kit and
they wanted to hear it so i sat down and
played for three minutes or so and when
i got up uh the guy there was a guy in a
business suit and there was a guy in a
t-shirt with ragged jeans it was just
kind of really laid back
and the guy the suit if you will
approach me and he says wow you know
pretty good drummer we're we're looking
for one for our band would you be
interested in getting together with us i
said yeah sure i'm in a band now but i'm
always interested to play with different
people
and so they handed me their card
and i looked at the card and on the back
of the card there was all this religious
scripture i was revolving around the
kingdom to be set up i didn't realize
that at the time nor did i really care
i saw the religious scripture and i
handed the card back to him i said well
thank you very much you know i'm the
spiritual person but i don't believe
that
i'm really looking to be in a christian
band at this time
and that's when steve piped up and he
said well you know it's like this
we're not really a christian band what
we are is we've studied the scripture
i've been all over the world with this
guy david kresh and he introduced david
and david didn't really say too much he
just kind of sat back and let steve do
most of the talking he said i've been
all over the world and um you know i've
we've studied this this this book they
call the bible we've ripped it apart and
we just have some insights to it you
know really all we want to do is play
music right now and uh you know we do
have a message that is revolving around
the scripture but you know that's really
uh
not our focus right now we just would
like to play music with you and say okay
i kind of left with the attitude don't
call me i'll call you
and a couple days later you know things
weren't going so well and i just started
thinking about this and i was really
impressed with the suit
and he was a very good orator you know
steve schneider and and um and david was
just real quiet and you know kind of
mysterious he said a few things
and then i gave him a call and uh over
the course of the next uh day or so we
got together and went they had a
property in pomona which about 45
minutes out of hollywood and we went
there and uh played some music i thought
david was a great guitarist i met their
artist cliff sellers who had paint
airbrushed guitars
and it was just uh they seemed to really
have it together they're very
professional and that's something that i
liked over the course the next couple
months i got to know him a little better
and specifically steve schneider would
come over with some of the guys and give
us studies because they said you know we
want to show you some of these things
out of this book and i remember the
first night i had my roommates and they
were all sitting around i said hey i
forgot to tell you guys but i have a
couple people coming over for we're
going to have a bible study i hope you
don't mind
and they were like why didn't you tell
us you know i could have gotten a date
with my girlfriend or we could have gone
out to the movies or something you know
and they were literally reaching for
their coats when the knot came at the
door and it was steve schneider
and uh jamie casillo greg summers just
several of the younger guys were there i
even think cliff was there let's see
peter was there peter hipsman
and um
you should have seen the look on their
faces when the door knocked and i opened
the door and they all came in and said
hey you know you're all ready and they
had a they had a 12 pack of beer with
them
and all of a sudden my roommate said
well you know i think we can stay for a
few minutes and
listen to what they got to say
and i just remember when steve schneider
sat down and and he had this one inch
margin bible you know we can make your
notes and he opened that book
and every page that he had
had all the script had all these cross
references color coded in it on every
single page it was just absolutely
filled with cross references
instantly i was impressed because i
could see that these i was never
impressed and i hope i don't offend
anyone here but i was never oppressed
with the tv preachers and the hypocrisy
of
of not all but several organized
religions you know i was always more
into the small movements of religion
that seem to be a little more pure in
heart and as they grow and of course it
becomes a money financial institution it
tends to lose focus a little i think a
lot
and so i was impressed with the way that
they ripped the bible apart and they had
really done their research and studied
and that's what impressed me was the
fact it was more of an intellectual
study than it was an indoctrination or
they never came off preachy that would
have turned me off instantly
and so they went through their study and
two hours later i'm looking around my
roommates are still sitting there i i
to me that was an act of god
and i remember over the course of the
next couple months we got together
several occasions and head studies
then one day david kresh invited me out
to waco texas a place called waco
and he said
i'm gonna be
we're going out there for passover which
is one of the two week periods of the
festival periods of god in the scripture
and he said literally there's going to
be hundreds of people from all over the
world that are going to be coming to
learn these truths
he says you're going to meet you know
people that are carpenters people that
are architects people that
have gone to seminary school people that
are pastors in their own churches in
england
i said well that sounds kind of
interesting and he asked me if i wanted
to go and at the time i was pretty
adventuresome and i did
so we pulled up to mount carmel and i
took a look at all the the
single buildings that line the place up
and i just thought it was one of the
strangest places i've ever seen in my
life
and we got there a week early so we
started playing some music and stuff and
people started arriving and i started to
question these people why are you here
what do you hope to gain from this and i
must have talked to 10 or 15 different
people at various times and they
basically all told me the same thing
they said that
they had learned more
about the scripture from this person
david correction they had their whole
life studying on their own or being
pastors or going to seminary school
and just like everyone seemed to have
the same testimony so i wanted to see
what it was going to be you know what it
was really all about i always knew that
there was a mystery to this book i
always wondered in my life
how come so many thousands and thousands
of people have died put their lives on
the line and sacrificed their lives for
this scripture throughout the course of
time
it has a power to it
and um
over the course of that two weeks i
remember the very first study and and
the reason that i'm relating the stories
because a lot of people ask me you know
how could you follow someone like david
koresh
people say this but they have no idea
who he was all they know is what they've
heard
and they've made their judgments because
i've heard some very bad things
well there's always two sides of the
story in this case there's i think
hundreds of sides to the story
um the first study that he gave he he
had a bib he had a bible and he held it
up he says most people see this book and
they see two pieces of cow leather with
a bunch of pages in between
and they spend their life trying to
unravel the mystery or get some kind of
basic truth out of it he says no when i
see and he held up to his forehead he
goes when i see it i see it
panoramically
as if it's happening now from genesis to
revelation
right now as it's happening
i mean that was pretty tough pill to
swallow but over the course of the next
two weeks we had studies that would last
anywhere from 10 to 12 hours a day
and
they were they were very entertaining i
mean it wasn't something that i found
dry i mean i actually started to become
involved and become part of this world
of the scripture and it was something
that i started to embrace
and i literally over the course that two
weeks came to believe and you know i
wasn't even 100 percent sure if this was
the final message or this was the
messenger but i came to believe that
david did see the scripture that way
panoramically as if it had happened as
if he had been there
and when he gave a study he gave a study
with
literally the looks on the faces of the
people that are written in the scripture
so you could actually see the sarcasms
you could see the nuances of the
communication that was taking place in
the bible where before i could never see
that reading it on my own it just made
me go to sleep frankly
and so um it was something that held the
interest
i think one thing that i saw david do on
several occasions and he did this with
me as well after that two or three week
period when everyone started to leave
and played music a little more and you
know i was trying to absorb all this
stuff he says what i want to do now is
um you know i i want you to be my
drummer i want you to be in the band but
you've have now have the basic
foundations of the seven seals the first
five seals if you will
and uh what i want to do is would you
like to go to maine and see your parents
absolutely i'd love to go see my parents
you know it's on him right why not
and my head was spinning frankly i
definitely needed some time to absorb it
all
and so he sent me up to me and he said
you know take a couple weeks take a
month take whatever time you need if you
find that you know and ask people about
these seven seals go to preachers go to
rabbis go to anybody
and if they have some insight into the
seals let me know i might be interested
but if i'm pretty sure you're going to
find that no one even knows what they
are or the most people going to say that
there's a mystery and we're waiting for
christ to come back before those things
can be revealed
if they don't know and you want to learn
more
come on back you know we want to have
you in i said well okay that's pretty
fair well over the course of the next
month i i went to maine and i got a call
one day about a month later and i was
putting it off because i i was convicted
at this point i mean i had known that
there was something there but at the
same time i didn't really want to
entirely give up my life and just go and
live on what we call the ant hill
because we got the texas fire ants here
and there's several um at mount carmel
so
i ended up going back and i ended up
going back to hollywood and
several events took place if you will
i'm going to kind of wrap it up real
quickly here
within six months we ended up
being in hollywood we ended up moving to
mount carmel there's several events that
took that took place that are really
important but because i really want to
get to questions you're going to have to
look it up in the book
but a lot of very very interesting very
deep things happened to me during that
period of time that i was in hollywood
and a lot of them revolved around a
certain friend of mine
who was in a band as well out there and
uh crash had some insights that
literally just just just blew me away
that he could know this about my friend
and all these things were factors
so we ended up moving to mount carmel
about a year before the batf attack of
february 28th and throughout that year
we tore down the little houses and we
started to build up the major complex
there called mount carmel and the big
building that everyone saw
we built a swimming pool
uh david kresh and steve schneider would
steve wouldn't he was you know a
brilliant salesman i mean steve
basically would negotiate all the deals
we ended up getting go-karts building a
track
the children some of the younger boys
got small dirt bikes and would that we
would all go out and play on the track
what ended up happening is
through a person that i met in waco and
we had ties in waco i mean this wasn't
some community that was just totally uh
within themselves out in the middle of
nowhere i mean uh
the branch of visions or
what what became to be known as the
branch of indians actually the branch of
indian stemmed from an earlier group
that had lived out there had been there
for 60 years
david koresh was the third of what
people out there called inspired or if
you will a prophet and he was the third
one to get the complete vision of the
seven seals before them there was hodith
and lois rhoden
who preceded david so it wasn't just
some fly by night group that david
started it was something that built off
a foundation of several years and there
were several people that had been there
almost from the inception of it who tell
me stories uh
david first came on the scene his name
was vernon howell when he first came on
the scene he was basically he could
barely formulate a sentence i mean he
had a great knowledge of the scripture
but he was no order he was great with
working on cars but he stuttered he had
a stuttering problem and literally after
1985
when he
claimed to have his vision of the seven
seals he started to
talk
very clearly very concisely and it was
almost like an overnight transformation
that a lot of the older people there
told me about which i thought was very
impressed impressive
well i ended up meeting someone whose
father was henry mcmahon who was a
licensed firearm dealer that ran a place
called hewitt handguns and was right
outside of waco and hewitt texas
and henry basically started to get
studies from david
and started to learn a lot of things and
thought that you know david was someone
that was very special someone was very
inspired and he started to take david to
gun shows i mean that was kind of his
forte
and through these little excursions of
going to gun shows here in texas they
david and paul and steven schneider
found out a couple things they found out
that because of all the
legislation's coming down the pike a
2-2-3 round is going up in value that
ak-47s are going up in value from 500 to
2000 overnight and you started to they
started to actually take on the business
of going to
to gun shows and doing everything
legally having the yellow sheets on all
the firearms and
basically buying and selling legally
there were people inside that made
vests hunter's vests that were sold at
the gun shows as well as several other
uh things that occurred
and um one of the things that ended up
happening is as we were building the
pool that summer
uh helicopters started to fly by really
low and you know we could tell they were
taking pictures we knew that you know we
were being watched i mean you know a big
group of people out there in the middle
of nowhere it's pretty strange according
to most people which most americans tend
to forget that america was founded on a
bunch of
religious extremists that came to this
nation and
and started to put together the
constitution and i think it's important
to remember that the ba the baptists
were scourged in the streets
when they first came and i'm sure a lot
of you know about the history of the
mormons
and what they had to suffer when they
were first starting with with their
particular doctrine
and so i it comes from a long foundation
of i guess killing or beating up what
you can't understand or what you don't
want to understand or
specifically what the establishment
can't understand
and
from this point that henry came into
being that's when all the gun
stuff started happening
a couple other interesting things took
place
well henry mcmahon one day gave us a
call and he had been raided by the batf
the bureau of alcohol tobacco and
firearms
and they were going through all his
yellow sheets and they started to ask
henry and davey aguilera the batf agent
headed up the whole investigation you
start to ask a lot of questions about
david koresh to henry and he says well
henry says you're investigating me why
are you asking all these questions about
crush you should investigate crash or go
speak with him so henry excused himself
and went to the kitchen and this all
came out the trials in san antonio and
everything i i'm saying
i can prove
it has happened
so david uh
henry mcmahon went into the other room
he got the phone and he called david and
he said david
the batf are here and they're rating me
they're going through all my yellow
sheets and asking me a lot of questions
about you
what do you want me to do
and chris said well why don't you have
them come on out to the property
this is about two to three months before
uh february 28th haven't come out to the
property they can check out any of the
yellow sheets on any of the firearms
that we purchased they have any
questions better yet put them on the
phone i'll speak to them henry mcmahon
went to the other room and he said i
have david crush on the phone
he wants to speak to you he's invited
out to the property and davey aguilera
shook his head and waved his hands above
his head like this
he didn't want to speak to david he
never wanted to ever try to make any
contact with david other than when the
when the
four individuals ended up moving across
the street which was going to bring my
next story
these four guys move across the street
one day out of the blue
this is about a month or so before the
the initial attack
and when they did this there was um
you know four guys move in
a two-room house
they bring in all this heavy equipment
you know they don't move in furniture
but they move in this equipment and they
start to set up their little
surveillance
over the course of the next couple days
well there was an event that took place
i think is pretty funny
um greg summers at the request of david
brought over some beer and some pizza to
the guys across the street to kind of
welcome welcome welcome them to the
neighborhood
seeing how there's only two people in
the neighborhood you know why not make
friends with your neighbors
and so they knocked at the door and they
said yeah we're from across the street
we just want to bring you guys over some
beer and some pizzas and say hi and this
hand came out the door grabbed the pizza
pulled the pizza in and slammed the door
and said thank you
i got my girl in here
so that's pretty strange you know i mean
obviously either he had his girl in
there there definitely wasn't something
they did not want us to see
so over the over the course of the next
week or so they did come in and finally
make contact and a guy named robert
rodriguez or robert gonzalez the one's
an alias was his real name i think
rodriguez was the name of was the alias
came over and started to make contact
with david and basically over the course
of the next uh he had nine to 13
contacts with david i believe it was
nine and david instantly started giving
him studies robert was a man that was
raised catholic and
as david would give him studies i could
see
this look on his face i mean it was like
he was he was starting to get his
question answers like myself and all the
people that were there literally david
could answer all our questions from a
scriptural standpoint you know steve
schneider and wayne martin and paul
fadded they tried to rip them apart for
months before they joined this community
and they couldn't do it
there was an interview that this this
individual did with the washington times
i believe it was right after the right
after the well april 19th and the place
burned the ground
and he said a couple of very interesting
things one was that the interviewer said
was david close meaning were you close
to being in the community or being
converted if you will he said yeah i was
close
i think that's very interesting he said
in in other statements that the agents
had to shake him up and say you're here
to do a job you know you're not here to
get converted robert come on
he also said that when the fbi took over
the fbi said what can you tell us about
david what's going to happen next and
robert said well give me a bible i'll
show you exactly what he's going to do
next from that scripture
and the fbi looked at him like he was
crazy
they wanted nothing to do with it and
then robert said he went out through his
bible wayne and you know
was very sorrowful he lost four friends
that day
and
i think it's really interesting that the
batf i mean robert said he saw no signs
of illegal activity during the time he
was in there and they still went forward
with the raid i mean they have an
undercover guy in there why won't they
work with their own undercover agent why
won't they listen to what he's saying
we'll talk about the warrant in a minute
but
after this period of time the waco
tribune herald put out
what they call the seven part series the
sinful messiah series
that was very demonizing it was just a
very harsh piece they didn't ask for our
side of the story at all and they
started to talk about if you if you're a
branch davidian you believe christ lives
on a threadbarion piece of land in the
middle of waco texas and he's
a beer drinking guitar toten gun-toting
preacher
that's how it started that's like the
headline right and it's the first of a
seven part series because so you can
imagine that we pretty much saw
that something was about to take place
now the problem i have i have several
problems but the first of many problems
that i have with the batf attack is
number one when you look at the warrant
and rip it apart
basically they went to the judge judge
green under false pretenses
they relied on information that was the
child abuse information and allegations
came from a guy named mark bro who
studied under david for several years
and then left
they relied on information that was five
years old under federal law when you go
to a judge you have to have current
information at least six months old
or at the most six months old before you
can get a warrant against someone
davey aguilera who headed up that report
said that kresh was receiving upper and
lower receivers to put together fully
automatic ak-47s
that's a batf agent
the problem with this scenario is an
ak-47 is a solid body firearm you can't
get an upper and lower receiver for it
therefore how can you put it together
make a fully automatic weapon
that's an ak-47
and now this is in the warrant
this is what they went to the judge with
to get a knock search warrant which the
judge signed he gave him a knock search
warrant
now i don't know what your
interpretation of a knock search warrant
is but mine is you go up to the door you
knock on the door and you serve the
warrant you go and get your evidence
okay
they chose to serve a knock search
warrant with what they called operation
trojan horse and the code word for
operation trojan horse to go down was
show time literally it's show time
now they chose to serve this warrant
with two cattle trailers pulling to the
front of the building
four or five atf teams one team was to
go to the back of the building another
team was to go up to the side of the
building and go into what they thought
was the gun room or the evidence room
and everyone's seen the pictures of that
atf agent trying to break the window and
get into that door jump into the door
and and then you see all this fire
coming at the atf agents and you see the
guy go down the ladder
another group of atf agents was to go to
the front door and quote unquote serve
the warrant that no one ever saw in
their hand and was sealed up
when they when the fbi had asked for
that warrant they said it was all shot
up in the raid
so we can't produce that warrant
literally that was sealed up until after
april 19th no one ever saw that search
warrant
another group of atf agents was to go to
the front of an area where we had a
penned up area with with
five alaskan malamutes fawn and are four
pups and their job was to suppress the
dogs
now
there was an atf and i'm gonna call it
exactly what it is it was an atf
propaganda film that was put out it was
played on hbo i saw it on court tv of
all things the other day i mean on court
he was absolutely disgusted
i'm sitting ready to go on hardball and
there is this this movie is called in
the line of duty
and uh the reason i bring this up is
because phil penegroff the man that
wrote that
was given all this false information
put this movie out it was made
during the siege before april 19th this
was already in production was basically
completed
he has since come forward and said since
he's seen all this information that the
government didn't get him when he was
making this particular film
you can call it that
he has said that um
that it's wrong he
he did a five-page letter and came to
one of our memorials and apologized to
all of the survivors profusely and in
his five-page letter he likened himself
to i hope i get his name right lenny
ruthenstahl who was the woman who did
all the hitler documentaries
and once once lenny went into poland and
saw what hitler was really doing and
what the nazis were all about she pulled
out and all of a sudden became really
really quiet
well this guy
with much shame likens himself to her
because he made a propaganda film and
the reason i bring this whole little
story up is because in their
film the f the atf agents go up to the
pendup area where the dogs are with fire
extinguishers and they start spraying
the dogs let me tell you they didn't
have fire extinguishers that day they
shot those dogs in cold blood
from the time from the trial testimony
some of the testimony indicated that the
very first shots may have been fired at
the dogs in the penned up area from the
atf agents
this is all happening simultaneously
while there's three helicopters in the
back of the building that are supposed
to be there for support coming into the
back of the building shooting at the
building according to several eyewitness
testimony i personally saw the evidence
of the bullet holes that came from had
to come from the sky they were in the
ceiling with literally sheetrock hanging
down
um i saw they shut up our water tanks i
literally got on my knees and i looked
through
the the uh entry in the exit wounded
the bullet came from right where the
side right where the the tank is uh
conclave
and you can see the bullet hole where it
came into where it came out and at an
angle you could see it was fired between
the two towers that we had out there i
was fired from the air absolutely
that's the one that killed winston blake
so
my point
they choose they chose to serve this
warrant like like a dynamic entry style
or a no knock search warrant i mean
they're already breaking down windows
while they're coming up to serve the
warrant now the atf has claimed
profusely that it was an ambush
that they were outgunned
well
if we were a group of if you will
quote-unquote cultists that wanted to
kill the babylonians or kill federal
authorities and we had fully automatic
weapons and we had
50 caliber machine guns and we were had
had 45 minutes
where we knew that they were coming and
we were laying wait for him i'm here to
tell you unless we're terrible terrible
shots and all blind not one of those
agents would have walked off that cattle
trailer it was simply never part of the
plan there was no plan
the agents that died the four ancients
that died died 20 minutes into the gun
battle
we have videotape of these agents
standing behind cars
standing up shooting into the second
story of the building where all the kids
are like it's a set of a rambo movie
and yet they've been ambushed they were
outgunned their story from day one never
made any sense
two pieces of evidence i'm going to
bring up really quickly one is the front
door
and at that front door
it was very mysterious because the story
from my friends on the inside was that
david crush went to the door
he i had he came down
30 seconds before the shooting began he
said
now they're on their way they're coming
now don't anybody do anything stupid we
want to talk to them we want to work it
out that's we're all about here
he was the front door
and just literally all hell broke loose
i instantly was down on my face
i spoke to several people there at the
front door they all told me the same
story at various times that crash went
to the door he held the door in his hand
he had his arm out he said hold on
there's women chilling here let's talk
about this
the door flies back in his hand from the
velocity of a bullet hitting it he slams
the door and falls back perry jones 70
year old and our man goes down in pain
from a stomach wound
and from that point some of the people
inside started to fire back and defend
their positions
so this door was very important because
we have pictures of it and the two
attorneys
i should say david crush's attorney and
and uh and steve schneider's attorney
actually came in via the tanks one day
actually on two or three separate
occasions and saw the evidence of the
helicopters firing they saw the front
door and they saw that all the bullet
holes were coming from the outside into
the building
now there were two steel doors at the
front of the building one of them was
entered in or metal doors i don't know
if they were steel they were metal one
was entered into the evidence list the
trials of san antonio and the other
wasn't it was conspicuously uh
missing and the defense attorney says
what about these st this this metal door
where is this metal door that had all
the bullet holes in it and all the
prosecuting attorneys could say in their
defense was oh that door must have
disintegrated in the fire
its sister door is entered into evidence
fully intact it's got a couple you know
bumps and knocks and bends from the
tanks running it over but the other door
mysteriously disintegrates in the fire
doesn't make sense
the second little piece of information
that i i want you all to know about
is the fact the atf were recording us
they had cameras
at their surveillance house
running all the time the fbi when they
came in and took over the scene the
first thing they said
was we want all
all the videotape of the early stages of
the raid that you have the atf said we
don't have any videotape of the early
stages of the raid i'm afraid all of our
cameras malfunctioned
it becomes very convenient i mean you
know you could say you can say that i'm
just making all this up it's it's all a
matter of record it's all at the the
trials in san antonio you know i have a
website we're making an informational
site which is the name of the book a
place called waco.com i'm gonna have the
reports on the cs guess i want to make
the evidence available i think
that we've been lied to enough yeah for
the last six and a half years we've been
lied to consistently
and it's time to lay it on the table i
mean
if you will
david kresh myself you've had all of our
dirty laundry exposed why can't the
government do the same thing and and say
well let's
you know i think the american public is
can take it i think we can take the
truth and i don't think it should be
suppressed from us i think that's why we
have a constitutional nation i mean i
was raised very patriotically i remember
reading in the history books valley
forge
you know how our forefathers the people
that died so we can have this kind of
freedoms that we have in this country
have a constitutional foundation
and all the people that went off to
vietnam they didn't even know why
and died for us
and yet
our government can pull this on us it's
just a terrible thing you know it's a
terrible thing and all i've ever said
since day one is let's lay it all out on
the table
well as you can see this is going to
create an atmosphere of mistrust
which of course it did and over the
course of the next 51 days the fbi takes
over
and uh
you know we felt that we'd have a better
time with the with the fbi than we did
the atf
a lot of things happen they set up the
speaker systems they started used as
psychops
and they actually consulted um russian
specialists so they could make sure to
get the best cyclops and i guess they
figured we'd be like uh was it noriega
when they uh when they went into
panamani was he was holding out and they
started to play rock and roll music
well the day they set up the speaker
system the very first thing they played
was an old alice cooper album
hey that just delighted me you know and
jamie and some of the younger guys were
like excellent started calling in for
requests you know hey you know the new
def leppard album came out we're in a
siege you think he can play that for us
they weren't too happy about that and
that's when they started to change their
tone and they had the roberts being
slaughtered and
the phone off the hook for 24 hours 48
hours whatever it was
and
you know from that point on things just
got worse and worse and worse and
through the course of the fbi
controlling all the media attention and
basically telling you what to think
we became the craziest bunch of
religious wackos you'd ever seen on the
face of the earth that probably deserve
what they got i mean i think
thousands and thousands of people are
coming around now they realized they
have been lied to but i think that the
general american public still holds that
perception
i think that's too bad some of the
people at mount carmel i just want to go
on record as saying with the most
brilliant people i've ever known in my
life
i mean i love to be around people that
are better than me i like to play with
musicians that are better than me
because that's how you grow
you know i like to be around brilliant
people
and they were the most brilliant i've
ever known wayne martin the harvard
educated attorney steve schneider who
taught classes on comparative religions
livingston fagin one of the gentlemen
that's in jail right now who's been in
solitary confinement for years
livingston fagan
he was a pastor of his own church in
england he came over to study and i
think it's important for people to know
the third of the people that lived and
died at mount carmel were black
where's the aclu when we needed them you
know i mean rodney king we had riots in
the streets but no one knew this no one
knew that it was such a diverse group of
people and cultures that existed in
mount carmel it's time people knew
a third of the people were black i mean
that's
you know they can't make us out to be
the racist that they would have liked to
have made us out to ben and some of the
reports came out there was
racial issues and tensions going on
which as it was so was not true
no i'll give you an example and this is
one of the things
that occurred and this is why david was
so misunderstood and people like mark
bro really fought against and there's
lots of reasons but he had a study one
day and he says
i hate black people
and i
you know i was raised pretty liberally i
was pretty shocked
and everyone was quiet
he goes i hate yellow people
and i hate white people
because we here are people of light
we are people that want to understand
the truth and that's what i relate to i
i want people of light around me no
colors
you know no nothing to limit you
and
he would always do stuff like that to
provoke you and make you think and then
there was always a wisdom behind it
and that's one of the things that
impressed upon me
well i'm going to wrap it up to april
19th so we can start taking questions
several things did occur and i just want
people that i i was um reading a lot of
material today
one of the things that i read
uh was by a gentleman who's who's who uh
has a very interesting website and he
did some articles and you have to
understand that when you're in a
building and they're starting to play
interviews from people that hate you
and want nothing to do with you and
think you're strange and think you're
wacko and think that basically you're
unworthy of life
you start to realize that there's no
allies out there there's it's us against
the world
not us against the bad it says against
the world hates us now or they haven't
even gotten to talk to us
and yet
they just soon have us wiped out i mean
we were hearing this
on the speaker systems
and you start to say to yourself you
know people want to say the crush was
guilty of self-fulfilling his prophecy
i think that during the course of that
51 days
with the number of lies that came out
that
the fbi if there was a guidebook they
could follow what not to do in the
situation
that's the guidebook they chose to
listen to they didn't listen to their
psychologist that said don't allow
cresh's message to come to pass pull
back
don't increase the tension but alleviate
the tension
you know they didn't listen to the human
side of it there's a picture in a wake
of the rules of engagement and
where there's this infrared video but
even before that
they have scenes where they're talking
to the negotiators and we sent them out
of tape i mean everyone during the siege
told their story on a videotape and we
sent it out so people would relay and
say you know these are people here that
are religious people they're studying
this book and they have a right to do
that you know
they may be guilty of crimes
but
they're just so demonized that
when we sent them this tape of all the
people and i did a little interview
the fbi chose to suppress that from the
public and it came out in the
congressional hearings
the congressional hearings they asked
about this tape and this the fbi
literally said we felt that if we were
to release this tape to the public it
would create much support and sympathy
for the branch davidians
oh you what you mean it might humanize
us you know
it might take away from your
demonization
you know i mean i give talks and people
say mr tibbett you've done a great job
at hiding your horns and your clothing
hooves you know i mean from the
perception i get from the press it's
what i expected when you came here
i just said um before i move on i want
to there's a quote that i thought was
very profound and it's exactly what has
happened it follows precisely what took
place senator henry clay said this in
the 1800s he said the devices of power
and its minions are the same in all
countries and in all ages
it marks its victim
and denounces it
exciting the public hatred
so it can conceal its own abuses and
encroachments
now i read that i committed it to memory
because it absolutely fit with what
happened here and i'm just going to give
you one more
parable if you will before we talk about
april 19th
i'm a big fan of uh
george orwell's animal farm
i'm very happy to see that it is now a
tnt movie and i'm really looking very
forward to seeing that
but if those of you that are familiar
with this story will know that the pigs
boy that's pretty interesting
equalization that that the pigs were the
power structures of the farm and the
horses were the workers and everyone had
their role
and every time one of the farm animals
questioned the authority of the pigs
the sheep weren't too bright
the sheeple
would break in
to their mantra
four legs good two legs bad four legs
good two legs bad and the whole farm
would break into this mantra and they
would forget the question they would
forget to question the pigs and question
authority because the whole world saying
four legs good two legs bad
and the fbi
over the course of 51 days every single
day consistently federal agents good
brand civilians bad
federal agents good brands davidians bad
and the entire nation joined in
you know and
it's a shame because i feel that we have
the greatest country on the face of the
earth i feel that americans
are incredibly industrial i mean we've
done so much to advance technology and
to advance this world that we're not
smart enough to say i mean there should
have been someone who should stop that
was janet reno's job she said stop
you know these people may be strange
you know but there's two factions here
and there's kids involved
which brings me back to my original
point
in wake up the rules of engagement when
they go in and they show
the negotiators
you get a picture of of what they called
the compound what i called my home they
got a picture of mount carmel they got a
picture of david kresh and the whole
mental attitude was that's the criminal
this is the enemy we need to get him
they should have had pictures of
serenity jones and joseph and isaiah and
startle and cyrus and the and the kids
that were in that building
that negotiators house and the tactical
commander's houses should have been
lined up with pictures of these kids and
the attitude should have been
this is an innocent child we need to do
whatever it takes to get them out of
there and if it means speaking precious
language
and not you know castizing him in the
media and getting two theologians in
that are willing to work with us like
james tabor and phil arnold who peresh
wanted to get his manuscript out too
then that's what we got to do
i think it's unfortunate in such a
brilliant nation
that
the ball was dropped that we lost sight
of that and people are dead now because
of it
you know what i'm not going to talk
about april 19th because i want to open
up to questions i know running out of
time and i know that someone's going to
ask me about it so we'll get into some
really juicy stuff there
is that
yeah incidentally this is being recorded
for c-span it's going to go at nationals
so if you have a good question um stand
up and face the camera and make sure
everyone can hear you yes sir
my my question is the the point you just
made about the uh
the protection of the the children
shouldn't that have been a two-way
street i mean shouldn't the
the rights of the children been or the
obligation of protecting the children
been considered from the davidian
standpoint as well
in terms of well maybe we should drop
this
maybe we should put the children's
safety ahead of our principles and go
ahead and surrender for the sake of the
children
that's a very interesting question it's
a very deep question i know it's one
that that most americans had on their
minds during the course of 51 days
there's a couple things that i think you
need to understand number one is when a
tank drives through your living room you
tend not to go out to those people that
are assaulting you when they start
setting up speaker systems you know you
tend to incorporate as a group and say
this is my family but i think the more
important issue is that 18 people
including men women and children did
exit during the 51 days when
negotiations were going good and keresh
had one negotiator he liked a lot and he
kept asking for him they pulled him off
he's basically a christian guy he wanted
to help he really didn't crash had a
great deal of respect for him they
pulled him off during the course of 51
days they went through i think it was 19
different fbi negotiators you can't
establish a report you can't build a
relationship with someone well that's
going on
so when those 18 children you know men
women and children several of them
children exited the building
one of the things they did is they left
with very some of the parents stayed in
some of them didn't the kids had exited
left with very specific instructions we
have very specific dietary rules we
didn't want our kids out eating candy
bars and running around like kids of the
world if you will we believe that you
know according to our scriptures there's
a certain way these kids should be
raised and that's how they were raised
you know and they were all incredible
children very bright they helped each
other you know they could sit still you
know i mean they didn't run around and
just wreak havoc so the point i want to
make here is that
the fbi sent us in a videotape
and in the videotape they had the kids
drinking soda pop eating candy bars
watching movies and maybe the mothers
wouldn't have those the mothers that
remained inside the fajr men inside were
very upset about this videotape and they
called the fbi
to the through the only one phone line
that we had
and they said you guys are going
expressly against the rules that we set
out when we send our children out i
don't want my kids raised that way what
are you doing why are you doing this
that's number one number two i spoke to
a woman her name was julie martinez who
became a very very close friend of mine
and julie had several children that died
in there
she had
five kids that died and she died as well
and julie came to me one night during
the siege in tears i said what is wrong
she goes i just got off the phone with
the fbi
and they made it sound like if i were to
leave here and i don't know what words
the fbi used with her but i know her
reaction i know she was in tears and she
said they made it sound like if i were
to leave this building i would never see
my kids again they made me feel so cheap
and degrading and dirty for even being
there with david and the people
in the midst of the siege
so you got parents that have a
that that believe they're never going to
see their kids again you know and maybe
it is a selfish thing but when it comes
down to a mother and a child that's
that's a very strong dynamic
that's that's a lot of the reasons why
people stayed in and incidentally
the kids were placed under what they
placed in the only area we had left to
go
most of the kids were at the back of the
building in the concrete structure they
were placed under wet blankets
now i've had federal authorities say
well they were placed under the wet
blankets
you know to make it look like
you guys weren't committing suicide i
think that's the most ridiculous thing
i've ever heard in my life
you know they had no place to go
the back on april 19th was cut off the
media wasn't allowed back there for some
mysterious reason
according to the infrared video tape
that's on wiggle the rules of engagement
and i cite this in my book
several
gunshots were going off at the back of
the building the other tanks now people
want to ignore this
you know people want to say that i'm
crazy and i'm some kind of
conspiratorial not for saying this but
i've seen the video you can go rent it
at blockbuster
we have two explosions the back of the
building six minutes before the fire
begins
we also have several rounds of fully
automatic weapons according to allard
edward allard i believe his name is he
was the one that he was one of the
gentlemen that holds patents on the
infrared video technology says this is
absolutely fully automatic weapons fire
nothing in nature makes this thermal
signature and you can see these little
flashes going off
two different areas and the most amazing
thing to me is as the fire is building
you see the flashes back up you see the
flashes go from from the forefront
closer to the building and start backing
up as the fire is increasing
i wish i were making it up
but i'm not it's it's there
yes sir
i have a question
and
that is that it seems to me that every
action that the
fbi took was directed
at the children
in other words
when they introduced cs
into your
mount carmel
and and this was discussed in the joint
congressional hearings they targeted
the children
they targeted the children with the idea
that their mothers would try to save
them and rush out
they also knew that every adult had a
gas mask
but
gas masks are not made for children
because they don't work their lungs are
not strong enough another area of
targeting the children i think was the
so-called psychological ops program
where they showed the bright lights
and the loud music and the other
unusual sounds
now they claimed
that david koresh
was brutalizing in fact beating quote
beating the children is what janet reno
told her she was beating babies was
there eating babies
and
i think all of us can understand that if
someone is
is
susceptible
to
to violence
then under stress
he's likely to gain in more violence so
these psychological operations again
would target the babies and make them be
beaten more by mr koresh so do you think
that the fbi
had any concern for the children as they
claimed they had
not according to the actions and you
know that's such a great point i'm so
glad that you brought that up during the
course of the 51 days
playing this music i mean you know i'm a
pretty peaceful person
and there was one time during the siege
where it was annoying me annoying me to
the point because when you're tired you
put in earplugs you can sleep you know
through just about anything i mean it's
amazing how the human spirit can adapt
you know we're very adaptable
kids aren't so kids are adaptable but it
will definitely affect children more so
than it would adults
one of the things that just is
absolutely shocking to me is the fact
that they would use these cyclops on the
kids
but more importantly is people have to
understand about the cs gas they use it
the tear gas that they chose to use
internationally and i've done a little
research on the subject internationally
you cannot use cs gas in wartime it is
banned
however there's no law stating we can't
use it against american citizens
according to the dow chemical report on
cs gas it says that cs gas is a riot
control agent that is only to be used
outdoors in an outdoor riot control
situation never to be used indoors
especially it says amongst women and
children especially children whose
respiratory tracts are not fully
developed it could kill them
um failure analysis was a scientific
organization they did a report on the cs
gas and the form
the several the
throughout the course of the six hours
of april 19th how much gas they put in
there in some areas of the building they
put in cs gas it was four times the
amount needed to detour a trained
soldier
let alone what that will do to a little
a little baby
um
boy i don't want to lose my next point
this cs gas is to me was
one of the most barbaric things you
could ever experience
i mean i i can't believe that they could
use that and joyce sparks
who was the individual who was in charge
of the state investigation against
correction the child abuse issues had
come out to the property with his
sheriff's department and questions
questioned you jack harwell the sheriff
of waco we had worked with law
enforcement in the past we invited the
atf we didn't go looking for them they
made it sound like we went looking for
them like we had some plan
she said in an interview that
she urged the fbi not to do the cs gas
plan to wait a minute on the seventh
manuscript urged them and said
well basically you know i
should i get my team ready and they said
no don't worry about it
one time don't worry about it you know
what were they planning one time during
the negotiation
they were asking how many fire
extinguishers we had in there
and did a report said oh we have two
fire extinguishers in the building and
the fbi negotiator said well it's about
time you buy some fire insurance
i mean this might
go figure
which brings me up to my next point real
quick
another interesting terrible tragedy
that occurred occurred a few months
before our attack and then of course is
randy weaver and what happened to his
family in the middle of idaho in the
middle of a side of a mountain and
without getting too detailed i just want
you to know the mentality of these
people this is what happened this
absolutely is it came out in the in the
trials for for his his case
his son sandy uh um
sammy thank you was shot uh his dog
started barking they went down a
marshall shot the dog
sammy shot at the marshall he ran back
and one of the marshals shot and killed
him the next day uh randy weaver put his
his dead son in the shed next to the
house
and was walking
was walking to the main building
and
fbi sniper lon t horyuchi who was one of
the only people that that has been left
on the law so we have a civil case
against the government everyone's all
the people we're going after has been
thrown off except lanti or uichi was a
who was an fbi schneider that was there
that day
lonti oriucci gets vicki weaver in his
sights now he starts opening up on on on
kevin harris and randy as they're
running into the house
they've got the vicky's got the door
open
she's got her baby in her arms and lanti
horyuchi from 200 yards away with a high
power scope shoots her in the face
she falls forward with the baby in her
arms
now the trials during that particular
case it was asked mr horiuchi didn't you
know from 200 yards away that this woman
had a baby in her heart in her in her
arms and he said no i thought it was a
firearm
so i shot her
now i've talked to snipers that
you know i've talked to people that have
been in the military anyone here in the
military was in the military 200 yards
away do you know what you're shooting
with a high-powered scope that's all i
want to know yes you do this gentleman's
waving his head yes there's several
people from all over this country that
have spoken told me the same thing he
knew what he was shooting but here's the
key
the next day
they had speaker systems set up in that
little debacle as well the next day the
the negotiators or someone from the fbi
got on the horn they said randy
what's vicky going to make you for
breakfast this morning
i mean that
that's unfathomable to me to me that our
federal authorities our servants people
that under the constitution have taken
an oath to serve the american public
could do that to anybody i don't care if
he's a fascist or a racist he has
certain rights you know this guy isn't
was never on trial i don't want to get
too far off i just want you to realize
that this kind of stuff happened us all
the time during the course of the 51
days
you know i mean the fbi agents would
moon us you know the the women would be
looking out of the out of the windows
and they'd be mooning us and sticking
their middle finger up at us you know
this is the federal government
yes sir
before the siege before all the troubles
and the siege began describe a typical
day what did you do
were you happy there what were some of
the do's and don'ts rules and
regulations before all the before all
the troubles began
great question um in my book
a place called waco um
i spent a lot of time on these issues
because humanly you go through a lot of
mixed emotions you know you go a lot of
the things where you i questioned a lot
of the things that were going on in
there but basically i understood one
thing you know i mean
some of the stuff that occurred there
was a part of the plan
and i accepted it
um
generally we would play music or build
we spent most of our days building and
beautifying the property you know we
didn't do that because we were planning
on committing a suicide
uh you know we had put in the tracks we
had put in we were building up the house
we had built a pool for ourselves
and uh most of the times were spent
working and in the evenings we would
study we had three square meals
some of the women would prepare and we'd
all come and meet together and the
studies usually occurred in the evening
that was your basic life i mean there
were periods of time where we would
watch movies
everything was on occasion there were
times when everyone would have ice cream
there was times when we would get
burgers
you know and everyone in the community
had a burger but basically people stayed
there people were what they believe
david crush was inspired i believe david
crush was inspired and basically we
spent our lives learning this truth
because according to the truth and i do
get into this very deeply in the book
according to the truth this group was
going to be targeted and was going to be
attacked you know we had prepared for
that at the same time corrected
everything humanly to try to avoid the
situation he also believed there was
another plan and that that plan could go
forward with music and he could reach
the world that way
so it's kind of confusing it's dualistic
and that was one of the hard things in
writing the book it took me several
years to even conceive of writing this
book because i thought it was such a
complicated subject i thought there was
no way i could explain my experience
i still think to this day there's
aspects of the truth that i don't even
get into i do not come
i did not want to get into david's
scripture in this book because i don't
believe that that's my role or that i'm
inspired to do that so i'm trying to
tell the story from my experience
without getting to the hardcore belief
of why we were there and that's what's
very difficult for me in writing this
book and you know i think it's something
that can be researched there are some of
the davidians that have written down
their version of the seven seals and
anyone that's interested can look that
up on on websites i i
i couldn't quote the site right now but
i didn't feel it was my role
but what i did feel was that you know we
were out there studying we were out
there living and we'd bother no one for
60 years
if you really wanted to everyone's
always free to leave that's part of your
free moral agency as a person i mean
generally the group did things together
and the group didn't really depart from
that uh considering that we were one
body
according to several scriptures if one
person does something or does something
that's against the basic rules of the
community it affects the entire
community
and so living under that structure yes
it was a rigid a rigorous structure yes
it was a very monastic lifestyle but at
the same time it's a lifestyle that
everyone chose to live and i could have
left at any time
but consciously in my head i did not
feel that i would be doing the right
thing i don't think that i could have
been left david to do my own thing in
life
and felt that
i could look myself in the mirror and
i've read several books on on psychology
and social proof and and combating mind
control and it's all kinds of different
literature that's out there
you know i think that um for me i just
made the decisions i had to make in life
that this was i was
put here for a reason to go through this
experience for a reason
do you think do you think you'd still be
there if
the troubles haven't started
the question was do i think i still be
there if the troubles haven't started i
can't i don't know i think
i might
but i also think maybe 20 years down the
road i don't know if i could have curb
my humanity that much you know i'm not a
saint you know i'm a sinner like the
rest of us
i think there were people there that
were close to saintliness
i i can't ask that question it's
something that was an experience that i
took day by day
yes sir
um
alex jones a local radio talk show host
has been really keeping this uh issue
alive too over the long before this
latest revelations have been coming out
uh he's leading an effort right now to
rebuild the church on the property up
there do you have anything to do with
that or are you planning on going back
and who owns that property now
great question i'm glad you brought that
up some that i was going to get into
but um
the rebuilding of the church on the
ground where all those people died and
all these atrocities took place i think
it's a beautiful thing in the fact that
so many texans
uh due to alex jones and due to people
that do care and that do know that they
were lied to and do want to know the
truth have come forward and not only
donated their
materials
and and and and money to make this
project happen but they've donated their
time
they've come out on sundays
and they've helped to rebuild this
church so we can have a standing
monument a sanctuary
out there not only for the people but
study
but as a symbol
a symbol that the human spirit will
endure and we are adaptable and as long
as you hold on to your
purpose in life or your sight you don't
lose touch with that with what you
consider to be god what you consider to
be right for you
that you can overcome you know those
people didn't die in vain and i think
it's just so amazing to me especially in
texas here because i mean
how much demonization was there here in
this state during the whole thing i mean
i came out of there and i remember
standing from the grand jury and i felt
mentally raped
the last thing i wanted to do was stand
before
18 people that lived in waco that looked
at me like i was the biggest freak they
ever saw in their life and didn't
believe a word i said that was the most
uncomfortable situation i've ever i've
been cs gassed and that was a little
more uncomfortable in the cias gas
frankly so it's incredible that people
have come and forth come forward and
every sunday they go out there and build
it should be done the next couple months
and
if anyone that would like information on
the building of the structure
they can go to www.infowars.com
to get that information and also
www.rebuildthechurch.com and that's
that's one word and i just really
appreciate everything that everyone's
done one of the goals i have for my
website which is a place called waco.com
is to put the cs gas report and put all
this information the warrants on there
so people can read it from themselves
but also and i just i should have done
this years ago and frankly i was not
proactive before
it took me a lot of time to go through
everything that i had to go through in
this and then finally come out on the
point where i could say okay let's take
them on you know it's gone far enough my
friends were in jail i could be in jail
not that i did anything wrong but i
could be in jail just for political
reasons and i want someone out there
fighting for me
so what i want to do is start a petition
to get the guys out of jail
i mean come on people you know we can
let terrorists go and free them for
political reasons but seven innocent
people that are in jail and the jury you
know i'm sorry
mr establishment mr clinton mr fbi
whoever wants to criticize me on this
one the jury said if they had seen all
the evidence that the judge had
suppressed from them everyone would be
released everyone
that your head jury 4 woman wants a
retrial
you know people like edward allard stone
want a re-trial i mean it's time these
people do not deserve to be there the
wrong people are in jail and you know
what if these people have to go on
suffering and suffering and suffering
then what a terrible terrible state of
affairs we're in here in this country
yes sir
we were listening and using the internet
on this for some time when it was very
active
and over 200 messages were posted on the
board and some of the people were
pathetically
trying to cling to the beliefs that we
had that this is a fair and honest and
nation of laws
it was unbelievable my conclusion was
that the
intent from the outset
was to kill every one of you
there is i've heard nothing
to dissuade me from that there's a
and a los angeles rabbi said that a soul
shall be judged not only by what it says
and does
but by what it sees
and condones by silence
and though much of that has gone on
thank you for being here would you have
a question while you're up
do you but thank you for your call
that's beautiful do you feel that the
atf
had
the plan of literally putting everyone
killing everyone they certainly intended
to kill the children what you said about
the dosage of cs
the children could not have survived
eight consecutive hours of pumping gas
into a closed building it's not possible
the children were dead from that
well what i think is and you're
referring to the fbi i think that the
atf when they when they staged their
raid and they had the helicopters firing
into the building and the agents coming
in firing i think that their goal
was to get koresh i mean i think that's
why they had the helicopters frankly and
what they targeted the area they
believed was his bedroom
you know
while he was jogging because they didn't
want that i mean
that's a great point keresh jogged in
front of his their house every day for
two weeks he was in town all the time
and the fbi when they took over they
said well kresh was isolated he never
came out and all of a sudden people in
waco in the community said hey i saw him
at chelsea's pub two weeks ago
you know i saw he was in my store just
the other day
and he jogged with about five or six of
the guys i did it on a couple of
occasions when i actually felt like i
wanted to try to get into shape
i jogged in front of their house too
two weeks right in front of their
undercover house every single day they
could have gotten not only david crash
but a hardcore group of the young men
around
taking them right there they never
wanted to do it peacefully that's what
blows my mind they i think they wanted
this dynamic entry i think that it's
something that we see all these cop
shows you know we see this this dynamic
entry this force we've got to go in and
get these drug dealers that's the point
i wanted to make
that's the point i wanted to make real
quick they got the helicopters
through
the only way that they could use
helicopters against american citizens is
under a loophole the dea law where it
states that if you are manufacturing
drugs all of a sudden you can use
military equipment against the evil drug
dealers and go in and get them
they said that we had a methamphetamine
lab in there and they went to the
governor and she okayed governor ann
richards okayed the helicopters to be
used because they convinced her and they
convinced the authorities that there was
a methamphetamine lab
david got people off drugs david crush
didn't take aspirin during the seed she
wouldn't take aspirin he never did drugs
they knew that he never did drugs but
they wanted to get the helicopters so
why not lie let's lie you know well not
only lie to the american public you know
hey you know they're sheeple we'll just
lie to them you know they're going to
follow along with what we say but let's
lie to the authorities will lie to the
judge we'll lie to the governor we'll
lie to whoever we can to bring about the
end that we want and that end is very
proud it's very arrogant it's very
what's the word i'm looking for it's
very
male violent you know and that's not
what i thought this country was about
growing up you know and i'll be frank
i was raised with some of the atrocities
that were going on in chile in nicaragua
and panama you know anyone sees the
panama deception knows that there was
something more to what was going on
there
but the fact that it happened here on
the soil it wasn't you know the
government going out into other foreign
lands and making this happen or backing
some rebel group that's going and
committing mass murders
or backing indonesians that went and
killed the east timors the the eastern
time reefs people that happened years
ago years ago
there was a massacre not just happening
now happened several several years ago
it took a man like noam chomsky to bring
this out to the world
it's just very
it's very frightening to me you know and
now it's happening here on the soil and
unfortunately there's a
very large group of americans that'll
sit there and they'll see it happen and
go like well you know those people are
probably bad they're deserving what
they're getting and they don't even
understand what the forefathers built
this constitution on can i take one more
okay um did the children have any
schooling other than like the bibles and
stuff yeah they had homeschooling there
was actually a couple teachers that
lived there one was sherry jewell and
she was a teacher and she she taught the
kids but was more impressively than the
homeschooling and some of them did go to
school for quite some time and then they
were taken out of school
about a year before everything happened
and pretty much was consistently
homeschooling what impressed me most
about these kids that the older kids
would take care of the younger kids and
would actually read books to them
so the sharing in that community was
unbelievable the fact that like a you
know a 13 year old girl would sit there
and read all these little kids and you
know they would just share different
stories and stuff they
it's like the kids educated the other
kids as well as the adults that were in
there so yes there was absolutely
excellent education
for the kids
okay
i'm sorry one second let's look mike
okay
thank you this is my favorite part i
could go on all night
the dynamic entry is a interesting thing
on the one hand batf wanted
to make a show
type of entry
but
much more importantly i think is
who provides the justification for
everything that happened to legal
authority and the provision of legal
authority comes
from the office of u.s attorney a branch
of the justice department and it was
the
assistant u.s attorney
william johnson who participated in
every aspect
every aspect of the event in waco from
beginning to the prosecution and he is
the man
who demanded
he demanded of the batf that the entry
be won
such that mr koresh could not get rid of
any of the end of the evidence he said i
won't prosecute it unless you do an
entry
that doesn't give him a chance
that if you give him a chance to dispose
the evidence i will not prosecute so he
he gave the batf the authority in my
opinion
to the to uh do their so-called dynamic
entry he was behind it and then of
course he was the one involved in that
affidavit he he helped repair it with
all its errors and and misstatements
he gave it to judge green a former
prosecutor himself
and said here here it is
the judge is supposed to look at it as a
neutral party instead he rubber-stamped
it and johnston was involved in every
aspect of it in my opinion if there's
one single person most responsible for
the whole incident it's william johnston
one point i want to make to that and
then we do got to close
is also i i it's pretty amazing to see
the turnaround that johnson has done
and you have to understand that when
mike mcnulty started to go into the
evidence locker which brought this whole
thing back into the press again
when he started to do that he started to
turn a lot of people around like lee
hancock of the dallas morning news who
broke this now lee hancock was never
ever fair favorable to us of the
davidians she wrote some of the most
incredible pieces of that just disgusted
me while this is happening and now she
turned around william johnson wrote a
letter to
to attorney general janet reno and said
there's a lot you don't know that we
have found out that i think the fbi and
people are hiding from you and covering
from you that you need to be aware about
they pull them off
he's no longer working anymore because
they say that they want to use him for a
witness so they can't have him in that
capacity so he's been pulled off of his
official duties basically lost his job
if you will because he made this aware
to janet arena i mean it's very strange
to me so it's like the higher ups i mean
people that were responsible for getting
koresh have done
a lot of them have done a complete
turnaround
and it's just amazing to see people in
power and people in authority people
with prestige coming forward and doing
this turnaround
i mean it just shows
how powerful that this media structure
is
and that this government is in in deceit
and then taking you away from what is
really going on
and so on the one hand yeah i think your
point is valid but i think that at this
point i think mr johnson's doing the
right thing
and i hope that more people do the right
thing i mean there's one thing i can say
i'll end with this
my view of the constitution my view of
my studies of
george washington
jefferson
lincoln
and the document inspired document we
live by called the constitution
is that if you take a no i don't care if
you're a traffic cop are you the
president of the united states of
america my belief is if you raise your
hand and you put your other hand on the
bible and you take an oath to serve the
american public it's what you are you're
a servant
if you take enough to serve the american
public
then you should be held by that oath and
i think if you violate that oath
then i think the punishment should be
severe more severe than
an average citizen who hasn't taken any
oath
that that does a crime they go to jail
right
well if we don't hold our official
authorities responsible
then we're gonna have problems that
we've seen like in oklahoma there are
people within in a nation of 250 million
people
you got some fringes out there you got
some people that don't understand what's
going on some people that can't handle
their anger and they do insane things
and if the government does not be
truthful with us if they do not hold the
people that are responsible for lying to
us and responsible for shooting us and
responsible for for deceiving us if
those people are not held responsible
then there will be more people
that aren't so level-headed that'll do
terrible terrible acts and the problem
is is the government the media
will blame it on constitutionalists
they'll blame it on us radicals like
david thibodeau is that they're speaking
against the government i love this
nation
you know i think we've got the best form
of government on the face of the earth
but i know that we can make it better
you know there should be reason
before there's any act of force
and if there isn't
then then why am i here why why are we
here what you know what why do we still
deceive ourselves and think we're living
by these principles that's all i just
want justice you know i'm not out for
revenge i want justice there are people
that are walking around that are guilty
of lying of killing of shooting of
gassing and there are people that are in
jail that are innocent and until the
paradigm shifts
then we're going to have problems
and i don't want my nation to have
problems anymore
thanks very much
[Applause]
right ladies and gentlemen i have uh
books available right over here at this
table for sale if you would like to get
one signed and if you would would please
uh take a number we are going to call
number groups for the books to be signed
thank you very much
was being terrified by the fbi too have
you ever heard of bernie romero no he
could be on the uh
he could be accused of some of the
oklahoma
it if i gave a friend of yourself
leaflet and my phone here
they kidnapped me
following this discussion of a place
called waco author david thibodeau
signed copies of his book
thanks
hey how are you doing good
nice why didn't you come out
let's fire him up
basically i thought i was going to be
shot if i left
so i preferred to be shot then burned to
death was kind of my reasoning at the
time
i came out of the side of the cameras
could see me so
right that's a crazy amazing thing would
you like me to make this out too to roy
sure
i was in l.a for five years and i'm just
it's such a breath of fresh air it's
like the weight of the world off my
shoulders being here
it's the people it's it's a great town
especially if you're in music
i'm surprised i didn't think i could
live in texas again after my experience
it's great
i really like it
[Music]
so it wasn't about
[Music]
someone gave that to me when it was
working
yeah this is the car that's the card
this is the card that steve schneider
and david crash gave to me that very
first day yeah it's this fairy card
someone gave it to me at work
the famed messiah productions card with
the
religious scripture on the back
cyrus productions messiah
i was wondering if it was
real or not
it's real that's the real deal right
there cool
all right thank you nice to meet you
congratulations for surviving i think
for producing the book
what's your name sir uh conrad schneider
but that's capable of works for c c o n
r id
general clark who was
yeah i forgot to mention that in texas
for 68 million firearms for 16 million
people and most people go the gun issue
they flip out they don't realize that
it's a different mentality i mean texas
is that's why they wanted to do that a
very special place there's 15 000
registered
uh machine guns in texas that people
paid tax on
at two thousand dollars a piece a year
they're so horrible nobody's been live
in the state anymore
that's what clinton and his folks wanted
to do put the big show on here
to intimidate everybody else coming here
for the big show all you really got to
do is go through the texas rangers
reports i mean yeah they've got that
thanks sir thank you very much
congratulations their home towns wake up
i'm so sorry for what you had to go
through
especially sorry that this government
did it
you know
i told a lot of people a long time ago
said someday you're going to get the
real story you may not get it now from
all the lies but someday you will know
you know what happened and i think it's
going to happen hopefully
it's happening on a much
more mass scale than ever has before
right you know it's just people
sometimes need a lot of time to rethink
things you know that's the problem with
the power of the press and the power of
that's right an agenda they're terrified
because the agenda is amazing and that's
right yeah scripturally it says they're
they're their words are like uh
their words are very soft but they're
they don't realize that they're like
razors but trucks swords they're very
sharp and
of nine survivors from the branch
davidian compound in waco texas
public affairs publishes his book a
place called waco
that followed this is about 90 minutes
for federal agents with the bureau of
alcohol tobacco firearms and explosives
there is nothing routine about serving
search and arrest warrants
the crimes they deal with usually
involve firearms and explosives
is one of the most dangerous jobs in all
of law enforcement in fact throughout
history 186 atf agents
have their names inscribed on the
national law enforcement officers
memorial the second highest total of any
federal agency
the deadliest day in atf history
occurred on february 28
1993
in a place called waco texas
an arrest warrant was issued for
religious cult leader david koresh
as well as a search warrant of his
compound to seize suspected illegal
weapons those weapons turned out to
include hand grenades and fully
automatic machine guns
a group of 77 atf agents along with 60
support personnel were ordered to serve
the warrants
the dangerous mission had been carefully
planned
tragically though correction as
followers were tipped off that the
agents were coming
so instead of a peaceful arrest in
search of the premises the officers were
caught in a violent ambush
one of the agents gave this account
there were at least 12 thousand rounds
fired it was like iwo jima
agents were pinned down hiding behind
whatever they could find to block the
bullets
when the gunfire had ended four atf
agents
conway lebloo
todd mckeon
robert williams
stephen willis
were dead
some 30 additional agents were wounded
obviously there was much second guessing
about waco and many changes in atf
training and procedures that resulted
so what went wrong on that fateful day
nearly 20 years ago
and how things changed at atf
tonight we hear from three of the agents
on the ground that day
and an author who has devoted a
substantial amount of time studying and
writing a book
about what happened
so let me introduce the speakers for
tonight's event
pete mastin retired atf 31 years of
service
he was the deputy incident commander at
waco he was the senior agent on the
ground
he helped develop the presentation to
show agencies around the world how atf
changed tactical approaches after waco
jerry patrilli
retired atf 29 years of service
he was the team leader for dallas
special response team he was at the
compound door serving the warrant
after waco he rewrote the regional
tactical response strategy for atf
bill buford
retired atf 31 years of service
he was the co-leader of the new orleans
team was one of the agents seen in much
of the media footage trying to breach
the compound from the roof
he was seriously wounded shot four times
and he saw one of his good friends and
colleagues gunned down just a few feet
away
and finally professor dick revis
he was a journalist and is now an
associate professor of english at north
carolina state university
he conducted an extensive research after
the raid getting to know many of the
davidians and covering the trial
he wrote the book the ashes of waco an
investigation
here's a copy of the book right here
published in the summer of 1995 he
testified before congress also that same
year about what happened at what they
called mount carmel
and why
so ladies and gentlemen that's our panel
for this evening and
pete as the deputy incident commander
a senior commander on the ground that
fateful day i'm going to turn to you
first for a little background
why did the bureau of alcohol tobacco
and firearms
raid the branch davidian compound known
as mount carmel on february 28 1993
special agents at the
austin post of duty
special agents at the austin post of
duty
that had responsibility for the waco
area
had been called by the mclennan county
sheriff's department to investigate
an instance of
possession of automatic weapons and
possession of explosives
for
about eight months the their
investigation had
developed a tremendous amount of
information that
that such firearms were located on the
compound
and that such explosives were located on
the compound
shortly before the the warrant
was executed
the arrest arrest warrants for
vernon wayne howell or david koresh
were issued by the united states
attorney's office in waco
and a search warrant for the premises of
mount carmel
and a separate location called the mag
bag about two or three miles away
were were issued
the search warrant the affidavit for the
search warrant
went through extreme scrutiny after the
after the event
and was not found wanting at all
uh it was a it was a well-written
well-documented piece of work
the warrant
then we went down to
to fort hood texas the three srt or
special response teams involved and
begin to practice
how we would lay out this
this warrant and how it would be
executed
you mentioned earlier today we were
chatting and you mentioned the local
sheriff had actually asked you all to
intervene as well the mclennan county
sheriff's department requested uh atf
assistance then yes okay very good uh
jerry um correction his followers had
amassed quite an arsenal of weapons you
mentioned to me talk to me about that
and what did you expect to find and what
did you find ultimately at waco
well we expected to find
automatic weapons
as the warrant stated
and
numerous firearms because we had known
that prior to the raid
in the four and a half month period
prior to february 28th branch davidians
had spent four in excess of forty three
thousand dollars on firearms and
explosives so we knew we were
going to uncover quite a bit
of illegal activity
and ultimately uh what did what was
found at the compound when all was over
when all was over there was in excess of
230 guns
uh and many many others which couldn't
even be identified based on the uh
results of a fire uh and and the
trampling of the of those other weapons
the def the fire destroyed a lot but i
think you also mentioned there were hand
grenades involved
i can attest to one
yeah they were definitely hand grenades
uh uh
bill actually
uh got up when he was in the i'll let
you tell that story but uh
there were definitely hand grenades
there and they got me with one of them
slowed me down
i think you mentioned too that even
after everything had burned
two million rounds of ammunition were
also discovered there yes yes
there was a
the the amount of ammunition that
wasn't expended was was just
mind-boggling and and they fired off
approximately 12 000 rounds at us during
the two and a half hour siege yes yes
dick uh let me jump down to you i know
you wrote a book about waco you weren't
there that day is that correct i was out
there
and uh a couple days later as i believe
you told me you you went to waco and you
started your investigation you actually
quit your job
so that you could do a full-fledged
investigation of your own as a
journalist into what happened there that
eventually led to the book uh the ashes
of waco and uh you had
some thoughts that maybe they should not
have gone in and i'd be interested in in
your thinking on that no i i don't think
i was alone at all
in that thought please talking to my man
here may think that
but they should not any i don't think it
was necessary to go in
secondly i think that had anyone besides
robert rodriguez understood those
people's
theology
that would not have gone in
because
i think the surprise was those people
fired on the atf agents
we're not used to that in this country
and
if you knew what they believed if you
knew what the religion was you knew they
might do that as as the
atf's undercover agent knew
but i don't think that was understood at
the highest levels
tell us about david koresh his original
name vernon howe
i changed that
later in life
and how did he get to waco and and what
was his background
well david koresh and almost all of his
followers were raised in the seventh-day
adventist church
and so they all had common beliefs
that disposed them to think
that the end of the world might come or
the return of jews
jesus might come soon the soon coming of
christ seventh-day adventists call it
and i would say that they are to
seventh-day adventism what trotskyists
are to
marx meaning they're the radical they
were the radicals of that trend of
thought
qurash was a fairly quresh was dyslexic
he never did well in school
because he could not
he couldn't write is what it comes to he
couldn't get the letter straighter he
was dysgraphic as some people would say
and he was making a living it was a high
school dropout making a living as a
carpenter
when he showed up in mount carmel
he apparently had tremendous charisma
one thing leads to another and the next
thing you know he is the leader of mount
carmel
and he begins evolving a theology in
which
he is the lamb of the book of revelation
and
he is another of the incarnations of the
word of god very grandiose scheme
but because he apparently developed
i don't know a word for it because he
couldn't read and write that well he
remembered everything by ear
and he could recite the bible
like no one i've ever heard of
and that added to his leadership he knew
the bible better than anybody in mount
carmel
some have
described him as a child molester and a
child abuser
and suggested that all kinds of sinful
activity were occurring inside the
compound was he a child molester
i think that legally
he was guilty of that
according to our laws now that is not
the way it was seen in mount carmel
he taught
that he had to father 21
children
who would be the judges who stand in
judgment on the world in the book of
revelation
and so that's what he said he was doing
now but there's no question but what
under our laws he was guilty of it
though i might point out the federal
government has no jurisdiction over
child molesting it's a state offense
tell me if this uh description of quresh
is accurate it's written in the local
newspaper in waco
says if you are a branch davidian christ
lives on a threadbare piece of land
about 10 miles east of waco called mount
carmel
he has dimples claims a ninth grade
education married his legal wife when
she was 14. enjoys a beer now and then
plays a mean guitar reportedly packs a
nine millimeter glock and keeps an
arsenal of military assault rifles and
willingly admits that he is a sinner
without equal
accurate i think all that's true but i
think he pointed out quresh drinks beer
because hueco's a baptist him
kind of thumbed his nose at the town in
other words
at baylor university
very good
jerry let me turn to you uh and i'm
going to come back to bill for the
actual raid itself but talk to us about
the planning and the training that led
up to the raid
uh who was involved how long was it in
the works and and uh you know there were
many units apparently that went to waco
why was that
we had
three of our special response teams uh
new orleans
uh houston and dallas teams
originally we had asked for two
additional teams we didn't have those so
we were then supported by non-srt
atf agents so we had uh those people we
did
uh
bill and i and a few others did
extensive reconnaissance
of the compound and and went down for
numerous meetings
at the houston division office to
put together the best plan we could
uh
that went on for a couple of months
prior to the actual raid
and then
ultimately we brought everyone together
and went down to fort hood texas
and did training with
all the people involved
about a week before the actual rate
so that's 77 agents and the 60 support
personnel all in one place yes but only
one week before the raid the rest of the
training a lot of it anyway occurred in
individual units correct okay correct
you mentioned something to me earlier
that that was very interesting i thought
and that is that you knew there were
children inside that compound and you
took extra measures to to try to
deal with them during this raid knowing
it would be a traumatic situation and
very difficult for them to tell me about
some of the things you did
some of the things we did in recognizing
that there would be women and children
there
we we were concerned that when while we
were executing the search warrant they'd
be out in the hot sun
we've got tents for them uh we we got
porta-potties uh we got
food for them
uh what's the name of that food happy
meal happy meals
[Music]
it wasn't such a happy day but
you know we
we had a number of female agents uh with
us
so that they could hopefully deal more
with the women and children
we took a lot of care in preparation for
that
and
one of our concerns
based on the intelligence we had
was
the individuals that were identified as
the mighty men
they were
physically
the individuals that would possibly
confront us in in fist fights and things
of that nature
and so
all of us made preparations for dealing
with that
uh as opposed to
not just a gun fight but actual
fisticuffs
and then planning for the children and
and taking care of them while we
executed the lawfully issued search
warrant
bill buford i'll turn to you at this
point
one of the things that you said before
the raid as part of the planning and
preparation was you actually interviewed
some of the davidians that
were living outside of the compound i
assume tell me what you found out from
them and and how it might have helped
well one of the things that we felt was
essential is that we know as much about
the davidians as we could
and i was fortunate enough to interview
a number of people who had been living
on the compound
and had left for one reason or another
and i had several questions that i i
asked each of them and
the first one i asked because when we
initially
planned the raid it was to
surround the compound and then call the
individuals out
and i asked each of these individuals
what will happen if we surround the
compound and we try to negotiate them to
come out
and in each and every case i was told
that
they will hold out as long as they can
and
when it looks like they can't hold out
any longer
they had a suicide pact and that they
would all commit suicide
this was told us by a 14 year old girl
whose father had gotten her out just
prior to her becoming a
victim
of
koresha's
uh
shall we say uh
well anyway he was a pedophile and
his father her father found out that
she had been given one of the unicorns
to become a bride at 14.
but she was told taught to kill herself
by putting the gun in the roof of her
mouth
to kill herself rather than putting it
to the side of her head
because you might miss if you put it to
the side of your head
it was uh after
interviewing these people and uh they
convinced me that there was a suicide
pact which in fact in the end is what
actually happened
uh
that we needed to do something that is
other than a surround and call out
that
quresh was the ultimate
lord
jesus whatever you may want to call him
and that whatever he said inside the
compound would happen
and i was convinced the individuals that
i talked to who had lived there
convinced me that all of the children
would be killed by their parents
and then the adults would commit suicide
if we were to just surround the place
and call them out that's the reason we
changed from a surround and call out
type situation and tried a more dramatic
entry so that we could in fact protect
as many of the children as we could and
i there's been a lot of talk about how
we had no regard for the children and
nothing could be further from the from
the truth
i was i'm a parent
grandparent and
our main concern was the the welfare of
the children and we felt like we would
be able to pull it off and get those
children out of there
without them being harmed
corrections followers were lying in wait
for you when you arrived that day i
think it was around 9 30 in the morning
roughly on february 28th
what tipped them off and how were they
so ready for atf coming on to their
premises what happened
there was uh
uh our operational security was not as
good as it should have been and we were
dealing with people outside of law
enforcement
during the planning of the raid
there were three different sources that
that actually contributed to the to the
ambush that took place one being the
ambulance company that we had contacted
we had told them when we needed the
ambulances and a dispatcher with the
ambulance company had called
her
boyfriend who happened to be a
journalist and told him that we would be
executing the warrant on
sunday the 28th
he in fact then contacted two other
people and
one of which was a
television reporter
a television reporter got disoriented
out on the road
in trying to find the compound that
morning
and stopped a rural mail carrier
and asked him for directions to the
compound
and
although he would never say exactly what
transpired
he obviously had let the royal the mail
carrier know that uh atf was about to
raid the compound
uh this individual then drove directly
back to the compound he was a branch
davidian in fact was the son of the
number three man inside the compound and
told david
that
atf was on the way that we were about
ready to raid the compound and this was
verified by robert rodriguez who
happened to be there at the time and
overheard a conversation
so they had about 45 minutes in which to
prepare for us to arrive
during that time they obviously emptied
the uh the arms room uh
took positions in the water tower
and uh throughout the compound and
when we arrived we were fired on from
what the texas rangers reported possibly
as many as 40 different shooting
positions when we first arrived on the
compound
just to close that loop what happened to
the mailman that gave them the tip he
was killed that day
killed during the siege during the
assault during the initial fire fight
pete help me here um you now i think
realized that they had gotten tipped off
that they realized something was about
to happen at some point in time fairly
soon
yet the decision was made to go ahead
with the raid knowing that you'd lost
that element of surprise
walk me through that decision-making
process why you decided to go ahead not
you personally but others in the
decision-making process and uh and and
what and what happened uh once you got
there
well i think there were a number of
factors involved the first
being our prior success
in operational matters from a standpoint
of srts
we had never failed
we had
in any
situation that we've been in we served
in the prior two years to wake over 250
high risk warrants
and we realized of course this was a
high risk warrant
but
our confidence level overcame uh most
anything else the second issue had to
deal with momentum
uh
the momentum of the moment the final
decision to go was made under the
turning blades of a of a uh-60
helicopter and
and there was no real
time to sit back and and look at all the
aspects of what intelligence that we had
and
and the third thing was that uh
we could uh
uh we had a trip wire
and the tripwire was uh in the raid
house across the street
that would give us uh the final
s go or no go if danger was spotted
uh so we we thought that was a
sufficient issue
to uh to utilize
and and you actually uh then
uh began the raid and uh you mentioned
today that you still felt you had some
element of surprise how so
well we loaded the the uh
horse trailers we were we were there
were 77 of us
uh loaded into two horse trailers
that in fact was uh was our saving grace
uh koresh knew we were coming uh he was
anticipating that we would drive up in
van's mark squat
and yet we pulled in in front of his
compound in two horse trailers that had
cover covers on the top of them
he didn't know we were in those horse
trailers i am
absolutely convinced in my own mind that
had he known
we were in those horse trailers he had
killed us in the trailers
so i think that the utilization of the
horse trailers was a was a factor
that
that helped our our surprise the
surprise was was there we knew we were
coming
but he didn't know we were coming in
that fashion
jerry uh there's some dispute i think
maybe even today about who fired the
first shot was it the davidians or was
it the atf agent so what's your
recollection
in my mind there's absolutely no doubt
they fired first
we had
a strong reputation we only returned
fire
and they opened up on us as soon as we
started coming out of the trailers
what was the
instruction the policy for using lethal
force in situations like that
you would only fire in defense of
yourself or a fellow person
simple as that
bill uh you've described this to me as
the the worst day of your professional
life and the best day
of your professional life uh explain
well i i and i believe this today it was
the worst day of my professional career
as an atf agent and probably in my life
in that we lost four people
we had
numerous others wounded
but
of the 77 agents whose feet hit the
ground that day i couldn't have been
more proud
each and every one of them it made no
difference if it was a male or female
did exactly what they were supposed to
do
they showed courage that was
unbelievable for people who had never
ever heard a shot fired in anger before
and i was
when i think back on it i'm still so
proud of those those agents some of them
really weren't cut out
for a big firefight like that but they
did everything they were supposed to do
that day and
i am so proud of them and i'm so proud
of atf as an agency today because of the
kind of people
that they turn out
dick
you've been listening to the
descriptions from the people on the
ground you weren't there obviously that
day but you did a lot of investigation
afterwards
mistakes made during the raid mistakes
made leading up to the raid you talked
about maybe a flawed affidavit used to
get the warrant
um do you still believe that to this day
oh yes um
when we were unable we in the press
couldn't read the worn until mount
carmel burned down because it hadn't
been served right
when we got it we couldn't believe how
poorly it was done
it accused
the people in mount carmel of
subscribing to clandestine publications
like shotgun
news which goes through the mail third
class postage permit been doing it for
years
it brings up the question of child
molesting which is not a federal offense
and therefore not a ground for a federal
warrant
it accuses him of trafficking in drugs
when the only incident that ever
involved that was when
he first took over mount carmel there
were two meth
meth makers living there
he threw them out called the county
sheriff to mount carmel and handed over
their equipment to the county sheriff
that was the only evidence
that he ever had anything to do with
drugs so the search warrant was put up
job it's about that simple
um
it it's it was poorly written and poorly
thought out
you were also critical
i i believe in your book and elsewhere
about the the role of the media
in this whole
uh event and and the the
days after it
uh talk to me about that why did you
decide to get involved
okay this has more to do with what
happened after february the 28th
i was assigned to go down and see what
was going on
and i went down and went to a conference
help of the fbi the atf and the fbi held
press conferences every day
and what struck me as a journalist and i
think most good journalists think this
way is we must always distrust our
sources
and try to balance what they say with
something else
but the only source of information was
the atf and the fbi
even though some people had surrendered
at mount carmel
and were being held in jail
we were denied access to them the dallas
morning news filed a suit
trying to get access to them
because naturally we wanted to hear both
sides of the story
so i pretty much gave up on doing the
story i figured when this is all over
the press will get it
well
when it was all over the press went home
everybody was tired of wake up
and so that's when i started trying to
look into it you spent a lot of time
investigating it
um
jerry help me uh
understand in terms of the end of the
siege all right this uh the gunfire
lasted for about two and a half hours
after you arrived from about 9 30 to 12
30 something along those lines
what brought an end to the siege
eventually
one of our
agents
jim cavanaugh
he was a deputy
incident commander if i recall the
correct title deputy tactical deputy
tactical commander and uh
he had gotten on the phone with david
koresh and
uh and or others
and negotiated a cease fire
that cease-fire was broken by the
davidians
he negotiated another one that
cease-fire was broken by the davidians
and finally the third ceasefire that he
negotiated
actually held
and at that point
very gingerly
we started coming out from behind cover
hoping that that third ceasefire would
not be broken
we then
gathered up our dead and wounded and
left the property
a couple comments have been made about
what happened that day one is
the thought that atf ran out of ammo and
that's what caused the retreat at that
point in time truth
i would say that we certainly were
extremely low i know i only had a couple
of bullets left
whether we ran out i can't say for sure
but we were definitely running out
some have said atf was outgunned and yet
i think you told me the next day that
the
atf wasn't uh happy with that uh
statement that uh they did not believe
they were outgunned what's your opinion
well there were certain people in
certain locations that didn't like that
statement but the truth is when
the bad guys have 50 caliber machine
guns when they have m60 machine guns
when they have fully automatic ak-47s
m16s
we were outgunned there's absolutely no
question in my mind we were outgunned
so at lunch today we talked about the 50
caliber uh weapon that that's here
tonight uh it's my understanding that
that was a davidian weapon not an atf
weapon you did not go in with 50 caliber
weapons no this this bureau has never
had 50 caliber weapons to use
ever
we take those off the streets we don't
use them we also don't have
and never never used m60 machine guns
none of that
pete um
why wasn't there any backup for you all
here here you were under fire
uh
taking casualties four agents killed
early in the in the raid and yet no
local law enforcement no federal law
enforcement came to your aid why not
well local law enforcement did come to
our aid
we received
we received the first
call for aid from the mclennan county
sheriff's department
and the waco police department and the
austin police department sent their swat
team
and the department of public safety with
the state of texas sent their squad
folks
they helped in the
containment of the of the
compound
once we withdrew
and our own agents
some of them still wounded
stayed
to surround the compound
and prevent escape there was a second
gun battle late in the afternoon
when three davidians tried to come and
come back into the compound
and
they ran into our
perimeter
and a second gun battle ensued
by the night of the 28th we had three of
our own srts
in
to augment what we had
and
by the next day
the first of the fbi's hrt hostage
rescue team
came in and took the inner perimeter on
on the 2nd of may
bill uh
in many ways uh you you've said that uh
what happened at waco that day was a
fulfillment of koresha's own uh prophecy
uh that this is something that he
brought on to fulfill something that he
had been saying to his followers for a
long long time
uh and it was more or less destined to
happen at some point and he chose to to
make it happen so that he could fulfill
his prophecy tell me about that
i had dealt with
a number of other
religious cults
that had similar philosophies to
koreshas
and it had been my
i'd found that in some of these cases
when they are
leading such a group
that they make certain prophecies as to
things that are going to happen
and when these things don't happen they
begin to lose face when they begin to
lose that face then they have to do
something
to make it happen
so that they don't lose face let's face
it he had a bird's nest on the ground
he had everything going for him and
he wasn't about to give that up
one of the situations that i was
concerned about that i had seen happen
with similar groups in the past was that
he would need to do something in order
to bring about his prophecy of this
armageddon
where law enforcement would assault the
compound they could hold out they would
all die and then in three days they
would be resurrected and he would be
the good jesus at that point they'd be
living in the garden of eden
one of the stories that came out was at
one point he brought the men and women
or mostly just his mighty men i guess
into the chapel and had them arm
themselves
told them they were going to the
mcdonald's in waco and were going to
kill everyone at the mcdonald's
and
after that was over with they would come
back to the compound and at that point
law enforcement would have to come after
them and he would have his prophecy his
armageddon
that didn't take place he actually
made the statement later that
this was just a test to see if they
would actually do what he asked i
believe the statement he made at that
point was something to the effect
if you can't kill for god you can't die
for god
so that was part of our concern like i
say in a previous investigation with a
similar
psycho for lack of a better term
he in fact did try to do something to
bring about his armageddon
and
fortunately he wasn't able to do so but
that was a definite concern that we all
had
dick would you agree that what happened
at waco was a self-fulfilling prophecy
i believe it
presented
quresh with
the chance to decide
if he wanted it to be a fulfillment of
prophecy
they had expected
that the end of the world would not come
until they moved to israel
which they planned to do about 1997.
they thought they would go to israel and
then events would begin to unfold
which would terminate pretty much as he
said
that it happened in waco
was a surprise to them
and i think quresh had to decide
some months in advance what the meaning
of it
was i wouldn't be at all surprised but
what he had decided in his own mind
that's what was going on but we don't
know
and certainly his followers weren't told
that
until
february 28th
bill uh talking about the raid itself uh
you get out of the trailer uh you're
under fire almost immediately is that a
fair statement yes
and the video the film footage that we
see so often is of you and a couple of
other fellow agents on the roof
taking fire
tell us first how you got up there why
you were up there and and talk to us
about what was happening
well it was
immediately when we got in front of the
compound
i was in the second trailer
and we heard the gunfire erupt and the
first thing i heard was an m60 machine
gun
i knew we didn't have any m60s then i
heard the 50 cals and the ak-47s knowing
that we had none of those weapons either
so i was
quite concerned needless to say
the new orleans team was going on to the
roof of the building
to make entry into koresha's bedroom and
also into the arms room
our hope was that we might be able to
catch karesh still in bed
the arms room was where all the weapons
were kept we felt like if we could
secure the arms room we could keep the
rest of them from getting the weapons
they already had the weapons which we
didn't know at the time
we went around to the side of the
building
put the ladders up
and my three-man team
myself
and glen jordan and keith constantino
we were doing what they call a break and
rake we broke out the glass on the
window
i peeked inside saw an individual in the
room with an ak-47
i put in a a flash flashbang a
distraction device
and then stepped into the room at that
point the individual had stepped back
into the hallway
the arms room still had probably 35 or
40 guns in
it i crossed the the room to get to the
doorway
and again the training that we had paid
off not going through the door but
looking through the crack in the door
and that individual
started coming back into the room and i
was able to neutralize him as he came
into the room
by that time we were receiving fire
through all the walls
the only
davidian i saw that day was the one
individual but the
gunfire was intense coming through the
walls
uh
glenn jordan uh one of the agents out of
little rock was yelled that he had been
hit and i went back to where glenn was
it was obvious he had been hit hard he
had taken a round in the back that went
down his arm and severed his brachial
artery in two places and he was bleeding
profusely
we were still receiving a
tremendous amount of gunfire through the
through the walls and i can remember
holding on to a two before which was
part of a gun rack
and the
splinters coming off of from the rounds
hitting the gun rack were sticking in my
face
and i was having trouble figuring out
why i wasn't being hit
i knelt down to try to render some aid
to to glenn while i was continuing to to
fire back through the wall
they started shooting through the floor
the first round that hit me
struck me right in the back end
and that one wasn't too bad
uh continued to uh return fire glenn
yelled that he'd been shot again
and uh i knelt down to try to do
something with him and then i was shot
twice more with an
ak-47 once in the hip once in the thigh
the rounds were still coming through the
wall i remember trying to push up off
the floor to get out of there and
there was a wooden box there filled with
hand grenades
and
if i'd been thinking at the time i'd
start popping pins and rolling them down
the hallway but i didn't think about
that at the time but
i remember thinking i hope that a round
doesn't hit that box of hand grenades
but i was able to uh to talk to glenn
keith was had not been wounded
and uh he said he would cover for us and
glenn and i were able to get back onto
the roof
and uh
i actually rolled off the roof and glenn
was able to get down and then keith was
able to get out a little bit later
i believe you mentioned that your good
friend rob williams was shot and killed
during the the the raid at that point in
time was he on the roof with you or did
this happen some other time no uh
after i got on the ground i had uh
broken silver ribs when i hit the ground
and and was current concerned i'd been
shot in the chest also
and ken chisholm are our medic
on the new orleans team was working on
me
and we were started receiving gunfire
and i was shot in the face
and
at that point
ken chisholm
covered me with his body
but rob williams a kid from the little
rock office
raised up and shot the individual or
shot at the individual that was shooting
at us
and in doing so exposed himself
and
the next time he raised up rob was was
shot and killed he was about
six feet from me at the time
uh
great kid
25 years old it was the day before his
26th birthday and
i had got to swear he meant on the job
he was just the kind of kid that anybody
would want to have working for him and
that was pretty hard
seeing him go down like that but
i mean it was
it was not a good day in that respect
four agents killed
30 wounded
there were some discrepancy uh pete
about the number of davidians that might
have been killed
and or injured during the raid
tell me about those numbers
on the
on the evening of the raid
after we had withdrawn from the area
koresh had spoken with a
radio station
and had told the radio station that we
killed 15 of his followers
that later
came down to
to six
and i believe the the ballistics run by
the state of texas have shown that we
kill two
uh ballistically
but uh
that was the that still is a discrepancy
in the in the
in their program anyway you mentioned uh
that koresh and his folks had an
interesting way to deal with the wounded
and injured what was that
they couldn't treat the wounded
they initially said in the afternoon of
the 28th that they were going to load
their wounded into a school bus and
bring them to the hospital
and
that was decided that that was not going
to be an option
that they weren't going to
come out of that the compound arm
and at that particular point in time
they began to
deal with their own wounded
shooting
bullet to the head pull it to the head
jerry uh and i'm gonna ask this question
of all three of the agents here
two and a half hours
the gunfire finally ends
ceasefire goes into effect
you have
you
managed to remove the injured and the
dead
and you leave the the site
what thoughts were going through your
mind at that point in time
well i guess a lot of thoughts uh
one of course the
the shock of the event that
this is never
in the history of law enforcement ever
happened
the amount of resistance that uh
we encountered was unheard of
the
thought of failure of not completing our
mission of not executing the search
warrant and arrest warrant
none of us had ever experienced that
we've always succeeded
seeing bill on the
hood of a car
uh
those are hard things to take
and uh
so
uh you know we we pulled back and
um i remember telling
my number two guy uh bob white
um
take care of everybody
and
hold as much of a perimeter as you can
there had been some commands to not hold
the perimeter
i told them i don't care what anybody
says you hold
so it was very difficult
i difficult day for all of us
uh
we'd never seen that i mean
we've been in combat before in
the service and we'd seen things there
but not in law enforcement not like that
bill you're
seriously wounded
shot four times
and yet i believe you said you were at
least semi-conscious
and uh
i'd love to hear your thoughts generally
but please include that moment of
some humor mixed in a bit if you will
here 20 years later anyway about uh
somebody was asking about your state and
uh didn't give you a real positive sign
yeah i was uh
laying there and uh pete
called over to ken chisholm who was our
medic and pete or ken had just run an iv
through me
and uh pete called over and says how's
bill doing and i could hear this my eyes
were closed but i opened my eyes when i
heard that and chisholm's going
like this
i remember opening my eye and i said no
i'm okay
but
yeah that was
i didn't think it was funny at the time
but it's kind of funny
but
i think my thoughts were uh
mostly about the guys we lost and
because i had been a an integral part of
the planning of the raid
it's taken me
all this time and still sometimes i have
problems dealing with the fact that it
wasn't to a large part my fault
if i had been able to come up with a
better plan or if i had done something
different
these guys would be alive today
and i know that's not realistic but to
say that it doesn't go through your mind
is
it's uh it's there all the time
and
i wish that uh
i had been a lot smarter than i was
and that we could have come up with
something that would have
ended completely different for not only
for us but for the davidians especially
for the children that were on the inside
but
i guess my main
thoughts were
uh
this is my
fault pete deputy incident commander
you've just uh
gone through a terrible ordeal with your
fellow agents
um i imagine there probably were some
thoughts along the lines of bill about
second guessing the decision to go in
second guessing why didn't we do this or
that
walk me through your thought process
after the raid was over
there were certainly those faults
those thoughts
[Music]
i was the senior
agent on the ground
and i felt like that it was my
responsibility
to make sure that
our folks
came home safe
and that we accomplished the mission and
in that
i failed
it was a
a very difficult pill to swallow
law enforcement i'd been in law
enforcement
30 years at that time i was a police
officer for five years prior to coming
with atf
and had been involved in a in a number
of incidents
law enforcement
by its very nature
requires
some working without a net
without the absolute
and
[Music]
we try to
make sure that the absolutes are
are tied as tight as they could be
but in that case they weren't
systemically
we weren't
set up as an agency
to conduct that operation
we didn't uh have
the
the uh intelligence that we needed to
operate that uh
in under in that environment
um
we we didn't have the weaponry that we
needed and we didn't have the the
operational security element that was
absolutely essential in that
in that environment
that uh that cost us a great deal
the momentum of the issue
was it was a problem
the media dealing with the media was a
was an instantaneous problem we had
folks dealing with
the media
who
who had just
been involved in in a shooting of their
special agents
and uh one of the real issues that we
were dealing with was it two days prior
to waco
on the 26th day of
february 1993
the world trade center had been bombed
and
we had two of our national response
teams
and
our primary media sources resources up
in new york dealing with that situation
and so the
the uh
responsibility then fell
to folks
that weren't used to dealing with the
national media with the
and that's a that's a terrible situation
to put to put those folks in
so
yeah i'm like bill
we all
shared i think those those issues
and
you couldn't change what happened that
day but i think what you did was you you
headed up the training academy down in
glencoe at one point jerry i know you
were very involved in coming back to
headquarters and doing an after-action
look at what happened and what we needed
to change to make it better so this
would never happen again
what were in your mind some of the
mistakes made at waco and how have
things changed at atf since then
well some of the mistakes were in the
the lack of
quality intelligence
prior to the raid
we didn't have the medical resources
that
should have been required for this raid
we had to depend on other outside
resources such as the ambulance company
which led to
operational security issues
we didn't have a
sniper teams
like we should have had
so there were a number of issues
that needed improvement
i was ultimately
asked
to come up to headquarters
and uh
i came up and and and
reorganized the entire structure at that
time we had 24
field divisions and 24 srts
we changed that over to a regional
concept
we went from
in excess of 400 agents devoted to the
program
to just
over 200
the director uh allocated a lot more
funding to the program
uh our training became unified and and
uh
in the five teams that we created uh we
created the uh a tremendous
medical program that's still in place
today we created
sniper teams that's still in place today
the
public information officer role
was
tremendously improved
so
today
through
the leadership of atf
we have an extremely strong program
in the srt program
that can stand
shoulder to shoulder with any other
agency in this country
or in the world as far as i'm concerned
but
on february 28th
i think we were
highly qualified
but
we had a lot of room for improvement and
and we made those changes and
those changes still stand today and they
still are worked on today to improve and
and and
get better so that we can protect our
agents and protect the innocent people
uh in the united states that we serve
warrants on
you know david koresh as far as i'm
concerned and his followers
were as guilty as the day is long
but those children they were not
and we did on february 28th we did
everything we could for them
and atf continues to do that to this day
to protect the innocent and put the
guilty parties in jail
bill
one of the things i think we discussed
at lunch today was
a failure perhaps to have a contingency
plan in place for the worst case
scenario and i believe it was referred
to perhaps as a strategic withdrawal
and that that was really not part of the
plan and that was perhaps one of the
mistakes that was made
would you maybe elaborate on that just
briefly and and talk about any other
mistakes and changes that have occurred
well i think that uh
one of the problems we had at that time
was the structure of the hierarchy of
atf
the
sac in charge of a particular area would
be the
incident commander
uh whether he had had any tactical
experience at all and that is that has
been changed
to a certain extent i believe now that
the uh
sac will be working very strongly with
the srt with the team leader of the srt
so that everybody's on the same sheet of
music but
i have to take responsibility for the
lack of a contingency plan
i put together a a contingency plan
which i passed on to the other guys and
they all said yeah that's great
and and there was nothing to it it meant
nothing we had no contingency for what
do we do if we suddenly are under fire
we can't get in the building and we have
28 agents wounded and four dead
we had no strategic withdrawal plan how
are we going to get these people out of
there if we are
overcome which is exactly what happened
we were kind of like
lost sheep there for a while when we
first started leaving the compound i
don't really remember leaving the
compound i was kind of out of it but
i've seen on the videos and talking to
some of the other people
luckily the individual agents there did
a pretty good job but there was no
covering movement
to get out everybody was for the most
part
walking out on their own except for the
ones that stayed behind for containment
and i think one of the things that
came as a result of waco is a strong
strong contingency plan on every raid
that atf runs now whether it's the srt
running it or whether it's the field
office
you those are things you can't
make a snap decision while you're under
fire those things have to be planned for
beforehand
and
our contingency plan that day both going
in and withdrawing
it was non-existent for the most part
and again i have to take responsibility
for that
uh or at least a large part of it
because uh
as pete said we've never failed before
we're gonna go in there we're gonna kick
a little booty and then we're gonna ease
out and
we'll be home before noon
didn't work out that way
i think you mentioned one good decision
that was made and something that was a
bit innovative at the time was taking in
a couple paramedics with you
that was not necessarily policy then was
it no it wasn't
we had a
an emt that happened to be on the dallas
team
and
he had an aid bag that he carried with
him
and we had an emt on the new orleans
team
who carried an aid bag with him this was
not something that that atf sanction is
just something that we as team leaders
felt like you know it can't hurt to have
these people with us
i know with the atf with the new orleans
team
we practiced at just about all of our
training starting ivs on one another we
practiced combat medicine what i call
combat medicine
but if it hadn't been for ken chisholm
and tim gabry uh out there that day we
probably would have lost a lot more
people than we lost they did a fantastic
job and were true heroes through that
whole thing they just
continued to take care of people
regardless of how much fire they were
under
so the the medical program that atf has
now i think is
as good as any in the in the country i
would put them up you know they could
probably go in with some seal teams and
do just about anything their medics can
do they're they're tremendous tremendous
guys
good to hear
dick uh you obviously look at this from
a different perspective uh you're a
journalist not a
tactical professional in law enforcement
but you've studied this very carefully
over a long period of time what would
you consider to be major mistakes made
and are you satisfied from the outside
looking in that atf has made appropriate
changes in how they do things
i'm not familiar with the changes the
atf has made
except through the two standoffs i've
seen the fbi participate in
and they made changes they learned from
waco without ever having admitted era
but they quit holding daily
at the montana friedman standoff they
did not hold daily press conferences
which i think during waco stirred people
up
people were saying go in and get them
there was almost a lynch moved
and most important that montana the fbi
let relatives visit
the freedmen who were holed up
no one was no relatives were allowed to
visit mount carmel
what happened in montana is that
relatives came in and said to those guys
i don't care what you believe about the
bible in the constitution you're my son
and it will break my heart to lose you
and those guys surrendered
that was not allowed at mark mount
carmel and i think it was a big era
because there was no challenge to the
authority of david koresh
mothers and fathers and brothers and
kids could have made a credible
challenge
had they been allowed go in to visit
good point
i'm going to now turn to the audience
and i'm going to start with
the director of atf todd jones who's
here with us uh
director i'm i guess the question i
would pose to you and feel free to
comment uh on any anything that you've
heard here tonight any thoughts that you
have about waco
but what is waco's relevance to today's
atf what's its relevance to you as the
leader of atf
20 years ago you weren't there
but i would imagine you know a lot about
it and you have a lot of thoughts about
what happened there
20 years ago i was a young assistant
united states attorney
in the district of minnesota and have
very vivid memories of watching
the new attorney general the united
states janet reno
talk about
[Music]
waco and the branch davidians and the
and the ending of that
over that period of time
and what i've heard here today
solidifies two things and i'll limit my
comments to those two things
one is law enforcement is a tough job
and the work that atf does is some of
the highest risk
tactical law enforcement
out there at the federal level because
of
our responsibilities
in the areas of
regulating and enforcing the law with
respect to firearms
the second thing i'll say and we'll
spend at the end of this month
an appropriate time with many of these
people in the room
honoring the four agents who gave their
lives
that day because
between waco
and february 28
of 1993
and december 31st of
2011
when we lost
an agent
in the line of duty and hostile action
there weren't any
casualties and hostile actions between
those two times
this was the biggest gun fight involving
federal law enforcement in the history
of the united states
the gentlemen who are here today
and the ones who are in the room
the men and women
of atf were heroes that day in my mind
and
that bravery continues it's in the dna
of atf
agreed sir
questions comments please right over
here
joy's got the microphone please uh wait
for the microphone dave mr rivas um
although you're not an attorney i don't
want to put you in an uncomfortable
place but i do believe that uh you were
at the trial of those branch davidians
that were under trial after the case
actually i think you jim and i were the
only people who actually sat through the
entire trial because these gentlemen
were witnesses
and you made the claim that you were
concerned about the search warrant
but jim and i every day drug in 200
firearms to this trial the davidians had
teams of attorneys
if the warrant was not good wouldn't it
have been thrown out of court um how
many federal judges would have had to
conspire to approve a faulty warrant
uh let me first point out to you that
there's no law against owning 203 guns
or 500
you don't raid people just because they
own guns
that's legal in this country
to my knowledge this search warrant was
taken to one magistrate
and that's who approved it
wasn't the case
numerous times
the which case
yeah i don't think you understood my
question i mean obviously the branch
davidians went to prison if i was a
defendant my attorney would try to get
the warrant thrown out so i mean this
although you're not an attorney numerous
attorneys numerous federal judges have
looked at the warrant and all have
upheld this warrant i know it's your
personal no
i i didn't say that the warrant was no
good i said the warrant was defamatory
if i could be more precise
it did allege
as a cause for the search i mean it
alleged several things child molesting
which is an onsecutor
drugs which was a fable
and it said he had prohibited weapons
and on that grounds that search warrant
stood
i might point out that it was not a no
knock search warrant
and that knocking was achieved by when
the agents ran for the doors
saying police search warrant lay down
um
so i think how do you say that
it seems to me that the whole procedure
was less than first class
if i might comment please please bill
the uh of those weapons the 240 some
uh quite a number of those and i believe
it's 47
were
illegal machine guns
plus illegal hand grenades
it's not legal anywhere in these united
states to possess a machine gun that is
not registered nor a handgun or a hand
grenade that is not registered therefore
the warrant was valid in the fact that
there were illegal weapons there
no you and i agree about that all i'm
saying is that the warrant included a
lot of inflammatory
nonsense as well
i don't consider
pedophilia to be nonsense
uh first and most important i want to
thank you three officers for your
service
very much uh jerry i i thought i heard
you allude early on to
you said you had originally requested
five teams
but you were only allowed three so i had
three questions
who made that decision
uh why did they make that decision and
if you had had your five teams do you
think that would have been a different
outcome i don't know who made the
decision i don't know why the decision
was made i'm sorry
um do i think there would have been a
different outcome
probably not i
everything else being the same
i don't think there would have been a
difference uh i think the agents that
were on the ground that day that were
not part of the srt
did an outstanding job that day
so
bottom line no i don't think there would
have been a difference
good evening want to thank you all for
your time here i just had one question
how many
law enforcement agencies were
on scene throughout the time and how did
that
help or hinder
your interactions and communications
with each other and
what if anything have you seen have been
changed since that time to better
cooperation or coordination with
multiple agencies who might respond to
similar incidents in the future
well there were a number of agencies
that were involved of course the
mclennan county sheriff was involved
the
texas rangers the department of public
safety were aware of what we were doing
although we didn't ask them to actively
participate in the execution of the
warrant
they were involved as far as
a part of the planning and were very
involved in setting up the roadblocks
for us as we went in to execute the
warrants so they were involved
their involvement after the initial fire
fight was tremendous
they were there
it was mentioned earlier about the fact
that
they
showed up almost immediately and and
they did and they would have been happy
to come in but it would have been
suicide to try to send one of those
teams uh into where we were across that
flat terrain with that building uh
commanding the terrain like it was so it
wasn't that they weren't willing to come
in they were chomping at the bit to come
but uh it was prudent that they didn't
at the time
could we have worked better with some of
the other agencies uh that's probably
true
our operational security was already
challenged and i think that had we have
expanded too much it would have been
even more challenged
but
we felt like the sheriff's office who
had the jurisdiction there and the texas
rangers
were involved and were aware of what we
were doing at all times
if i could add something to that the
texas rangers did a superb job
of investigating the homicide
or the homicides
and the
compromise of the raid the raid leak
investigation
they did a fantastic job
and just to clarify
there were only atf agents
that executed the warrants
none of those agent other agencies
participated in the actual execution of
the arrest warrant and the search
warrant
peter quick question while maybe some
others are
thinking of ones of their own and that
is how much was headquarters involved in
the planning of waco and and in the
moments after
headquarters headquarters had a uh an
operational unit activated during the
raid itself
and
they immediately were
are dispatched
senior officials to waco
to
conduct
the operation afterwards
headquarters approved the tactical plans
and
looked at the you know looked at it from
that standpoint
but from and sent support personnel down
there
in in
in the terms of some of the special
operations folks
uh who came down to help
steve higgins was one of my
all-time favorite people he really did a
lot to help build the national memorial
and to support the memorial fund
throughout his tenure
just an outstanding individual
and ultimately he lost his job i think
it's fair to say over what happened at
waco
bill is that fair that he lost his job
did somebody have to lose their job over
what happened
i think he was
no he shouldn't have lost his job
he was handcuffed in some of his
testimony before congress
by treasury
which made him look like he was hesitant
or didn't know what he was talking about
uh
he's a stand-up a guy as we've ever had
and uh
there there might have been some people
whose head should have been on the block
but i don't believe his should have been
one of them
thank you for that
anything else before we close out yeah
back here
so you talked about the initial assault
and i have this picture of the atf
coming out
what happened after that what was the
decision-making process in terms of
initiating finishing up the war what
happened with i think it was an apc that
went in
how did that decision-making process
happen
pete yeah
i'm sorry i i i did you want to know
about the ap uh the uh for the final how
did it after right now because we have
the atf coming out and sort of the story
hasn't finished yet okay if you could
just let us know what happened after
that
uh on the 2nd of
march
the ah hrt the fbi's hostage rescue
folks came in and took the inner
perimeter
their hostage negotiators began a
negotiation or attempted negotiation
process with with koresh
prior to their coming in koresh had
released
somewhere in the neighborhood of 22 or
23 people
mostly young children and older people
children who were not his biological
children we understood
and older people
and i don't believe after the second or
third of march anybody came out
they all stayed in
the fbi
maintained a negotiation process with
them they maintained pressure on them
we were in an outer perimeter
support role
and the decisions
that the fbi made were based on their
best information uh using their
uh
intelligence using their surveillance
materials
and decided on the 19th day of
of april 51 days later
that deterioration of conditions within
the compound necessitated some action to
get those folks out
they they initiated gas
and at some point in time
fire was set
inside the building by the davidian
and i might mention after the fire was
and the
scene was secured atf
the fbi and the
texas rangers then conducted a search of
the compound and that's when the
firearms and hand grenades and the
ammunition were recovered
after the
fire investigation had been completed
a total i think of 233 firearms 50 of
them
uh determined to be machine guns
probably eight more uh that were
too destroyed by the fire
to be
qualified as machine guns
thank you thank you
thank you
i was just wondering at the time of the
incident did atf have any of its own
hostage negotiating
resources
and
does the agency have those kind of
resources at this point
will you take that oh yeah
we had no hostage negotiation ability uh
the hostage negotiations that were done
by atf folks
were done by agents on their own
who just created an empathetic
attitude with uh with a davidian there
is hot there are hostage rescue or
hostage negotiators now within atf
and uh
and there's a an extensive training
program that went on shortly after that
um
due to the
benefit of the internet i have the
opportunity to read the search warrant
here i can't leave this discussion
without getting back to your comment mr
rivas about the quality of the search
warrant
if you look at the search warrant
there's about three lines that talk
about children
that might be abused at the davidian
complex there's two lines that talk
about shotgun news
and those issues there has to be four or
five pages that talk about
tremendous evidence that machine guns
were present
uh destructive devices
the the ability to make machine guns uh
evidence from people at the compound of
seeing uh
caress shoot machine guns
this search warrant that i that i could
read here is ironclad to pull it apart
and say that it was deficient because of
a couple de minimis references
to pedophilia
or to uh chuck and news i think is a
disservice to the people who wrote this
warrant and executed
does
when you learn
when you learn that the atf agent who
drew that search warrant
lists shotgun news as a clandestine
publication
does that point to competency
there's two lines in the search bar but
there were there were two lines that
show sloppiness
and
i i have said that the search warrant
was legally sufficient to get a search
but i but what we found in it shocked us
by the carelessness
and that its defamatory nature it was
not drawn up by a how do you say
by a person who was trying to be prudent
and restrained
everybody can read it
we have time for maybe one more question
back here rebecca
gentlemen i definitely would like to
echo the sentiment thank you for your
service
we talked a little bit about the
operational security uh and you
mentioned um the undercover that was
involved as well as interviews with
davidians that have left the complex
we've all heard about intelligence
failures uh you know incessantly in the
news
and the tactical commander never has you
know enough information to make those
decisions
but would there be a piece of
information
that you know in hindsight or something
that you would have liked to have had
available to make it a a go or no-go
situation on that day
i'll take it well for me i believe the
uh the nowhere no-go
uh for me that day
uh would have involved having the the
men in the compound outside working in
the construction area
our whole
raid plan based on the tactical
intelligence that we had
and the surveillance information that we
had
we felt it was very important for the
men to be outside working in the
construction area because they were
unarmed when they were out there working
if we were able to get in
in the horse trailers without being
spotted
the first team the first trailer part of
that team from houston would have then
gone directly to the construction area
where the vast majority of the men would
have been working they would have been
cut off from their firearms
and
that in itself would have
limited the amount of firepower that
that would have even been possible to uh
to come there was some other factors
the fact that
koresh would sometimes issue the weapons
uh to the individuals when he would get
paranoid about the police coming
he would then pick them up and lock them
all back up in the arms room when he'd
get paranoid about maybe someone within
the compound concerned about the fact
that he was sleeping with their
13-year-old daughter
so he would pick the guns back up
so we felt like there was at least a 50
50 chance that maybe all of the weapons
would have been locked up in the arms
room that's one reason we felt like it
was very important to get to the arms
room as quickly as possible but
to me the one thing that we didn't have
that day
uh that would have been essential to
have a successful outcome would have
been the majority of the men outside
working in that construction area were
and they weren't that day
can i ask a question
please this is the first time i've had a
chance to hear from the atf
because during the course i was writing
my book
roughly the 18 months
posterior to the event
uh both the fbi and the atf were told
not to speak to the press
and
in the san antonio criminal trial in the
brief part of it where the defense put
on witnesses
they brought a man into court who ran an
auto machine shop
and he brought with him
a sail slip or receipt
for about 10 days before the raid
and he testified that david koresh had
come into his shop that day to pick up a
motor
and then he showed the receipt of the
sail slip from the motor
and the question a lot of us have always
had was
why didn't you arrest koresh
when he was outside of mount carmel
and you had an undercover house 200
yards
from his front door
meaning you would have noticed when he
left and
came back
why do we only think of how did the raid
go wrong rather than think of was any
raid ever necessary
i can answer that one very simply we
had
looked at a number of ways to try to
arrest koresh off of the compound
the information that koresh told our
undercover agent robert rodriguez was
that he was afraid to leave the compound
because social services he felt like
would pick him up because of his
activity with the little girls on the
compound
our surveillance house if he left during
that time
it was not he was not seen leaving the
compound
we had talked about even possibly trying
to stage a
a wreck with a school bus
in front of the compound where maybe
they would come outside we could have
agents on the bus to possibly arrest him
there was one individual in the press
who claimed that koresh went out and ran
around the compound every morning which
was
totally bogus but he said why don't you
just hop over a five strand barbed wire
fence jump out there grab him drag him
back across the five-strand fence along
with his eight mighty men that he had
running with him and throw him in a car
and drag him away we didn't feel like
this was practical
we had even talked about having a
helicopter hover on the far side of a
one of the hills there very small hill
but then set off some sort of an
explosive device
to look like the helicopter had crashed
to possibly draw them out
so that we had been it we would be able
to
arrest quresh at that point
the bottom line is
if we had been able to arrest karesh off
of the compound
it would have made absolutely no
difference in the long run in that we
still had all of his mighty men inside
the compound who were under instructions
to carry out his orders no matter what
so we would have faced the same thing i
believe if we had had correction custody
the only possibility is if we could have
got correct to tell them uh look guys go
ahead and give up uh i'm already
arrested i'm gonna go to prison anyways
you guys give up too and i don't believe
that would have happened but yes there
were numerous ideas that were kicked
about to try to arrest him off of the
compound
thank you
i'd like to conclude with these thoughts
there's an inscription on the national
law enforcement officers memorial that
says it is not how these officers died
that made them heroes
is how they lived
and so with that in mind i'd like to
just remind everyone
who the four agents who died on february
28 1993 were
conrad lebloo
30 years old worked out of the new
orleans field office
he's now buried in lake charles
louisiana
son of a prominent louisiana lawyer
and he chose a different path of service
he served atf for five years a friend of
his said you are a hero
i guess most people forget in time some
of us haven't and won't his wife paige
was left behind along with two sons
scott and cameron and paige i might add
is a continuous supporter of the
national law enforcement officers
memorial fund she has found great
comfort in the memorial knowing that her
husband and her nation has not forgotten
him
todd mckeon aged 28 worked out of the
new orleans field office buried in
elizabethton
tennessee
one of his childhood friends was quoted
as saying he was an all-american boy
from boy scout to national honor society
he was very patriotic very gung-ho and
aggressive about serving his country
he had degrees in engineering technology
and criminal justice at east tennessee
state university
and
he served for three years as an atf
agent interrupted by service in
operation desert storm served with the
marine corps
his wife who he left behind leslie
they had been married just three days
before he left for desert storm
robert rob williams age 26 worked out of
the little rock arkansas field office
he's buried in brandon mississippi
he was born in baltimore raised in
jackson mississippi he died the day
before his 27th birthday he was a 1988
graduate of florida state university of
criminology and criminal justice and the
robert williams scholarship has been
established at florida state in his
memory it's awarded to a senior student
interested in a law enforcement career
he served atf for more than four years
left behind a wife cindy
stephen willis age 32 worked out of the
houston field office buried in houston
texas he was born in new orleans
graduated from southwest texas state
university had a degree in criminal
justice
each sunday he ate dinner with his
parents john and evelyn and his sister
lisa who was just 18 months younger they
talked on the phone almost daily
and a friend of his said stephen david
willis was a man and is now a soul of
honor he cherished his position with atf
and was willing to do whatever the
department needed to maintain order in
this crazy sometimes uncivilized world
it was very easy for anyone to see and
hear
just how proud he was
of his job
atf's jim cavanaugh who was there that
day in waco
he was involved in the negotiations with
david koresh he summed up the
contributions of all four of these men
this way
the price of liberty is always paid by
heroes and by beautiful families whose
belief in such freedoms
runs very deep
the siege at waco ended 51 days after it
started when a fire destroyed the
compound during a second assault 76 men
women and children died in the fire
including david koresh
soon after the waco siege ended a
memorial service was held at the
national law enforcement officers
memorial
more than a thousand people attended
including most if not all who
served at waco
afterwards one attendees told me
i've been told
i've been to a lot of funerals and
memorial services but coming here i
finally feel some closure
knowing they will be honored here at
this monument
at the time there were still many
questions being raised about what
happened in waco many ugly
characterizations of federal law
enforcement
but 20 years ago u.s attorney general
janet reno
summed up the matter this way
if we are going to have a civilization
and give the law any meaning in our
lives we cannot respond to the arrival
of police on our doorsteps by opening
fire on them
there is much to be angry about when we
talk about waco
and the government's conduct is not the
reason
david koresh is the reason
tonight as we approach the 20th
anniversary of the raided waco we
remember all those who served and
sacrificed
we want to thank our panelists pete
maston
jerry petrilli bill buford and dick
revis
for tonight's witness to history
i want to thank director jones and all
the atf officials who joined us as well
and helped to make tonight possible
thank you target for your sponsorship of
this program
thank you to c-span for filming
tonight's event and sharing uh this
discussion with many others
and thanks to all of our friends and
supporters who have joined us here
tonight this is the largest crowd we've
ever had for a witness to history event
and we thank you for making that
possible we're going to have coffee and
tea served afterwards for those who
would like to stay with us for a short
while we'll be open here until 9 00 pm
and you'll have a chance to visit with
our panelists please take that
opportunity
thank you all and good night
[Applause]
you're watching american history tv
all weekend every weekend on c-span more
about waco all weekend here on american
history tv
uh
bringing these tanks and stuff around
here i tell you what being an american
first
i'm the kind of guy
that i'll stand in front of a tank you
can run over me
but i'll be back in one of the tracks no
one's gonna hurt me or my family that's
that's that's american policy here
you could have arrested me any day as i
jog up and down this road you could have
arrested me going to town or going to
walmart
waco is going to bear witness against
the atf
and i do not appreciate it and never
will i ever appreciate somebody coming
here with two
helicopters and cattle cattle trailers
and all that
and uh pushing people around with guns
hey i'll meet you at the doorstep any
day
you know and somebody will get hurt if
you want to keep playing that game
i'm talking to you
somebody's gonna get hurt
david individuals inside the branch
davidian
compound exit the compound now
submit to the proper authority david
david you have had your 15 minutes of
fame it's time to leave the building
[Music]
in 1992 the bureau of alcohol tobacco
and firearms began investigating a group
outside of waco texas known as the
branch davidians it was believed that
the group was making illegal
modifications to firearms and were
stockpiling the weapons there had also
been accusations of child abuse brought
against the group's leader david koresh
the atf attempted to execute a search
warrant at the group's compound on
sunday morning february 28 1993.
a gun battle broke out between atf
agents and members of the branch
davidians inside
four agents were killed during the
shootout another 16 were injured five
branch davidians were also killed and
david koresh was wounded
what followed was a 51-day standoff
between federal agents and the davidians
the siege finally ended on april 19 1993
when the fbi under orders from attorney
general janet reno tried to gas the
members out of the building
fire broke out and spread throughout
killing 76 people inside including david
koresh
the
beginnings are with a fellow by the name
of victor hoddish
he was bulgarian and therefore he would
have been of the orthodox church but he
immigrated to illinois and
there he
visited
a service of the seventh-day adventist
church
which emphasized its its basic ideas the
return of christ the advent or the
second advent second coming of christ
and he was convinced by their teaching
so he left his original denomination
became a seventh-day adventist
and he
began to write his own literature and he
began to critique
parent seventh-day adventist church
thinking they were
not really
conforming to the teachings of the
church that they had relaxed a lot and
so he wanted to reform the church
and
so in the end the church rejected his
proposals for reform
and basically kicked him out of the
church so
he started looking for another place to
go and
sent out scouts and
finally decided on this area near waco
texas hadith was seen as a kind of a
divine figure like an elijah
or
like a john the baptist to announce the
the coming of the new kingdom so
in this tradition of the davidians
you have the notion of the importance
not only of scripture
as an authority but of a prophet and
recognizing what a prophet
can do for the community and his his
idea was it's like taking a scroll and
unrolling it and you find new
information
that you can read as you go along and he
said the prophet does that and so i'm
giving new insights
uh to you so this this is why then
other people will follow him so in 55
a fellow by the name of ben rhoden
who was familiar with and had been with
this teaching of of hadith uh and had
been with them
from time to time returned and said you
all are looking for a sign i'm the sign
i have
yet more information another message for
you and his idea
was that
to call this new movement
the branch what had been revealed to him
was that the the name
of this leader should be the branch and
of this movement so this is where we get
the the branch davidians
uh added on
uh he lived until 78 but meanwhile his
wife lois
also had a special teaching so when her
husband died
the followers just moved to her to to
lead them
and then she
lived another
[Music]
six eight years after that so she had
some
some influence until uh 86 is when she
died but when vernon howell
appeared
on the scene in 1980 81
very soon people began to look to him
and
he i think was considered the leader of
the movement by
83 84. so even before she was out of the
picture people began to be drawn to him
by virtue of his ability to
quote the bible string passages together
consider himself
a second messiah lamb of god or using
language such as that maybe god is the
one maybe not for sure but maybe god is
the one that's indicted a good manner
god speaks of the things he has made
revelation says god is a what
david koresh came here or vernon howell
who's changed his name to david koresh
came here in 1981
and
[Music]
he started um
you know basically saying that he had a
message and that god showed him things
and so lois studied with them and
um
it developed into a
um
to a point where
lois
called us all in 1984 in april of 1984
to come to mount carmel
and to
listen to what
vernon howell at that time had to say
and to see if he was going to be the
next spiritual leader
oh isaiah talked about a ravenous bird
from the east
a person
his name is koresh according to
scripture
some theology majors say well ancient
claresh which is english cyrus was a
persian king
but the mystery is is that
the ancient cyrus name was cyrus
but in isaiah 45 that cyrus his surname
is cyrus which is the last name
revelation says he has a new name he
hasn't known that no one knows but
himself his name is the word of god
you have to look at a lot of things to
catch the full picture
now he believed that he came to bring
judgment
on the church
and that he did because we had to judge
between truth and error
and whether we
should follow him or we should follow
the holy spirit
and
unfortunately or
it was prophesied that it would happen
that he was going to lead the leaders or
the church into apostasy so that meant
that the leaders the
elders
which represent the church
would have to go along with them and
they did
and um
they even rejected lois
as the spiritual leader
now she died two years later
so it allowed him to really take uh hold
[Music]
it's not against laws by a firearm it's
not against law
to buy anything that they sell at a gun
show
and when this is all resolved
you know
hey yellow sheet is legal
an accusation is not
the question of collection of firearms
there
is is much debated that was the basis as
i understand it for the the warrant for
the arrest and and so forth
but
to read the davidians many of them even
the leadership positions said that they
didn't know that that was going on or
what little they did know about it they
said was being used for uh a way to make
money uh just to you know to go to a gun
show and
and
sell these for profit
so that but uh using that as a uh
a method of of making
money
you know caused some eyebrows to be
raised i'm sure because
if you're coming from a
uh basically pacifist or conscientious
objection tradition
to uh that well
then
then the claim obviously is well it's
just to make money we weren't there to
um
to do battle with anybody so forth so
that was uh
that was a difference then uh koresh's
theology
he argued that he was supposed to sp uh
sire the 24 elders
that are mentioned in the book of
revelation to be the
there at the last judgment and so forth
and to do that uh he
said that he would uh
cohabit with the wives of uh the men who
were there the married uh couples and so
forth so this was a huge
transition as well the question is
what am i doing
what am i doing with all these children
you know what's really going on here
well you know
god is god and this nation is supposed
to
honor and serve god this isn't god we
trust on our currency
and these children that i have are for a
reason
and unless we really have the ear
and the eyes to open ourselves up to be
able to read really read the scriptures
and understand the prophecies in a lot
of the seven seals
the explanation would seem almost
foolish
so
there again this this would be um
you know contrary to what victor hoduff
had said certainly in terms of
uh you know we we
want to live
holy lives and we want to be separate
from the world and so forth so this
looks like a really a sea change
in terms of this individual and his
influence but
um on the other hand
the the davidians will you know
say some of them will say well
if this was what he saw as the will of
god it was time to have these uh
children born
and who better to do that than the
messiah or the representative of god
then they you know they have their
rationale but i think most outsiders
would pretty severely question that
david individuals inside the branch
davidian compound
we are in the process of placing tear
gas into the building
exit the compound now
submit to the proper authority david
[Music]
during the siege the fbi
came to me
and they asked me if i knew
um
you know karesh and i told them yes i
did
so i told them i can go in there and
defuse the situation i can tell karesh
that he's brought the attention of the
world
he's done
uh what he was called to do
and
to come out
and he'd be better off to come out alive
and teach the truth
than
you know
come out dead
but the prophecy said he would die
so they said no we can't let you go
there we've got negotiators and so on
and so forth and i said okay
[Music]
madam attorney general
i am extremely
disappointed
in the decisions that have been made out
of the department of justice
the federal bureau of investigation
the
agency of alcohol tobacco and firearms
now when in god's name is the law
enforcement
at the federal level
going to understand that these
are very sensitive
events
that you can't
put barbed wire
guns fbi
secret service around them
send in sound 24 hours a day at night
and then wonder
why they do something unstable
nothing we do now can change the
suffering felt by the families of the
atf agents
or the families of those who perished in
the compound
we must do everything we can
to learn from these events
about what we can do in the future
to prevent people like david korish or
people motivated by other
thoughts from causing such a senseless
horrible loss of human life
i think that this this was a
you know a learning experience as well i
think
we've had
a lot of care in handling
little groups
since that time and i don't
i would hope that both sides have
learned something from from all of that
and
the constitution says that that we
should make no laws establishing
religion nor preventing the free
exercise of religion and so here are
little groups that want to
exercise this freedom
to pursue
their understanding and they're living
out of christianity as they feel is
appropriate and i think
generally the
the nation has
supported that
it's when you move from your belief
system into some practices that are seen
to be
dangerous to others or harmful in some
way
that
you might expect government intervention
so
who participated in the raid that's
tonight's c-span lineup
[Music]
next the senate judiciary committee
looks into the march 1993 incident at
the branch davidian compound in waco
texas witnesses testifying during this
portion of today's hearing include
several professors as well as atf
special agents who participated in the
raid the house judiciary committee held
similar hearings in july this is the
first of two days of hearings before the
senate judiciary committee which is
chaired by orrin hatch of utah this
first portion of the hearing runs just
over three hours
is that wrong
over the years
i had been a very strong enforce a
strong supporter of federal law
enforcement
both of its people and agencies and i
still am
however in recent years in recent months
law enforcement at both the federal and
state levels
has been subject has been the subject of
much scrutiny and criticism
i sense the frustration of those men and
women of high integrity who are true
public servants
employed to enforce our nation's laws
and who often endanger their own lives
in the process
not surprisingly there is a growing
sentiment in law enforcement that they
are
being unfairly treated
recent tragedies and other troubling
news stories they feel are being used by
the media and by some in congress to
undermine public confidence and those we
have hired to protect the public
to those brave men and women i say this
senator shares your concern
i want nothing but the best for you who
served with the fbi atf dea and every
other law enforcement
agency
and that includes fair recognition for
the sacrifices you make
but i also want what's best for the
public
and that's a that's something that is is
part of these hearings
we want what's best for the public as a
whole
it is for this reason that i am
particularly saddened by the events that
have transpired in the last three years
such events have not responded to will
permanently erode the public's
confidence in federal law enforcement in
our country
this we cannot allow to happen
this hearing is not an effort to place
blame on any individual or on the
administration
indeed we will be examining the systemic
bureaucratic problems and policies at
atf and fbi that resulted in the tragedy
at waco
the mandate for this committee is to
ensure that tragedies like the one at
waco i am specifically referring to the
deaths of the residents of mount carmel
center
including 25 children and to the four
atf agents who were killed in the line
of duty
are never again associated with a law
enforcement operation
what i find most troubling
is that the american people now perceive
law enforcement as it is suggested in
this picture over here and i just point
to poster number one
contrary to what one may think when
first glancing at this photograph
this picture is not a soldier fighting
for peace
in the gulf war or as or in somalia
rather it is an fbi agent at waco it is
my absolute belief that this is not the
image that the framers of our
constitution had in mind
when they carefully constructed that
sacred document
it is certainly not how i perceive the
fbi
nor is it the image held by the legions
of american citizens who have worked
with and been helped by the fbi over the
years
ask the parent
of a missing child
ask a senior citizen in my own home
state of utah whose life's savings were
saved when the fbi shut down a
fraudulent telemarketing racket that
preyed on seniors
and you could go through countless other
innumerable
illustrations
but sadly the image in this poster is
the image many people now have
and it is imperative that we address
these concerns
i hope that the americans who serve in
federal law enforcement will see this
hearing as an opportunity
my mother used to tell me that whenever
i made a mistake i should learn lessons
from it correct my actions or my
thinking and then move on
this hearing is an opportunity to find
the lessons in this tragedy make
necessary corrections in our actions or
our thinking and then move on
it is with these ideas in mind that this
committee conducted its investigation
into the events at wacom
and in this framework i intend to
conduct these hearings
we have met with heard from and examined
information from numerous federal
agencies private citizens activist
groups and the media
in excess of three hundred thousand
documents and seven hundred hours of
videotape and audio tape have been
analyzed and dozens of interviews have
been conducted in preparation for these
hearings
let me be clear this investigation has
not uncovered any evidence of political
corruption
or influences we have not found any of
that
there was no conspiracy to kill branch
davidians
what the investigation has uncovered
is that there are several troubling
patterns which have developed in federal
law enforcement
over the next two days we hope to
discuss just what those patterns are
as well as review what congress and the
american people expect from their law
enforcement agencies
this country is based on the principles
embodied in the constitution
fundamental to this document is the
concept that government must be kept
within bounds
the fourth amendment ironically a
charred copy of the very amendment
was found in the debris
at waco and that's poster number two
there's the charred copy that was found
right there
at waco guarantees
this fourth amendment guarantees
the right of the people to be secure in
their persons houses papers and effects
in my opinion the handling of this
situation by federal law enforcement was
not in keeping with that principle
americans have come to expect that law
enforcement's primary responsibility
is the investigation of crime and
protection of the public
not the frightening of people via
paramilitary units
having had the benefit of the ruby ridge
hearings the house of representatives
hearings on waco and the enormous
documentation regarding these matters
i believe it is in the best interest of
this committee the u.s senate and most
importantly of the american public to
air these concerns further we must
establish a level of oversight over the
management of law enforcement agencies
that will ensure that debacles like ruby
ridge and waco will never happen again
to that end i would like to briefly
outline what will be addressed at these
hearings
the first day of this two-day hearing
will focus on the collecting and
processing of intelligence information
by the bureau of alcohol tobacco and
firearms
atf's failure to adequately collect and
analyze the relevant and available
information on david koresh and his
followers
directly resulted in a plan that didn't
did not properly assess the mindset
of the davidians
atf only considered information that
supported the tactical approach it had
pre-selected
no contingencies were ever developed
it defies logic that any law enforcement
agency would attempt to accomplish such
an operation without a contingency plan
especially a plan that puts more than
100 agents in harm's way
this fatal flaw paved the way for the
tragic deaths of four brave young
dedicated law enforcement officers
the second day the committee will
carefully examine the relationship
between the fbi negotiators and the fbi
hostage rescue team or the hrt
at the heart of this debate is the
degree to which the employment
of an hrt is appropriate in u.s law
enforcement operations
i believe it is appropriate in many
instances but not so in others
these people are
people who risk their lives for us but
they should be used very sparingly
this issue is particularly relevant in
barricade situations
in the case of waco there appears to
have been tension between those who felt
that a military-style response was
appropriate
and those who believed that the
negotiation process would be more
effective
although i am a proponent of using the
hrt in appropriate
situations the question whether waco and
ruby ridge were two of those
circumstances does arise
unfortunately there are numerous
situations where hrt has been
successfully employed
but ha but have not made the newspapers
i am aware that many of these successes
both domestically and overseas are
situations that could not have been
resolved without the use of the hostage
rescue team
however i firmly believe that
paramilitary units such as hrt
must be employed against u.s citizens as
a last resort not as the first
one of the major problems at waco
appears to have been the infusion of hrt
tactics into the negotiations process
such an infusion served to work at cross
purposes with what was
a successful negotiation strategy
negotiations had successfully resulted
in the release of a number of men women
and most importantly children
although we will never know whether a
strict negotiation strategy would have
been completely successful if it had
been allowed to play out
it is clear that the mechanism for
continuing negotiations was available to
the fbi
as there was no escalation on the level
of threat or violence by the davidians
the use of military style tactics by hrt
was arguably not appropriate or
necessary in conclusion i look forward
to hearing from the administration as to
how they intend to ensure that tragedies
like ruby ridge
and waco are never repeated so i stand
ready to work constructively with them
toward this goal and i believe this
committee as a whole does as well
we'll now turn to our to our republican
uh excuse me our democrat leader on the
committee
uh senator happening all too often mr
chairman
mr chairman uh thank you and good
morning uh
the stated goal of these two days of
hearings on the siege at waco uh
is in my view a good one
to discuss with two federal law
enforcement agencies involved in the
siege a number of important changes in
policies and practices they have
implemented in order to improve their
operations and to reduce the possibility
that another tragedy like waco could
occur in the future
both agencies have candidly admitted
that
serious mistakes occurred at waco and
that improvements
needed to be made
this hearing provides a forum to
evaluate these new policies and
procedures and to ensure that the
changes made are the right ones and that
implementation is complete and effective
but i believe it's important that these
hearings
serve a second goal as well
and that is to put the incident at waco
with all the mistakes that were made
into its proper context
let me make this point absolutely clear
there is no place in our country for
racist cops like
mark furman there's no place in our
country for abusive cops there's no
place in our country for law enforcement
bent on the use of unjustified force
but there's a big difference between
mistakes and malevolence
the record of the waco incident
documents mistakes
mistakes in
gathering intelligence mistakes and
planning and executing operational plans
and law enforcement should and must be
held accountable for such mistakes
but the record from waco does not
evidence however
is any improper motive or intent
on the part of law enforcement
i believe this is a very important point
to make to the american public because
there are growing number of people
across the country
who are seizing on the incident at waco
as well as ruby ridge to suggest that
law enforcement is our enemy
this suggestion is powerful because
every federal law enforcement officer
is entrusted with one of the most
important powers the public bestows upon
its government
the authority to investigate and
prosecute violations of our laws in
particular the criminal laws of the
united states
but this suggestion stands in conflict
not only with the record from waco but
with the excellent overall record of the
federal law enforcement agencies
including both the atf and the fbi
it stands in conflict with the vast
majority of federal law enforcement
officers
that who deserve our trust
they are hard-working dedicated
professionals who protect the public
every day
and as we saw in waco and in many other
instances by giving their lives not just
putting them in the line
so as we examine the mistakes made by
atf and the fbi
i think it's very important that we as
elected members of this government
to keep certain key facts in mind
first
that the atf had a legitimate and very
important reason to be at waco in the
first place
that is to serve warrants
on those reasonably suspected of
violating the federal criminal law
second
that the fbi had a legitimate and very
important reason
to get david koresh and the davidians
out of their fortified compound
and brought to justice
the davidians had responded to the
agents attempting to serve lawful
warrants
by killing for
and wounding 21.
third
and in the end
david koresh and the davidians set fire
to themselves
and committed suicide
government did not do that
and finally
keep in mind one other fact
and that is the changing nature of
criminal activity
and the very difficult problem this
creates for american law enforcement
the days of the fbi with this trustee
revolver are over
today's criminals are armed with
automatic and semi-automatic weapons
including high-caliber armor-piercing
ammunition
consider for example
that the atf and fbi agents of waco
were facing a group that was heavily
armed
in addition to numerous fully automatic
and semi-automatic rifles there were
grenades
rocket projectile and one million rounds
of ammunition
not your usual walk in the park
the davidians possessed two anti-tank
armored piercing long-range assault
weapons as well
i'd like to show you this is an example
of the ammunition used in these guns
this is uh
this is a
serious piece
of
weaponry
for comparison's sake let me show you
the ammunition that is standard issue
nine millimeter handgun carried by
law enforcement
it's changing time
bonnie and clyde didn't walk around
with this
this is a different world
in which these poor these poor
folks find themselves
as they go out to enforce our laws
in short
law enforcement today
faces criminals armed with military
style weapons
law enforcement today
faces terrorist bombings like we've
never seen in our history as a nation
like that occurred in oklahoma
and also
other deadly acts of sabotage
the safety of the public as well as law
enforcement officers themselves
requires capabilities unthought of even
10 years ago
now of course these capabilities carry
with them
responsibility
that did not exist at the same degree
before
we have to ensure that our federal law
enforcement receives the best training
and the best leadership possible
this in my view is the context in which
we must consider the actions of atf
and that the fbi have taken in waco
some of the specific questions i'll pose
to the panel of witnesses today includes
what is the process by which atf and fbi
now formulate operational plans for
difficult situations like waco
how do we ensure
that teams planning operations
receive the best intelligence possible
and the best information
from relevant experts
and what is appropriate for the hostage
rescue teams when is it appropriate for
hospital rescue hostage rescue teams to
be dispatched
are there written guidelines governing
the use of these teams
fourthly
how is the inherent tension
between negotiations and action
between the carrot and the stick
to be handled in these types of
situations
how do we best equip on-site
commanders in hostage or
resistance type situations
to strike the elusive balance between
negotiations
and increased pressure needed to reach
resolution
these are there's no question that waco
was a terrible tragedy
and that in many respects federal law
enforcement handled difficult situations
badly
and both the atf and the fbi
made numerous
significant changes structural and
operational in an effort to use the
lessons of waco to avoid future
tragedy these are what we should be
looking at as well
these hearings will serve an important
goal if they convey to the american
public
how seriously their government takes the
responsibility
of law enforcement
and that
responding to the shortcoming scene at
waco
we made priority efforts to see to it
that federal law enforcement agencies
the ones involved
in fact made changes
i look forward to discussing these and
other issues with the witnesses who will
testify today and tomorrow and i join
senator hatch in welcoming all of you
here today and thank you mr chairman for
these hearings well thank you senator
biden we will begin our our hearings by
introducing our first panel
the purpose of this panel is set forth
uh in a general manner
uh is to set forth in a general manner
how a law enforcement agency should
conduct information and intelligence
gathering in order to formulate a
successful operational plan
to help us get a clear understanding as
to what should be done
uh we have dr james fife who is a
professor of criminal justice and a
senior policy research fellow
at temple university in philadelphia
dr feif is a 20-year veteran of the new
york police department and since his
retirement in 1979
has actively worked in the academic
world of criminal justice
he has testified many times as a police
practices expert before congress and in
both state and federal courts
dr feiff will begin by providing a brief
overview of the type of information and
intelligence gathering that is necessary
in large-scale law enforcement
operations
we will also hear from dr nancy amerman
who is currently a professor of
sociology of religion at the center for
social and religious research at the
hartford seminary in connecticut
dr amerman received her phd from yale
and has published numerous pieces on
various religious liberty issues
moreover she served on the experts panel
which provided recommendations to the
departments of justice and treasury with
respect to the incidents at waco
dr amerman will discuss types of
information sources which were available
to law enforcement to help formulate a
successful plan
at the heart of dr ammerman's
that the more law enforcement knows
about its targets the better
so we welcome both of you to the
committee we look forward to your
testimony
rise as much as you can we will put your
complete statements in the record as
though fully delivered so we'll turn to
you dr feinstein chairman before you
begin may ask a question yes um uh
we have uh three panels uh today
uh one of which the third panel is a
panel that i asked to be assembled that
um and uh i may not be able to be here
this afternoon is it is it appropriate
to ask i mean i'd like to ask uh
you to consider moving panel three to
panel two and alternating like we
usually do with uh panels of majority
minority and
i don't recall ever not doing that yeah
well we we've tried to have this flow in
a certain way let's try and get to it
and see what happens and if if we can't
let's let's consider that at that time
but i'd like it to flow in in this way
so that we first talk to the people who
raise these issues then talk to those
who who were there and then then go on
from there so that we can ultimately
resolve what really has to be done but
we'll certainly we'll certainly look at
that let's let's see if we can move
through this morning and if we can get
this all done this morning well i'm
going to ask formally that panel 3 be
moved after this panel mr chairman we
finish this pan i'd like you to do that
like i said i don't ever recall it's not
all the radio alternating between a
majority minority panel well i don't
ever recall that but let's let's
hopefully certainly look at it and see
what we can do mr five dr fife will turn
to you first morning senator it's an
honor and a privilege to be with you uh
to discuss the implications for law
enforcement of the waco disaster
before i do that
i should point out that i agree with
senator biden and
i don't believe that
waco involved any finality on the part
of law enforcement officials i think
there were some very serious mistakes
made
i also believe that what happened that
waco cannot be considered in a vacuum
or to have meaning only at the federal
level
waco is one of the latest in a long
series of law enforcement related
debacles
during my career as a practitioner and
student of law enforcement these have
included many of the 1960s urban riots
attica the sla shootout the move bombing
the rodney king beating and the police
response to the riot that followed and
the o.j simpson trial the corruption
scandals that regularly seem to haunt
some police agencies
and of course ruby ridge
these illest incidents illustrate the
heart of this committee's deliberations
the need for further development and
dissemination of standards to guide law
enforcement field operations and where
such standards are in place the need for
mechanisms to ensure compliance with
them
waco did not happen because there were
no standards to guide authorities on the
day of the atf raid or on the day of the
fire
waco happened because well-known and
well-established arrest hostage and
barricade protocols were ignored
i know that you indicated that i would
talk about the kinds of intelligence
that need to be gathered and
basically they're not very sophisticated
they're very much the same as what the
military and the fire service
and and heart surgeons know that before
you commit yourself to a
life-threatening situation
should find out as much as possible
about what you're getting into
in the same way that mistakes were made
at waco
unnecessary blood was shed at ruby ridge
not because they were in place no
standards for such an encounter
instead somebody tore up existing
well-reasoned standards on the way to
that place and substituted his own
nobody should be fooled into believing
that the new deadly force policy issued
a couple of weeks ago is actually a new
policy or that it will serve as a model
for local police to emulate or that it
will prevent future ruby ridges
this new policy is a restatement of the
fbi's long-term rules for deadly force
and mirrors in every substantive way
the constitutional requirements laid out
by the united states supreme court a
decade ago and tennessee versus garner
indeed as any informed local police
official knows any policy less
restrictive than this new one would be
unconstitutional
at ruby ridge as at waco the problem was
not the absence of rules the problem was
that the rules were ignored
my background and orientation are in
local policing and there is much that
can be learned from the experiences of
local police
local police know
that they must answer to investigation
by another totally independent level of
government
the u.s justice department's federal
bureau of investigation and civil rights
division and increasingly to independent
and representative civilian review and
advisory boards
there is no fbi to investigate the fbi
there is no justice department to
investigate the justice department there
should be
there is no independent nonpartisan
citizen review of incidents like ruby
ridge and waco
there should be
federal legislators should seriously
investigate the feasibility of creating
an independent body to oversee and
review the actions of federal law
enforcement
in addition the senate and house should
begin with the executive branch a
serious discussion of how a citizens
advisory and review panel perhaps along
the lines of the u.s civil rights
commission could be created
because of my orientation to local
policing i would like to spend a minute
on it
this is
at the state or local level when police
encounters go bad it is usually not
because the rules are ignored it's
usually because poorly supervised and
trained officers simply did not know
what to do
this is a problem that causes bloodshed
and riots and i urge this committee to
examine it most carefully during these
deliberations
the development and dissemination of
performance standards in law enforcement
has focused at the management level and
has been much less influential at the
line level
in the late 1970s the justice department
funded an effort by the four major law
enforcement professional groups to
develop standards for the administration
of law enforcement agencies
these groups did so and laid the
groundwork for the commission on
accreditation for law enforcement
agencies of which i'm a commissioner
to date kalia has accredited nearly 400
state and local enforcement law
enforcement agencies
kalia standards also serve
as the blueprint for administering many
thousands more
i'm proud to serve as a kalia
commissioner but i'm frustrated that our
standards affect primarily the
management of law enforcement services
rather than the direct delivery of law
enforcement services
this is unfortunate and not much
different from professionalizing
hospital administration but not surgery
or professionalizing court management
but not trial practice
many arguments against development and
dissemination of standards for the
direct delivery of law enforcement
services have been offered
since no two law enforcement situations
are exactly alike some claim it is
neither realistic nor desirable to
attempt to develop guidelines for the
exercise of discretion in emergencies or
to attempt to hold personnel accountable
for abiding but
all other life threat all other life or
death occupations face infinitely
varying emergencies
but with rare exception they hold their
members to clear but flexible standards
imagine being treated in an emergency
room by a cardiologist who improvised in
every case because he felt that no two
heart attacks were exactly alike for
allowing generals to tear up rules of
engagement on route to the front because
no two battles are exactly alike
the single best thing that this
committee could do for the cause of
effective law enforcement would be to
help define effective law enforcement
and to ensure that all u.s law
enforcement officers were trained to do
it and were held accountable for doing
it
by now
we all know what it takes to be a good
police manager and in the law
enforcement community we've made folk
heroes of the best police managers
unfortunately we have yet to define the
good cop in a way that can be agreed
upon articulated and systematically
turned into training that will clone
other good cops
it has been a generation since the last
federal studies of law enforcement in
the united states
both of these efforts president
johnson's commission on law enforcement
and the administration of justice and
president nixon's national advisory
commission on criminal justice standards
and goals have had enormous and positive
effects on police management
we now need an investigation of the
state of street-level policing and
federal law enforcement and a commitment
to professionalizing and developing
standards for it to developing good cops
and good agents and to assuring that
nobody else polices our streets thank
you well thank you dr
dr amberman we'll turn to you
yes
i want to commend you on having these
hearings in the kind of atmosphere that
i have so far
seen this morning
i'm here as a sociologist who studies
conservative religious movements and got
drawn into
the waco affair
at being asked to serve on the panel of
experts for the justice and treasury
departments but i'm also here as a
citizen concerned about law enforcement
in our rather complex democracy
i am convinced that at the heart of the
disaster in waco was the decision first
by the batf and then by fbi tactical
units
to treat this as primarily a
military-style
operation once that decision was made
everyone's energy went into assessing
firepower and angles of attack and
leaving the human dimension
of the situation too easily forgotten
it's my contention that it is essential
in any action that involves a dissident
religious or political group
that
law enforcement remember that these are
first of all human actors who do not in
the in the main define themselves
primarily in military terms and neither
should we
we should be making every effort to
understand the logic of their religious
beliefs and proceed with full respect
for their citizenship rights even if
they seem utterly outlandish to us and
even if they may have broken the law
i've argued in the materials that you
have before you that keeping the human
dimension central in law enforcement
requires that behavioral science advice
be more widely available
and that it carry more strategic clout
i've made several specific suggestions
about how that might be possible i'll be
glad to discuss with you further
but for now let me simply make a few
remarks about why this is important
by offering three rather obvious
examples of how behavioral science
advice might have changed what
happened at waco
first behavioral scientists would
probably have advised the batf that
their estimation of the danger posed by
the davidians in spite of all the
armaments that they had was probably
overblown
that that overestimate occurred it seems
to me because the batf's primary source
of information was a deprogrammed
ex-member
social scientists
after studying dozens of people who have
left high-intensity religious groups
have noted that those who have been
deprogrammed are especially likely to be
bitter and to exaggerate the evils of
the group
behavioral science advice then might
have made it possible for batf to
imagine other ways to approach this case
second and ever so obviously
sociologists and social psychologists
certainly would have advised that any
group under siege is likely to turn
inward
to bond to each other not to break apart
to follow their leader ever more
strongly that rather than to find him
discredited
outside pressure only consolidates the
group's view that outsiders are the
enemy
in this case something exacerbated by
the religious group beliefs of this
group
and isolation cutting off communication
only decreases the available information
that the group might have to counter
their internal view of the world
and third people who study religious
groups
have learned to take seriously the
religious beliefs and rhetoric of the
group
we understand the power of religious
symbols to create its own alternative
while what that group says may
dabble as it did to the negotiators in
waco
no real negotiation is possible unless
the group's religious worldview is taken
as the operative one
this case in short highlights the need
for law enforcement to take seriously
the complex human dynamics of the
situation that it confronts
when those situations include religious
groups
why strategists will take seriously the
power of those religious beliefs
and will weigh carefully the competing
claims of religious liberty against the
legitimate societal limits that need to
be placed on that liberty
thank you well thank you we appreciate
your testimony we will have uh one round
of 10 minutes each
uh for questioning and maybe i can start
it off let me just ask you dr fife
how can federal law enforcement agencies
be better prepared
so the appropriate response to crisis
situations like waco
is both considered and available
i think the question is one of
accountability senator
i i don't think that there's any doubt
that federal law enforcement agencies
are the best trained in the united
states and i think the standards exist
the protocols exist
the principles are there for negotiating
rather than shooting
out of situations and i think the major
issue is a sort of disregard and a sense
that
the rules are more flexible than they
really are so uh the thing that has
troubled me about both these incidents
was that when i look at federal rules
and policies for potentially violent
encounters i understand that they're
made for unusual crisis situations it
seems to me that in both these
situations those rules were disregarded
on grounds that these were critical
unusual crisis situations
i i think the question is how we get
people to abide by the rules that
already exist well you've discussed
today the importance of proper research
and i uh
and and information gathering as well
when developing a law enforcement
operations plan
when is likely to happen when
you have situations when research
collection and intelligence
processing are not properly conducted
you get unhappy endings to situations
i've
learned this at the local level with
police officers who work on an
individual basis and the thrust of
training for police officers on patrol
around the country is to try and get
them to learn about the areas where they
work to plan for the kind of predictable
emergencies that they'll run into
and when they do that they're much more
likely to produce a happy bloodless
ending to crisis situations the same
thing holds true at
the larger level at the macro level like
this situation has there been a change
in in the pattern and practice of law
enforcement with respect to tactics
versus negotiations say over the past
decade i'm concerned that there is
i come from an unusual place i suppose i
was a new york cop for many years and we
took great pride in being the place that
basically developed hostage and
barricade negotiation procedures i think
frank bowles will testify tomorrow is
really the pioneer of all that
and our definition of success in a
hostage or barricade situation was
always a bloodless resolution and people
worked as hard as possible and as long
as possible to obtain that result
what i see in this situation and in
several others at the local level lately
there's a real tension between the
negotiator and the tactical people i
spoke not too long ago to a person who
was a sniper for a municipal police
department and just the title uh sniper
for a police department bothers me it's
it's really has nothing at all to do
with community policing but his view was
that there are two approaches to hostage
situations one he called the western
view and the other is an eastern view
and the eastern view is the one to which
i subscribe and that is that police
officers should take as much time as
possible to negotiate people out of
situations and should define success in
the absence of bloodshed uh his view of
the western uh protocol was that police
officers should regard negotiations as a
means of manipulating people into
positions where a tactical execution
could be executed a tactical resolution
could be executed i'm very troubled by
that i don't find anything in written
standards that conform to it but i've
seen lots of incidents where that seems
to have been uh operative
well thank you dr amerman uh i was
interested in your comments very much
and and your written statement which is
uh even more detailed how can federal
law enforcement agencies be better
prepared so the appropriate response and
crisis situation that's both considered
and available
i think there are a variety of things
that need to be done one is to really
start at the basic training level uh so
that when people are in the field they
not only have the set of guidelines uh
that mr fife is talking about but that
they have
a background that sensitizes them to
behavioral science kind of information
so that when they hear behavioral
science advice and voices this is not
something new to them uh that they're
not utterly existing in a culture in
which tactical force is the only way to
enforce the law
also
i think it's very important for the
federal government
to have available to it people who are
more special have more specialized
training and
dealing with the particular kinds of
situations we saw at waco fortunately
that doesn't crop up every day so we
don't need every agent on the line to
have that kind of training but we do
need to have a pool of people who spend
more time
uh
finding out about religious and
political uh groups that may in fact
pose a problem for the rest of us in
society and how we can respond to them
without bloodshed
so that those kinds of specialized units
need to be then be available to all of
the federal law enforcement agencies
i think it's also
uh this situation has provided a kind of
opportune moment for us to realize that
there is in fact a large pool of
expertise potentially available to
federal law enforcement but that we need
to have regular forms of communication
between the academic community and
federal law enforcement that allow
that larger pool of expertise to be
called on in situations like this so
that people are not faced with the
situation of being in the field on the
spot trying to figure out who's an
expert and who's not well tell us tell
us the best way that you have
for federal law enforcement to tap into
the network of experts
and consultants who might be available
in the private sector to help them in
the
not only in these type of situations but
to prepare for these type of situations
well there are a number of professional
academic associations that seem to be
quite uh
logical places to go for situations like
this the american sociological
association
the american psychological association
for religious groups the association for
sociology of religion the society for
the scientific study of religion the
american academy of religion number of
well-recognized professional
organizations that maintain offices that
can be very helpful so that with one
phone call
recommendations can be made about
a series of people who might be
particularly helpful in a situation like
this thank you just one other question
uh before we turn to senator biden
you've discussed today the proper or the
importance of proper research and and
information gathering when developing a
law enforcement operations plan
you've suggested that experts in various
fields be consulted before an
operational plan has been developed
and i know that one of the concerns that
law enforcement people have is that
experts or academicians might possibly
tip off
the suspect group that a federal agency
is investigating
do you perceive that as a real concern
and if it is how do you prevent that
from happening
it seems to me that the academics i know
would certainly be
eager to work with law enforcement in
responsibly helping us as a society to
deal with difficult situations and would
be more than willing to
abide by the kinds of strictures that
that law enforcement agency
felt to be necessary in planning for an
operation
those are situations that i can imagine
potentially being difficult situations
of conscience perhaps
for an academic who felt perhaps that he
or she had
more than one loyalty
but i also know that we
who are scholars of religious groups
also feel a large sense of loyalty to
our larger society and are more than
willing to participate in helping
to make our society a more
hospitable place for all of us
all right senator biden we'll turn to
you thank you very much i want to thank
you both uh for being here uh
um and your uh and for your for your
input not only today but through this
process this is you i want to make it
clear to the public you may be watching
you're not new to this um you're not new
to this incident either and i uh dr
pfeiff i uh
want to make this may hurt you more than
help you but uh
your book
above the law is uh the uh
the text from which i quite frankly uh
um uh
used and my staff used
uh to write the police brutality
provisions and the crime law that we
have in the law
and
and how to target departments based on
pattern or practices of abuse it was
very helpful to us i hope you like the
final product that we put in the law i
don't know i'm not that's not the reason
for the hearing but i
the point is to indicate to you that i
have great respect for you and uh and
have already taken advantage of your uh
of your expertise hopefully uh in a
positive way thanks senator i i really
appreciate that and i uh i'm very
impressed with the wording of the law i
um i really don't
please don't be offended if i don't have
questions i think your statement was
clear and concise uh to the point i have
won uh one request uh maybe it should be
a question
i agree with your notion of it would be
nice if we could define what quote a
good cop is
and have you ever attempted to do that i
mean literally attempted to do that in
writing i don't recall it from the book
maybe i missed it but i i mean have you
has any that been undertaken uh by you
or any other academics you're you're
aware of uh yes it has and uh i i've
written about it a bit uh my experience
as a police officer was that all cops
knew who the good cops were they were
the officers people wanted to work with
who didn't get into trouble who were
predictable and not crazy and always had
the right right answer
so
what we tried to do with an experiment
in dade county was to ask police
officers to identify the persons among
them who are the good cops and then to
ask those officers to sit down and tell
us how they would respond to different
potentially violent situations so
we gave those officers a
a group
a sample of a hundred incidents that had
gone bad in the sense that they resulted
in some use of force or injury or
complaint against a police officer and
to ask them to tell us what decisions
the officers had made and how those had
affected the outcome in negative ways
we then built those things into training
trying to clone the good cop and what
the good cop knew and put them out on
the street and i can tell you that since
1989 when everybody in the metro david
police department was trained in these
principles the outcomes we were looking
for complaints against officers use of
force by officers and assault sign
officers have all declined by 30 to 50
percent that's great do you is there an
actual manual or a copy or i i would i'd
certainly make that available to you
with the permission of the chairman i
think that'd be very important to be
made available for the record and i
personally would like to see it as well
sure i think the important point there
is to start by asking the people who
know the officers best and who have the
most success in resolving potentially
violent situations and trying to take
what they know systematize it and give
it to other officers and agents which
leads me to the next point and i only
have one question for you dr hammerman
but
it's amazing to me just in the years
that i have been a united states senator
and not having worked with cops as a cop
but worked with cops as a public
defender
i mean being in the middle of it and in
the family court in juvenile justice
systems before i had this job
how drastically things have changed
in terms of what police perceive to be
and i would argue reality
indicates has occurred what police
perceived to be though for the sake of
discussion
their changed circumstance their
increased vulnerability
their
their
their
in some cases almost intractable dilemma
they send to find find themselves in
because of the nature of a whole range
of things that i wish i had the time
to discuss with you as a sociologist i
am i don't not this will make it clear
discuss you as you as the sociologist me
as a student um
uh and one of the things that i think
that has precipitated
is whether it's i remember uh uh
professor uh dr fife when you were on
the new york police department the big
issue was saturday night specials
i mean god willing to bring back
saturday night specials wouldn't that be
wonderful that was our problem again you
know these guns that blew up in the
hands of the assailant half the time if
we only had those instead of mack nines
or whatever i mean so the whole thing
has changed
it seems to me in terms of not the human
dimension what causes people to do what
they do although i think that's
circumstances aggravated those
factors as well
but we have a whole new phenomenon here
hopefully waco is a case of first
instance and last repetition
in that
we haven't had to deal with we haven't
had to think about
terrorism which is not waco we have not
had to think about terrorism on our
shores i i've been involved in this for
a long time in the intelligence
committee and then in the judiciary
committee and the terrorism subcommittee
and you know we that was something that
happened somewhere else the idea that
something would happen like happened in
the tokyo subway or something would
happen like just happened in in in
europe in the subway system i mean
that's not that doesn't happen here not
made in america
secondly the idea that we'd have and i
sort of to avoid an unnecessary argument
that has nothing to do with the with
what my point i'm about to make for the
sake of discussion let me exclude the
branch davidians what i'm about to say
but the idea that there has been a
generation of several wacko groups out
there not waco wacko groups that
premise their actions upon religious
activity
our religious beliefs whether it's uh
something coming out of the becca valley
or whether it's in uh in uh in in the
middle east or whether it's something
coming out of uh the mountains of idaho
or the plain or the uh or the fields of
delaware i mean
it's a new phenomenon
in terms of our dealing with it as a
matter that could or may or may not
impact upon the safety health and
well-being of the participants as well
as the citizenry at large
and so i kind of view this
as a place from which to start um
in hindsight we could say we should have
started five years ago or 10 years ago
or 20 years ago um but but as we start
from here one of the things that
intrigues me uh professor amberman is
your um
comments uh and your in your statement
and your report
uh where you emphasize the important how
important is for law enforcement to know
the views of behavioral scientists on
page 90 report you conclude and i quote
knowing these things might not have
changed the outcome in waco it is
unclear to me whether any negotiating
strategy could have succeeded in getting
most or all the members to leave the
compound
and the reason i quote that and i
sincerely mean this i'm not trying to be
argumentative here but i'm trying to
understand
where does that leave us if after months
of thought that went into your report
you're still unsure as to whether
further negotiation would have changed
the result in the marked way
if you are a field commander
and your behavioral scientist says it's
unclear or you've got several other
reasons why it's important to act soon
such as losing tactical readiness of
your officers or losing the security of
the surrounding area uh when you go
forward in a tactical operation what
what does the guy or the woman in the
field
do i mean where does that i mean
operationally how does that ultimately
you understand what i'm trying to say
absolutely we used to have an expression
if i can make sure make it clear here
what i'm
i'll never forget as a young lawyer
first case i ever had in the family
court it was on we called a competency
hearing
and i was a young kid
six months out of law school
seven 16 year old accused of very
serious crime under delaware law in
order to be tried as an adult for that
crime you had to go to the family court
and have what they call a competency
hearing to determine whether this person
was competent to stand trial as an adult
and so i was assigned to defend this
young person and i had met with
a um
a psychiatrist who'd gone to the prison
uh to to interview this young person and
so and so forth and there was an old
judge his nickname he hated the nickname
named apples reardon former judge was
the chief prosecutor for the state
was then 71 years old and i walked into
the courtroom and looked up at a fine a
revered judge in our state passed away
now judge melson i looked up at judge
nelson and i said your honor i'd
sincerely like to ask for a postponement
my psychiatrist is tied up in another
case up in the superior court cannot be
here i think it's important at all
apple's reared and the former judge
prosecutor stood up and he said no
problem he said i'll stipulate to
whatever biden psychiatrist says
i thought geez i've just won
i mean this is incredible he's going to
stipulate to what my psychiatrist said
and i said well your honor no and i
started to say no objection then proceed
and as i stood up to say that
old apple's weird and look he says on
one condition
i can bring in a psychiatrist tomorrow
because i guarantee i can finally say
the exact opposite judge
it seems to me with all due respect
that's where you sociologists are these
days on the issues of cults on the
issues of religion on the it's not to
suggest we shouldn't seek your input but
tell me what does the commander do when
do we correct do we look at the
curriculum very i mean do we look at
where you went to school or what do we
look at to determine who they have i'll
be glad to respond
uh first of all
i
uh would want to say that at the time
that that report was written i did not
have all of the information that i now
have and i'm not sure i would have even
written that one qualifying sentence in
the report if i'd had the information i
now have would you have had you been in
the scene you think in real time yes as
a matter of fact because the information
i now have is transcripts from the
negotiating uh
sessions and so forth that represent
what was in fact going on there that
demonstrate very clearly that the
negotiators did have
a viable strategy of negotiation ongoing
that they had an understanding with mr
kresh about
writing his document that would
explicate his understanding of the seals
that in fact on the morning of the fire
he was ready to deliver the first part
of that manuscript as a sign of good
faith
uh that that is information that i now
have i did not have so that that one
sentence in my report was intended to
say that none of us can ever in
hindsight be absolutely positive that
something would have gone differently if
we had but been there to advise people
so
the other
10 pages of the report lay out the ways
in which i frankly think things would
have been different if social science
advice had been been heeded one other
point i think it's important to say that
within the social science community
sociologists and scholars of religion
there is in fact very clear consensus
about the way in which this group
operated and the way in which law
enforcement tactics exacerbated that
situation there were in fact differences
of opinion among the psychiatrists but
very little differences difference of
opinion among the sociologists i i make
it clear i think and i realized my time
as definitely make it clear i agree with
you
i don't have any academic background to
draw the conclusion i drew i can recall
debating with my staff the day they went
in saying why are they doing that i
could not understand why that occurred
but that was just instinctual it was not
based on any
professional background i had so i'm not
arguing with the conclusion um nor am i
arguing with the value and the i would
argue increased premium on
sociologists and social scientists
giving us input into what motivates
people who are
who are more in abundance than they were
in the past in terms of organizational
structures i just would like you for the
record to lay out for us what
operational scheme you would suggest
assuming that based on your report you
get a sociologist psychiatrist
psychologist these experts and i do not
denigrate i mean that sincerely i want
that information but is there an
operational mechanism that you suggest
as to how they interface with
anything other than giving advice
do they is that where it ends or do they
are you suggesting a larger wider
operational role
i am not a law enforcement expert here
but it seems to me that it is important
that some sort of mechanism be put in
place where the advice of behavioral
science
people
have
some strategic clout in the
decision-making process that it not be
simply advice that can be shrugged off
and ignored as it certainly seems then
it confuses me and i truly like if you
have anything in writing to indicate how
you would operationally do that be very
helpful i thank you mr chairman thank
you thank you thank you senator bob
we'll turn to senator grassley
mr chairman i would make a few points
before i ask my first questions of the
first panel uh first of all i i think we
all want to start with a premise
that
all cops are good cops at least until
you find out otherwise we ought to have
the benefit
give them the benefit
because respect for law and order are
basic to our society
and respect for law enforcement it seems
to me is basis for respect for law and
order
uh waco and ruby ridge are exceptions to
this but exceptions magnify problem
and if we don't correct them
it erodes public confidence and that's
why i think we're holding these hearings
so i commend the chairman for the
approach that he takes in these hearings
i think
they're designed to explore underlying
problems
that led to waco and
ruby ridge
so we understand these problems better
we can conduct effective oversight which
is the responsibility of this committee
in my opinion the tragedies at waco and
ruby ridge were caused in large part
by the militarization of law enforcement
because of
their infatuation with military tactics
and gadgetry and i guess it's best
demonstrated by this photo here
some law enforcement outfits have come
to resemble kind of keystone ninjas
this phenomena militates against the
number one mission of law enforcement
which i understand to be the
preservation of life
the goal these agencies need to get back
to
is being law enforcement
and not military
they need to resist the temptation of
military toys and equipment and tactics
those things are glamorous and sexy of
course
and they
can be useful though in empire building
but they cannot coexist with law
enforcement
and that's because their objectives are
in conflict you cannot preserve life
using a military
and so these hearings will help this
committee understand the underlying
problems that led to the disaster at
waco
that way we can oversee
fundamental changes
in the structure
and especially the culture
of law enforcement agencies
obviously david koresh was no hero
he was a despicable rogue i believe
it is hard to lay blame for the tragedy
at waco without pointing a finger at him
the question with respect to mr quresh
is
did he deserve what he got criminal that
he was
or were law enforcement officials
obliged to bend over backwards
to preserve his life and those of all
others involved
in reading materials prepared for these
hearings
i note that many in the law enforcement
community feel mr koresh got what he
deserved
others are harshly critical of that view
i want to explore that question this
morning tomorrow
these two days of hearings i think will
under
uncover the excesses
of military influence and law
enforcement
both atf and the fbi had very deadly
military capabilities
the military option was used as a first
resort instead of as a last resort
and for very different reasons these
capabilities got out of control the atf
for example deployed special response
teams
but they were woefully under trained
major breakdowns occurred in
intelligence communication command and
control and tactical support
the situation is kind of like giving
keys to a teenager
to drive the car without having
drivers training it cars a very
dangerous tool
and that's what happened with the atf
srt unit i believe they were under
trained not prepared now the fbi seems
to me had an opposite problem
it's hrt
is overtrained
they are trained to a razor's edge
they on the scene at waco
the swashbucklers
were in control
whenever quresh would respond favorably
to on
requests from negotiators his reward
would be psychological warfare
from the tactical unit you'll recall at
ruby ridge
these were
uh very same tactical people sent in a
robot
with a shotgun attached to negotiate
with randy weaver
the equivalent in this case was trying
to get
koresh to come out
by turning off his electricity
playing dying rabbits
and doing it very loudly and calling him
a cartoon character
in my book this is called the
neanderthal option there's no place for
it
in law enforcement so it's my hope that
these hearings will serve a useful
purpose
and i hope that useful purpose will be
to rein in the military option and to
help law enforcement going back to being
cops
we cannot have a situation which our
military troops in somalia could not get
tanks but the fbi had them at waco
this is an upside down lodging
to their credit both the atf and the fbi
have taken positive steps towards
restructuring
still
to be addressed in my view though
is a cultural problem
that is one area that i want to address
in my questions these two days so for
both of you
i would start by asking
about something that the u.s justice
department did in soliciting the
recommendations of experts in its review
of the waco disaster one of those
experts
ron mccarthy
a consultant from california stated that
other options could have been available
under different circumstances but that
in no way
would he suggest
that the authorities are in any way at
fault for the final outcome of the waco
incident he states that only the adult
participants criminals and fanatics
inside the compound are responsible and
at fault for the deaths of the children
he further claims that the failure of
the fbi's maneuvers on day 51 are the
result of the law enforcement or the
unlawful
and
bizarre actions
and mindless aggressions of the
criminals inside who slaughtered their
own children
do you believe such an attitude will
contribute to improvement of law
enforcement reforms
in future crises
uh senator uh i i must say i know ron
mccarthy and regardless of friend but i
disagree with him
i think uh a cultural problem that has
permeated policing for generations is a
fascination with technology if you uh
think back even to chester gould and his
crime stoppers textbook and dick tracy
you'll see that the gadgetry was always
something that was seen
as uh
something that could resolve police
problems my experience is that policing
and law enforcement are really human
interactional jobs they're one-on-one
jobs and the important skills and
equipment
are the office's ability to deal with
people rather than the hardware he has
at his or her disposal i'll give you an
example as uh
i sit here i recall an incident that was
not much different from the corrections
and 1977 and 78 just before i left the
new york city police department
a sergeant and a police officer pulled
over a traffic violator on the lower
east side
and the police officer took the man's
license and registration and started to
walk back to his police car with it and
the traffic violator suddenly pulled out
a gun and shot and killed the two of
them and he then went and took his
driver's license from the dead police
officer's hands and drove off
several people recognized me it was a
neighborhood character and they followed
a manhunt in the alphabet city section
of the lower east side of manhattan
unlike anything i've ever seen and went
on for two or three weeks unsuccessfully
about 4 30 in the morning two detectives
who were sitting in that squad room
that's used in nypd blue got a telephone
call
from an individual who said that the guy
you're looking for is in an apartment on
east 13th street i have the phone number
but i don't know the apartment number
the house is a very large building with
75 or 80 apartments in it
and the two detectives had been told
that the man was going to leave in the
morning he was being sneaked out of the
city and being transported someplace
else
but the informant wasn't sure when that
would happen so we had these two
detectives who had this information
about an individual who might leave a 65
or 70 family apartment house any minute
was wanted for what the cops regard as
the most heinous kind of crime
and who presented a problem because the
officers didn't know precisely where he
was
and
the what the officers did in that
situation was something i've always
regarded as the most imaginative and
successful kind of police police work
they did not engage in any uh high-tech
uh uh operation
the two of them raced to the scene and
one uh called the phone number and uh
said chino the police you're in there
you better get out and he hung up
and chino came walking out the front
door in a hurry and the other officer
grabbed him right at the front door and
the thing that has always bothered me
with the koresh incident is why that
didn't happen in this situation
a fundamental principle in law
enforcement
is that it's better to get them to come
to you than it is for you to go to them
it's better to make them come through
the doorway than it is for you to go
through the doorway and uh i don't see
why that was not done it seemed to me
that there were opportunities to do that
and to suggest otherwise really damages
the cause of effective law enforcement
here's armorman
yes i think uh the statement that you
read i find in many ways very troubling
because of some of the language that is
in that statement
about this being a mindless group a
criminal group
criminal may be correct in the technical
sense of the word but to characterize
the group as mindless is to assume that
there is no internal logic that these
are not
equal human beings with the rest of us
and i think as mr fife has been pointing
out
law enforcement at its best treats the
situations in which it finds itself as
human relations situations and when we
have demonized the people that we are
dealing with when we have
seen them as
mindless and only criminal we therefore
lose the advantage
of seeking to understand
the particular point of view that they
have and therefore engaging in the kind
of good smart law enforcement that we
can in fact engage in
mr chairman i'm done uh i want to just
say though we're only we're going to
have two days of hearings i think
it's very important that beyond the two
days of hearings
we watch
to see if this culture is changing and i
think that that's a very important
oversight function of this committee
to not just have a hearing and i know
the chairman wants to go beyond just
having hearing and he'd be very
responsible but i think we just have to
observe
within law enforcement is this culture
changing
thank you senator appreciate it senator
simon will turn to you thank thank you
very much mr chairman first of all
i thought your opening statement was an
excellent one it was balanced
it
said what
should be said and i appreciate it mr
chairman
you said we have to find lessons and i
think that's
uh
that is where we are
and i would also underscore what senator
biden said there was no improper motive
here
people
wanted to do an effective job some
mistakes were made tragic mistakes
but
and i think we should underscore also
my impression over the years dealing
with the fbi and the atf
uh the american people
generally can be very proud of the work
that these two
organizations
do
the
there is a a tendency
on the part of the public as well as the
police
to exaggerate a threat from
quote people who are different
uh in your statement dr ammerman
you say behavioral scientists who have
studied people who
leave high intensity religious groups
especially when they leave with the aid
of people who specialize in deep
programming
note that such ex-members often become
very bitter about the group they have
left and exaggerate
its evils
i think that is true
and
we tend
to
[Music]
we
demonize if i can use a
word here for
for a seminary professor we demonize
those who quote
are different
we have gone through this a great deal
we're going to have a democratic
convention in chicago
i think one of the reasons
for the difficulties in 1968
was
there were exaggerated reports
by federal officials to mayor daley
about the nature of the threat
and then there was an exaggerated
response
to what was taking place
and i see this happening
over and over again in history
uh the mormons
were in illinois in the 1840s
and
because they had some polygamy was then
practiced by some but
rumors were ripe as to what they were
doing
and you ended up with a
military force that went after them you
had joseph smith
killed
um
if we had
some understanding of the other side
there would not have been that situation
and i see this happen february 1942 when
we took 120 000 japanese americans away
from the west coast
uh no justification we just didn't not a
single person committed a crime
[Music]
anti-semitism unfortunately has been
part
of the history not only in our country
but in other countries
where
people have uh
people who are different in quotes
are
made to be
scapegoats springfield illinois
just not many months ago
a mosque
for a handful of muslims
was burned down
what
the public has to understand is they
can't
take things into their
own hands but law enforcement officials
also
have to
uh have to understand and not exaggerate
the other side i think that's extremely
important
i guess uh
uh and
this is a digression now now mr fight
but when what you said about
the one-on-one relationship
that really is
the key to good police work
it's not getting the latest piece of
equipment the latest computer yes they
can help
but it's that one-on-one relationship
let me just ask a very fundamental
question
if and this is easy hindsight is an easy
thing and this is one of the things
where
we're going through an exercise in
hindsight
but an exercise as senator hatch has
pointed out that
can teach us some lessons
if you had been in charge
looking back in retrospect
and you both partially answered this
how would you handle things differently
my answer to that i think is best
illustrated by
what i was doing at the time
a few days before
the
the assault on waco the second assault
on the waco i testified in a case in
phoenix arizona in defense of a police
officer who had been called to a
situation in which an emotionally
disturbed young man had taken up a rifle
and barricaded himself in a church and
the state police and the local police
responded and did what i thought were
all the right things they set up an
inner perimeter and an outer perimeter
and remained behind cover and tried to
negotiate with him and he came out at
several occasions and pointed the rifle
around
no one ever took a shot at him they
tried to talk with them about three
hours passed and the young man came out
with his rifle and spotted a police
officer who peered over the hood of a
car
very quickly and the officer was a
veteran said that the kid made eye
contact with me put the gun up to his
shoulder lean forward in a shooting
position and i was staring right down
the barrel of the gun and the officer
said i had two choices one was to try
and duck behind the car but the rifle
bullet could come right through it you
saw the kind of bullet that senator
barton showed or to shoot him and he
shot him and i testified that there was
a tragedy
but that the officer had acted
appropriately
a couple of days later a former fbi
agent who had been very involved in
hostage negotiations testified on behalf
of the plaintiff in the case and
rebutted what i had to say
and he said that putting police officers
that close to the young man was a
provocation
and that on that morning the fbi had
been at waco for 51 days
and would never do anything to provoke a
confrontation and he finished his direct
examination and went to lunch and during
lunch the conflagration occurred and he
came back and had to undergo
cross-examination uh after the fire but
i think the point uh obviously the the
defense won that case but the point was
that the assault on waco was an absolute
shock to this fellow who indicated that
he had been uh the coordinator of
hundreds of hostage and barricade
situations for the fbi and uh it was to
me as well i think
as mr balls will no doubt tell you
tomorrow
the view of most hostage negotiation
people is that you should continue to
talk as long as possible and as long as
you have people talking that can't be
hurting you or anybody else that the
officials can outweigh anybody
i would like to add out
backing up to the beginning here before
there ever was a siege uh
i think the most important thing that
the atf could have done is to have
assessed the information they were
getting by getting information that came
from a variety of kinds of sources
unfortunately the information they were
getting came primarily from
the kinds of people who are most
concerned about these religious groups
that are
different and that seem to them that are
labeled by them dangerous cults
and
unfortunately it seems to me there is
there's a large segment of the american
public that finds
uh
people with different kinds of religious
beliefs and practices
perhaps who live off in an isolated
place somewhere who look a little
strange perhaps or
whose beliefs simply don't fit our
stereotype for what people ought to
believe if they're going to be really
good religious people
we tend to find those people
perhaps dangerous to us
and unfortunately there is a fairly well
organized uh movement that
seeks to uh provide information to law
enforcement and to uh concerned parents
and and others
that uh
that tends to exaggerate the danger uh
imposed by these groups in this case
there were a number of people who knew
the branch davidians quite well
who had studied the branch davidians for
their entire history
in waco people at baylor university for
instance who were regularly back and
forth between mount carmel and their
homes in waco who knew these folks and
that kind of
assessment of additional information
from people who
do not necessarily have an interest in
seeing the demise of a religious group
but rather have an interest in seeing
the understanding of that group and an
accurate assessment of the potential
threat to the society that it seems to
me would have
dictated a strategy that would have been
far less confrontational in the
beginning
and did the federal officials know about
these experts at yale and and number one
and two number two if they did
were they consulted
i think that uh one of the things that
we discovered was that the culture and
the structure of federal law enforcement
tends toward only consulting the people
who are already inside the system
so that they don't have a ready
list of people or a method for seeking
out consultation beyond their own
internal uh organization and in this
case they should however they did know
about the people at baylor who were
familiar with the the branch davidians
and simply did not choose to follow up
on that information
i thank both of you thank you mr
chairman thank you senator simon we'll
now turn to senator wine who is next
in appearance here
thank you mr chairman
during the time that waco was occurring
i had involvement in another
unfolding
tragedy
and that was the lucasville
riots in in ohio lucasville prison at
that time i was the lieutenant governor
of the state
one of my responsibilities as lieutenant
governor was to oversee our
whole anti-crime effort which also
included our prisons and i don't mean to
overstate my role in this case because
the governor voinovich was the governor
and he was directly involved and
director wilkinson was the one who was
who was making the decisions on this on
the scene
but i'm i'm struck by some some
parallels between what happened at
lucasville
and what happened at waco and let me
just make a couple comments and i would
like for both of you to to comment if
you could
we ended up our
siege at lucasville
tragically with
one correction officer losing his life
and the loss of that correction officer
i know for myself at least will be
with me for the rest of my life
no law enforcement officers were killed
one hostage i said
was no law enforcement officers other
than officer landingham was killed
some of the
prisoners ended up
being
killed
but we resolved that
through negotiations
and
ultimately ended the siege
we had available to us and utilized
fbi
hostage negotiation experts who are on
the scene with us
who directly advised our
own negotiators
we also had available on the scene
fbi
officers
who engaged in psychological profiles
profiles of the leaders
of
the prison riot
and they used they got information based
on
what they could hear in the negotiations
as they were going on plus studying the
files
we
the point of all is of this is that we
were very pleased with
the information we received from both
sets of experts
we thought the information they gave us
was very good very valuable helped us to
resolve
the situation
some of those individuals
i am told were also involved directly at
waco
and if and as for the other ones
they came out of the same basic pool of
talent
i guess my question is how do you
explain the difference in results
other than
maybe the obvious and that is that we
were dealing with a situation where we
had it was a in a sense a typical prison
riot situation where we had hostages who
were taking who who were
correction officers the prisoners were
in the compound
uh
whereas waco involves a different a
different set of facts a different set
of circumstances
i wonder if you could both both could
comment on that and let me just say also
dr five
i totally i believe you're the one that
said it i totally agree with your
comment that the goal
should always be minimize loss of life i
was struck though by your comment that
there is a natural i don't want to
misquote you but i interpret it as
saying there's somewhat of a natural
tension
between negotiation people
and
the more tactical or military side of
the operation
it would seem to me that while that
tension might exist
both of those
ideally should be used as tools
of the decision makers
and the decision makers have to
use both of them
as as potential tools and that you go
with your negotiations first
and you continue those as long as you
can and you should have a great deal of
patience but we always knew in ohio
during the lucasville siege for example
that at any one moment they could start
killing massive numbers of hostages and
that we would have to go in and so we
looked at the military side or the
foresight as a contingency that we had
to have prepared had to have trained had
had the plan had to be ready to go but
you know
we hope to god we would never have to
use them so it seems to me that there
while there is a conflict the way that
should be used
in in in an ideal situation or maybe the
protocol should be
but they're both tools and they're used
by the decision makers
who ultimately have to bear the
responsibility and that you always go
first with your negotiations and you go
with your negotiations as long as
absolutely humanly possible until
the the the people who are holding your
hostages
take such action that you simply have no
choice but to go in in with force i
think the most important so i'd like for
both of you if you could just to comment
on that and maybe comment on on the
difference
uh you know it just has struck me
ever since both these events occurred we
were using the same type people and we
were very uh grateful to have them and
we thought they did a hell of a good job
franklin
i think uh you're absolutely right that
there is a great deal of skill and
compassion and caring available in these
law enforcement agencies what is
absolutely critical to
to understand about the difference
between the two situations you describe
however is that there were no hostages
at waco
the people who were inside the buildings
in mount carmel chose to be there and we
can we can argue about the the situation
of the children there but nevertheless
those children were with their parents
and their parents chose to be there so
you didn't have a situation where it was
likely that someone inside is going to
some start killing off other people
inside
so it's a fundamentally different kind
of negotiating situation i would
certainly agree with you that
the two kinds of strategies always have
to be available and
but that the balance of how one measures
uh the use of each of those strategies
has to be determined by the particular
situation in which you find yourself
the waco situation was not one in which
these are people who
have a past history of criminal behavior
who are primarily oriented uh toward
the same kinds of arguments about force
and about uh the use of force that the
people in the prison might have if i
could just follow up because i want to
keep my thought on that though
i understand that distinction
but
i assume you've had you've had the
opportunity to thoroughly study
many documents you get your hands on in
regard to what happened at waco guess
what i'm trying to determine is
we thought we got good information from
the psychological profile people for
example
we thought we had good information from
the negotiation
experts who were advising our
negotiators
do you perceive the problem at waco as
being bad information from those same
people or do you perceive the problem as
being
the decision makers not utilizing that
information correctly
in the very early days of the fbi uh
handling of the siege at waco the
behavioral science profilers wrote what
i would see as an extremely careful and
accurate assessment of the situation
that they found themselves in they
identified the fact that this was
primarily a religious group that was
driven by
uh
a set of religious beliefs that were
that saw the fbi as the enemy and in
fact a predicted enemy uh that in in
effect the fbi was now playing into the
very prophetic scenario that that david
koresh had laid out
they saw the danger of mass suicide they
saw the way in which
increased force was only likely to
increase the resolve of the group they
saw the the way in which the group
understood its home as a kind of sacred
ground that was now being violated by uh
by outsiders so they understood what
they needed to understand and they made
what i thought were some very astute
recommendations and they were overruled
dr five i didn't give you a chance to
comment i apologize thank you senator i
would just take that down a level and
say that uh i'm sure that mr bowles will
tell you tomorrow that one of the first
things uh police officials who are at
hostage barricade situations try and do
is a diagnosis of what they're dealing
with and the police generally have uh
broken hostage takers and barricaded
persons down into three types and the
the the treatment that you give those
people depends on the diagnosis you make
one uh one type is a rational offender
who was caught at a scene
because he didn't get away in time so
the bank robber who takes hostages in a
bank uh like the person in a prison
there's usually someone who has has been
caught doing something that he he hopes
will change his life and who wants to
continue his life and who can be
intimidated usually uh out of giving up
hostages or out of his barricade
situation uh the other two however are
people who are deranged people who are
emotionally disturbed and you can't
threaten those people out because they
they're not rational they may not want
to live and the third type is uh people
who take hostages or barricade
themselves for some political or
religious reason and an awful lot of
those people want to become martyrs so
as senator grassley pointed out
the first responsibility of the la the
police is to preserve life so the police
should do everything possible to make
sure that these people are not given an
opportunity to become martyrs and the
way to do that is to continue to try to
talk to them rather than to intimidate
them or provoke them to martyrdom
thank you i see that my red light is on
my time is up thank you mr chairman
thank you senator we'll turn to senator
feinstein now thank you very much
mr chairman
let me begin with a summary statement on
my part
i have concluded from my review of the
facts that the negotiation tactics
used at waco were deeply flawed and
really doomed to fail
and the reason is because there was a
very clear conflict between the hrt the
hostage rescue team
and the negotiators
i'll give you two examples once there
was a 50 caliber weapon seen at the
window
and the negotiators succeeded in getting
david koresh to have that weapon removed
from the window the negotiators were
then criticized
because the hrt said well if the gun's
at the window at least we know where it
is
another time was when koresh let some
people go
and the hrt turned out the power
so instead of using the carrot they used
the stick
and there was a basic conflict inherent
in the whole process which i think
doomed it
and in my opinion
negotiation in this my summary statement
should never be used by a law
enforcement authority
to put someone in a position to shoot
them or kill them but only
to to achieve a peaceful surrender would
you agree with that
i absolutely agree i think the job
of the police is to preserve life and
they have no
catching bad guys uh ending hostage
situations quickly ending barricade
situations quickly uh none of those
things are as important as the
responsibility of the police to protect
life and sometimes we forget that it's
been pointed out here that quite often
uh police officers and asians start to
think of themselves as soldiers and
that's a real problem because in a
democracy uh police officers should not
be soldiers because soldiers have
enemies and the military deals with
enemies in a way that our police should
not regard as appropriate yes i and i
think this is one of the things that
comes clear to me in both ruby ridge
and waco
where soldierly tactics were used they
were doomed to failure
and perhaps this brings us to the
subject of intelligence gathering i
understand that two things have happened
but one of them for the purpose of today
intelligence got gathering that the fbi
has now developed a behavioral sciences
unit
i hope operating separate and i hope we
have a chance to ask them about this
to really begin to do some behavioral
assessments
because it's clear to me is that law
enforcement does not have the ability
to really understand
uh fanatic religious groups and
therefore
what negotiating tactics
could be effective and i think we have
to conclude that with fanatic groups
they're not going to
they're not going to surrender
unless some way they're convinced that
force is not going to work because they
will probably destroy themselves first
and we've seen this in two instances let
me give you
something because on intelligence
gathering because i'm really perplexed
by this let me take you back to 1979
in my city san francisco
where a group called the people's temple
had been in existence for four years
the head of the people's temple had
actually been appointed to head the san
francisco housing authority
they bought substantial property in the
city major property two big parcels they
had a huge congregation
they seemed to be doing good
they cultivated public officials had
them over for meals
um interdigitated with them in general
made people feel that they were a
welcome presence and yet they were a
fanatic religious cult i was fortunate
for some reason and i don't quite know
why that i did never i never got
involved
then
they went to guyana
it took a congressman in a fact-finding
expedition to go down there the
congressman ended up shot to death a
reporter shot to death
and the people
drank cyanide
and some were shot in the course of a
mass suicide well left in san francisco
where 60 of them holed up in the
people's temple i was very fortunate to
have a brilliant young negotiator by the
name of dr chris hatcher
who went in there and took months
literally working with the people full
time
to convince them to come out
as opposed to committing suicide
themselves
but there was no intelligence about this
group ahead of time
how
does one
in a system of a democracy
gather the kind of intelligence that you
need
to be
ahead of time to be able to
deal with the group once the incident
has begun to unfold
i i'd like to take a shot at that and i
think it's symptomatic of a much broader
problem and that that's this that
police officers are used to uh acting on
very limited information uh they
typically uh at the local level police
officers right now are responding to uh
to calls where the dispatcher has told
them that there's a robbery in progress
and that's all the information they have
so the people who are at the scene know
much more about the situation than the
officers do
so police officers and to a lesser
degree federal law enforcement agencies
become excellent crisis responders and
that causes them i think to focus on
responding to prices quickly to size
them up and to improvise some
resolutions to them and what is lost is
a the whole idea of strategic planning
and thinking ahead about what we can do
as you talk senator i was reminded a few
years ago that when i lived here in
washington we had a riot that involved
some hispanics and
most of my friends in the police
department here were surprised to even
hear that there was a substantial
hispanic population in washington dc
though the police department had not
been looking at his clientele and one of
the most important things i think the
committee can do is to encourage police
agencies and federal law enforcement
agencies to constantly scan the horizon
and look at who their clientele are and
how they are changing
if you think of police and law
enforcement officials as referees of the
social order it's very important for
them to know when the social order is
changing and to try and figure out how
it's likely to affect them and
unfortunately in many cases uh our
law enforcement officials don't do that
you think even on a broader level in
that about the whole nature of the
criminal justice enterprise this is
crime and criminal justice and disorder
and religious groups who may be fanatic
are one of the few social problems
for which we have virtually no long-term
strategies you all know that we have
long-term strategies for defense and we
have long-term strategies for aids as
well as some short-term tactics but we
really have no idea where we're going to
be
where crime and the police are concerned
10 or 12 or 15 years from now so i think
uh let me just stop because my question
is how do how
how do you gather
intelligence
on some of these groups without imposing
on people violating their constitutional
rights
to know about them ahead of time
to have the background
as to what kind of actions you have to
take if and when there's an incident i
think i think you have to bring that
right down to the level of the police
officer on the beat and the cop on the
beat i was always told is the eyes and
ears of government and he can find out
all kinds of things for you uh on in a
very non-threatening way and and and
building a healthy relationship with the
community he or she serves so i think we
have to encourage police officers to
developed that cops on the beat knew a
little bit about the people's temple or
they should have known if they had been
out there with their eyes and ears open
so i think
police officers are very underutilized
for that purpose
i would certainly second that that uh
the most refreshing thing i heard in all
my conversations with people uh at the
fbi at quantico in the behavioral
science unit was that
they told stories about how they often
get calls from local people about you
know we've we've discovered this this
strange new group up the road from us
what do we do about it
and but that input wasn't factored in i
gather into some of these decisions what
the what the fbi does at that point with
local law enforcement is to simply say
well you know go visit these folks in a
very sort of non-threatening way it's
the sort of cop on the beat strategy
that
the first line of defense is in fact for
law enforcement and for the rest of us
to quit being so scared of strange
groups that we're afraid to knock on the
front door and get to know these folks
in other words don't isolate them
absolutely the worst thing that happened
to the people's temple was their move to
guyana
i think that's right yeah yeah i think
just as a a point senator and the work i
did in dade county we did we found an
interesting thing a date as you know is
a county that surrounds miami but we
watched what police officers did while
they were at work and this is a very
well trained competent police department
that was beginning its community
policing enterprise the
we calculated that officers in that
department the offices we watched over
almost a thousand days
initiated
conversations with citizens in
non-adversarial circumstances not
stopping suspicious people but just got
out of the car to talk to people once
every 12 days so it's very difficult to
learn anything about a community if you
only respond to crises you really got to
get out and have your feelers out to
learn about what's going on in a place
thank you both very much well thank you
senator fine i find that i will turn to
senator kyle thank you mr chairman uh i
missed your statement for which i
apologize but i i do want to um
compliment senator grassley i think he
encapsulated many of the thoughts that
we've talked about informally among
ourselves did a very good job
suggest that that that framed the issues
very nicely and i've appreciated the
testimony of the witnesses here it seems
to me that this is both very simple and
and and somewhat complex at the same
time
the application of common sense and the
doctrine of reasonable force
seem to me to be the
uh
twin principles upon which uh law
enforcement approaches most of these
kinds of problems
uh reasonable force of course meaning
never more than is reasonable and yet
it's also complicated because in order
to do that in any given situation you
have to be pretty sophisticated in
understanding the people and
understanding how to resolve the
situation
the the thing that i would like to focus
on by the way if you have a comment on
that please share it with me but i i
think that's fairly fairly
common doctrine
the situation that seems to me to be
occurring more and more at least it's in
the news more and more
is the situation that was somewhat uh
involved at waco and was the situation
at ruby ridge and
is in a couple of other situations one
is a fairly famous case now in montana
that i still don't think is resolved
where there's been some relatively
non-serious
uh crime alleged to have been committed
for which there is some kind of a
warrant outstanding or some other legal
kind of action
that
um law enforcement is attempting to
process
but the people
are
upon whom it would be processed
have threatened some kind of violence
in other words they're at the cabin
saying we're armed and we really don't
want you around here so don't serve your
warrant
or something bad could happen
and that's the situation that that we
find ourselves in more and more yet law
enforcement has dealt with that
situation over the years
it doesn't necessarily fit neatly into
the three categories and i'd like mr
fight to
comment on that because you have a
situation where
uh in one sense the the people are very
rational
uh they just want to be left alone but
they are also a little strange because
of their approach to life they have a
little different view on things that may
not mean that they will act totally
rationally and so my question is and
while i know it's impossible to
generalize what are the basic common
principles and and the typical ways in
which you would suggest dealing with
these crises
not the question that that senator simon
asked how would you have dealt with this
particular situation but rather similar
to that
how would you normally deal with these
what are the two or three best ways of
dealing with these kind of situations
so that when the fbi and other agencies
in the future
talk with us about
guidance and we talk with them about
oversight we can have a little greater
appreciation of the range of options
that are that are appropriate in these
circumstances would both of you comment
on that please i i'm uh somewhat
familiar with the situation you're
talking about in montana and i know that
it's it's rather unique but i think it
still fits into that uh category of
people uh who resist the police for some
political reason and
who may be totally rational but whose
idea of a desirable outcome may be very
different from what most of us would
think would be desirable so uh i think
that
without trying to prescribe what should
be done in detail i think the principles
that apply to hostage and barricade
situations generally are also applicable
here
one is that you should do everything
possible to avoid forcing a
confrontation
another is that time is always on the
side of the officials
and that you should take advantage of as
much time as possible even if it means
starving people out seems to me that
they have to leave at some time and that
the way to apprehend them is as the
officers in manhattan did is to get them
to come to you rather than to go to them
because uh uh for a law enforcement
official a blazing gun duel should not
be a desirable outcome for those folks
in montana a blazing gun duel
may be the desirable outcome and law
enforcement officials should do
everything possible to see that they
don't get that
okay but i know that that's not an easy
situation to deal with
i think the the key point that's being
made here is that there are different
kinds of rationalities
that what makes sense to
those of us sitting in this room what
makes sense to law enforcement officials
may not make sense in the same way to a
political group to a religious group
and it's incumbent on the people who get
into a situation of trying to serve a
warrant
deal with a hostage or barricade
situation to understand what the
rationality is that's operative for the
people involved
it's also possible senator to even think
about this in cost benefit terms you
know
one of the things that causes
police officers and law enforcement
officials to try
and produce quick resolutions of
situations there's a whole idea of
expediency and time and if you think
about how that has uh
operate it operated here we are two and
a half three years after waco is still
talking about it lots of time and effort
is being spent on that i think in my own
city of philadelphia of the move
incident in 1985 where the police bombed
a building
that
city is still tied up in litigation it's
had to reconstruct a whole neighborhood
it has two police officers assigned to a
home that the move people think they
still own so just in cost benefit terms
it's
a good idea to take as much time before
a confrontation as to force the
confrontation and live with the
consequences
one of the things i think we're going to
have to deal with in our society is
something that's been with us in this
country since its inception in fact it
was one of the reasons for the inception
of this country but also has increased
in
[Music]
in
importance perhaps in the last few years
and that's this whole notion of
people who
predict that government will come to get
them and then do things which
fulfill that
prediction
how does law enforcement deal in advance
with groups whose biggest fear
is the government and uh who thrive on
the predictions
that um
that the government is against them and
and and will come for them particularly
given the fact that these same groups
often tend to
defend themselves with significant
weaponry
i think
what the police have to do in those
situations although i don't like to
think of the police of soldiers
as tantamount to what the military does
and
uh that is to try and structure
confrontation so that resistance is
almost impossible and police officers on
the street do that all the time they try
and get the drop on people so that
the individual involved knows that he
has no choice but to surrender i think
that uh
if there is a need to confront groups
like that uh the confrontation should be
structured in the same way you try and
get people when they're alone when
they're unarmed and where they they
can't give you a reason to kill them
i think another part of the psychology
here uh
before the tactics in some sense is that
it's awfully easy when there's a group
out there
that uh proclaims that you're a terrible
person in the enemy to to take their
word for it
uh and in fact
develop a kind of barricade mentality
yourself
uh to
turn inward and see that person who's uh
proclaiming that you're a terrible
person and an enemy as in fact your
enemy so that there's a kind of
self-fulfilling prophecy that often gets
put in place
when we have these confrontations with
groups that try to paint the law
enforcement and the government as their
enemies we often begin to then act like
exactly what they are portraying us as
acting uh it's a it's a very difficult
cycle to break and
some of the kinds of strategies that mr
fife i think has been talking about are
important in helping to break that cycle
i appreciate that i i think that we are
going to have to do more in working with
our national
law enforcement agencies and of course
to assist them in working with local
groups
to deal with
the increasing number of
disaffected
groups in our country particularly out
west i see them in my state of arizona
people who
are
one might say psychologically anyway are
somewhat paranoid about the government
and somehow we're going to have to
prevent the kinds of things which one
can foresee in the future
as this paranoia increases
i'm not sure what the answers to to
those issues are but i suspect it in
much of it is involved in the kind of
thing
you talked about mr fight of simply
having the law enforcement people
establish some
degree of
communication with these folks to let
them know that at least from their
perspective they don't have to worry
about the government being their enemy
yes i hear
on the local level of individual police
officers situations in which police
officers have killed people and then
said that it was an example of suicide
by cop
and more often than not when
you look carefully at those situations
you see that there they involve
confrontations with emotionally
disturbed people
that were fully forced by police
officers who then had to shoot their way
out of them and
i think
on a collective level we may see the
same thing with these religious groups
and
the trick
and dealing both with the emotionally
disturbed person and the cult that seems
crazy to us is to avoid forcing a
confrontation just so i not be
misunderstood that the groups that i'm
mostly talking about
would be described in the media
generally as militia type of groups but
i i i don't really like to use that that
word so much but but they're not
religious they are simply people who
fear the government is going to take
their guns away or attack their property
and so on and it's for that reason that
they fear the government and act in a
rather paranoid way appreciate your
comments very much thank you mr chairman
thank you senator senator feingold
you'll be our concluding questioner
chairman i know this panel's been up for
a long time so i'll ask for my statement
to be included in the record thank you
we'll we'll put it in the record just
ask a few questions um
zammerman i've appreciated your uh
comments about the different kinds of
sources that might be available to help
us in a situation like this you
mentioned that at baylor there were
people who actually were familiar on a
personal basis with the branch davidians
can you just tell me a little bit more
about the more general sources that are
available in this type of situation and
how are law enforcement people to
work with these two different kinds of
information the specific in the general
um
one of the things that has been very
encouraging in the days since waco is
that there do seem to have been moves
at the justice department and with the
fbi to set up
something of a crisis management team
and that crisis management team does now
seem to be seeking out the help of
scholars in the field of religion to
help brief them and get them
some available general knowledge about
uh the way in which they should think
about the kind of the strategic planning
that we've been talking about what are
the general things we know about
dissident religious groups that can help
us to have a kind of
orientation toward a situation
but those very same scholars can then
be network contacts to help put law
enforcement in touch with people who
might have very specific knowledge about
a given group uh in this case professor
pitts for instance at baylor who knew
the branch davidians very well
uh however
it's certainly the case that there are a
whole lot more
uh religious and political groups out
there than there are scholars who have
studied every single specific one of
them
so that this more general
knowledge of the kinds of predictable
patterns of behavior that we've seen by
studying lots of different groups can
often be very helpful even if it's not
specific to the exact group that we're
dealing with could you mention just a
couple of other institutions where this
kind of work is being done maybe you
already have but
there there's work uh being done at
every place from uh the university of
nevada to uh
uh the universe virginia university
commonwealth university to
uh independent scholars to people at
loyola university new orleans there are
institutions all over the country and my
report to the justice and treasury
departments among other things listed
about 20 scholars who are seen in the
field of
social science study of religion as the
people who know new religious movements
high-intensity religious movements
you say that many of the factors that
had to be considered at waco included
the volume of weapons and explosives the
allegations of child abuse and instances
of violence in the past are generally
are these things generally consistent
with with the religious groups that
you've studied
the allegations are certainly consistent
and that's one of the interesting things
uh to be looked at here that there is a
very consistent pattern in the
relationship between a dissonant
religious group and the larger society
surrounding it once that group is
defined by some group within the larger
society is somehow dangerous
the pattern of allegations
is a very familiar one and those
allegations may or may not ever hold up
once people actually go and look at the
group and we can look at this pattern
going all the way back into the 19th
century i mean the way people described
what was going on inside convents
uh sounds an awful lot like what we hear
people describing going on inside the
branch davidians or what people thought
as was referred to earlier about what
was going on with the mormons in their
early history
i think it's very important for us both
to take those allegations seriously in
the sense of
actually investigating them but also to
realize that there is this predictable
pattern once a group has decided that
they want to live very differently and
see the rest of us is wrong
that we're also likely to respond with a
variety of kinds of fears and
expectations and exaggerations
i think that the perceptions issue is
very very important and and there's a
question of fairness there but
and i want to just pursue that a bit
because you've
held forth this notion of dissident
religions
i will do you know obviously whatever i
can to protect minority or dissident
religions but at some point there has to
be a distinction between dissidents and
criminal activity
particularly violent criminal activity
you know at what point uh does not the
perception
but the reality of a group's activities
sort of trump the ideology
uh
or really more importantly for our
hearing
how do law enforcement people
make that kind of determination that
this isn't just a
series of perceptions that are directed
toward any dissident group but are
really in fact a very dangerous
situation
well that that requires very careful
data gathering on the group now the kind
of good police work that mr fife has
been talking about
finding out whether in fact this is a
group that not only owns a lot of
weapons but in fact talks about using
those weapons against somebody other
than than about
the rabbits on the range or whatever
that
which i think in the case of the
davidians if people had listened
carefully to their rhetoric with an ear
toward an understanding of religious
apocalyptic language would probably not
have been worried about them using these
weapons
against their neighbors
but it's that kind of very careful
intelligence gathering in the very
specific situations that is necessary
here
to find out whether we're dealing with a
real threat or one that is merely
perceived by neighbors who've been uh
maligned by the group
there's a final question uh let me just
follow that a bit in response to senator
dewine you noted that there was no
no reason for the davidians to start
killing each other off
uh but that contradicts the widely held
notion that the davidians were preparing
for the apocalypse or the end of the
world
reports did indicate that suicide in in
some opinions was a distinct possibility
apparently the experts couldn't decide
on this uh
what
what further guidance do you have for
that
i think that is the one issue that there
is a real division of opinion on within
the scholarly community about the the
nature of the end um
whether in fact
uh the davidians
committed mass suicide and in
how much of it was mass suicide and how
much of it was assisted
uh by others within the group
the the situation however is not one
where
you had people who were killing each
other off somehow
out of any sort of self-interest in the
usual sense of that word but rather
people who were collectively
engaged in what they saw if it was a
mass suicide as a kind of mass martyrdom
and movement into another world that
would be for them a better world so that
even
something as horrible as a parent
killing a child
which i want to be very clear i
understand to be a very horrible thing
that i would not want to see happen
but that is somehow understandable
within a world view
in which
that death results in a kind of rebirth
thank you and thank the chair
thank you senator feingold we want to
thank both of you witnesses you've been
excellent we've learned a lot from you
and we appreciate the efforts that
you've put forth we're trying to
establish here
some things that need to be changed and
things that are being changed and we
hope that this committee will make that
clear to everybody that there are some
massive changes going on that will be in
the best interests of the country in the
best interest of our people
and both of you have added a great deal
to this hearing so we appreciate you
both being here chairman if you'll
permit me i want to thank the witnesses
as well and uh dr fife i look forward to
seeing that uh material from dave is it
dade county dave county dade county and
uh and i also look forward uh uh
professor amberman if you uh at least if
if not now not in a letter at a
telephone conversation to expound a
little more with me on how operationally
you'd think about how this works okay uh
could i just also make a request i i
would like to read a number of your
papers that you've written
uh dr amerman both on the religious
topic as you know i'm the author of the
religious freedom restoration act uh
along with others and uh so i'm very
interested in that area plus anything
you can on waco and i would like to
i wouldn't mind having these autographs
by the way and i wouldn't mind having uh
at least your one book there if you
would certainly
thanks so much appreciate having you
here under the new ethics rules we'll
probably have to pay for the book but uh
i'm not going to i'm going to i'm going
to learn from it
uh we're certainly going to accommodate
our our distinguished ranking members so
our next panel on
of the day
is comprised of two individuals who put
forth a lot of time and effort in
reviewing the actions of atf
uh not only its actions but it's a its
agents and agency as they relate to the
events surrounding the failed warrant
execution at waco on february 28 1993
mr jeffrey moulton was the project
director for treasury's waco review
he had the task of organizing an
intensive investigation of this event
in addition to his general oversight
responsibilities mr moulton
was intimately involved in the writing
editing and reviewing of the report
joining mr molten is captain john
coleman
before he retired captain john coleman
served 23 years in the los angeles
county sheriff's department three years
in the whittier police department in
three years active army duty which
included service in korea
captain coleman was consulted by the
review for his expertise and tactical
operations
and as a consultant he provided the
review with an independent please sit
down and gentlemen with an independent
assessment of atf's operation from this
point of expertise
we are delighted to have both of you
here we look forward to your testimony
and we'll begin with you first mr
moulton and then we'll move to mr
coleman mr chairman before professor
moulton begins i want to make sure that
i don't get accused of any conflict of
interest mr moulton teaches at weidner
university law school on the delaware
campus
i am an adjunct professor on that law
school campus
i'd like the record to show that we have
not collaborated
and i welcome you here i uh it's it's
nice to have you uh here and uh thank
you for your good work but uh
thank you senator biden thank you mr
chairman uh members of the committee uh
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to appear before you today uh as senator
hatch stated two years ago i served as
the project director for the treasury
department investigation into atf's
failed raid on the branch davidian
compound near waco texas
just briefly by way of background
because i don't want to represent myself
to be more of an expert than i am uh
before i undertook that assignment uh i
graduated with columbia law school in
1984 uh and on the conflict of interest
score i was a classmate with senator
hatch's son brent so we'll get that on
on the table i know how radical that
class was like
that's right um
before i clerked then for chief judge
feinberg uh on the second circuit court
of appeals and then for justice
rehnquist on the united states supreme
court
uh after that i roughly i served for
roughly four years as an assistant
united states attorney in philadelphia
in the middle of those four years uh i
spent six months on a temporary detail
to the justice department under attorney
general mees and attorney general
thornberg as special counsel to the
assistant attorney general in charge of
the criminal division
i then spent several years in private
practice before undertaking the
assignment as project director today as
senator biden said i am a an associate
professor at weidner law school in
delaware where i teach white-collar
crime legal ethics and criminal
procedure and i have the good fortune to
have senator biden as a colleague um
i have submitted a written statement for
the record uh i'd like to just make it
without objection we'll put your
complete statements in the record and we
do appreciate it if you can summarize
and i will i'll briefly make a few
comments now
as we all know on february 28 1993 four
agents from the treasury department's
bureau of alcohol tobacco and firearms
were killed and more than 20 were
wounded as they unsuccessfully attempted
to serve lawful
search and arrest warrants at the branch
davidian compound near waco texas
several residents of the compound died
that day as well
the ensuing standoff again as we all
know ended 51 days later on april 19th
when the compound erupted in fire
that destroyed the compound more than 70
residents died
on the day of that tragic fire president
clinton directed the treasury and
justice departments to conduct vigorous
and thorough investigations of the
events leading to the loss of law
enforcement and civilian lives secretary
benson created a unique review structure
that i believe was very effective and i
just want to spend a minute uh
describing that
he asked ron noble who by then had been
designated to be the assistant secretary
of treasury for enforcement to lead
treasury's review of atf's involvement
in the case from the beginning of its
investigation of koresh through the
unsuccessful effort to execute search
and arrest warrants
and to ensure that that report was both
comprehensive and impartial the
secretary enlisted the help of three
individuals of national prominence and
integrity watergate prosecutor henry
ruth pulitzer prize-winning journalist
edwin guthman and los angeles police
chief willie williams their role was to
provide guidance to the investigation to
consider its findings and to assess the
final report
in addition to those independent
reviewers selected by secretary benson
the treasury's office of inspector
general
monitor the review team and perhaps most
importantly we consulted 10 non-treasury
experts in tactical operations firearms
and explosives one of those tactical
experts as senator hatch said was john
coleman who's sitting here
with me
this morning
coming this afternoon
the independent analysis of each of
those experts was appended to our report
i understand from the agenda for today
that you're particularly interested in
looking at
the effectiveness of atf's intelligence
gathering and processing in connection
with this investigation of david koresh
and his followers that's a subject
that's a treasury review
thoroughly investigated two years ago
and which we addressed in our report i
would like briefly to highlight uh for
the committee the reviews findings with
respect to that subject
but before i do i'd like to say just a
few words about some of the other
findings in our report
some of which have been touched on and
some of which may or may not be touched
on
first i want to emphasize one thing that
we learned that i hope is not lost in
these hearings
and that is that the rank and file
agents of atf who were sent to enforce
federal firearms laws
at branch civilian compound did their
very best to perform their assigned
tasks under extremely difficult
circumstances many of those line agents
some of whom we'll hear from later today
demonstrated what was often spectacular
courage
in the face of extraordinary gunfire as
the committee considers today the
failures at waco
i hope it remembers the individual acts
of dedication and bravery and courage
that occurred as well
in addition uh before getting to the
intelligence function the review
concluded that atf properly initiated
investigation of david koresh and his
followers after receiving complaints
from local law enforcement officials we
found no support for allegations that
were prominent at the time that atf
targeted koresh because of his religious
beliefs and to the contrary in light of
the information uh presented by local
authorities it would have been
irresponsible we concluded for atf not
to have initiated an investigation
we also addressed the question whether
atf had probable cause to believe that
people inside the compound possessed and
were manufacturing illegal machine guns
and explosive devices it's been talked
today about the first fourth amendment
and the question whether uh they behaved
appropriately at behaved appropriately
and executing attempting to execute the
warrant
we learned and laid out in detail in our
report how atf agents painstakingly
traced the paper trail of transactions
involving firearms firearms parts and
chemicals how they interviewed local law
enforcement officials neighbors and
former residents of the compound
by late february 1993 atf had amassed an
impressive amount of evidence that
koresh was unlawfully possessing and
manufacturing machine guns and explosive
devices more than enough to justify the
issuance of search and arrest warrants
unfortunately the review also found
serious problems once atf turned from
developing probable cause to deciding
how best to use that information the
development of the raid plan and the
implementation of that plan were marred
by disturbing evidence of flawed
decision making
inadequate intelligence gathering
miscommunication and serious supervisory
failures
we also discovered and addressed what we
concluded were deliberately misleading
statements uh after the raid about the
raid by certain atf supervisors i will
confirm the rest of my remarks just for
another minute or two
on
uh the subject of the flaws in the
indulgence gathering and processing
aspects of ats investigation
with the help of our tactile tactical
experts including john coleman
the review concluded that atf's
intelligence operation was deeply flawed
in several critical respects and the
intelligence failures identified in our
report
related both to the planning of the
february 28th raid and to the execution
of the raid
itself those failures could have been
avoided we concluded had there been a
separate centrally managed intelligence
structure designed to collect analyze
and disseminate intelligence information
even though atf's national response plan
called for an intelligence coordinator
and an agent was indeed assigned to that
role that agent had was given virtually
no intelligence responsibilities and had
none on the day of the raid instead the
dissemination analysis of intelligence
information was often a hit or miss
proposition
with those best suited to evaluate the
information either never receiving it at
all or or being too bogged down with
other duties to appreciate its
significance
atf's intelligence efforts did uncover a
great deal of information that was
relevant to the planning of an
enforcement action it directed against
koresh and against evidence of firearms
and weapons violations at the compound
unfortunately there again was no
effective system in place to coordinate
analyze and follow up on that
information
as a result the tactical planners
developed their enforcement approach
based on information that was too often
inadequate inaccurate or misunderstood
uh i'll save to see my time is up i'll
say for uh response to question specific
items of uh intelligence failures that
led to both the
development of a raid plan that was
flawed and the development
and a flawed decision to go forward with
the raid suffice it to say
that
serious weaknesses in atf's intelligence
gathering and analysis contribute to
contributed to the tragic results on
february 28th fortunately it's my
understanding uh that atf has made
substantial changes both in terms of
structure uh and in training that
directly address those intelligence
failures uh thank you again mr chairman
for giving me the opportunity to make
this statement well thank you mr moulton
that was an excellent statement mr
coleman we'll turn to you thank you mr
chairman
as you've indicated my name is john
coleman i'm a retired captain from the
los angeles county sheriff's department
having retired in 1987 with over 26
years of law enforcement experience
in addition to assignments within patrol
detective technical services and
administrative divisions i spent almost
nine years with the department's
tactical unit as a swat team leader and
then later as a swat commander
during my tenure with the department i
was involved in the resolution of over
225 barricaded suspect incidents
25 hostage incidents in the service of
over 300 high-risk warrants
i was a principal planner of the 1969
raid at the spawn movie ranch which led
to the arrest of charles manson and his
cult following the tate labyanka murders
this operation involved over 150
tactical and non-tactical personnel as
well as numerous departmental and other
agency resources i was also the chairman
of the interagency in transit security
subcommittee for the 1984 summer olympic
games in los angeles and have planned
many tactical and conventional
operations at varying magnitudes
in 1983 i founded the now thriving
national tactical officers association
an organization comprised of past and
present members of law enforcement or
military swat units and acted as its
director until 1993 when i relinquished
control to board of directors and new
executive director i'm a graduate of
california state university at los
angeles where i earned both bs and m.a
degrees i'm also a graduate of the fbi
national academy as well as numerous law
enforcement related schools and courses
of instruction
i'm the author of a guide to the
development of special weapons and
tactic teams and many articles which
have appeared in various law enforcement
journals i've provided instruction to
literally thousands of police officers
from throughout the united states canada
and other countries on subjects varying
from swat operations to patrol
procedures
i'm an adjunct faculty member or former
adjunct faculty member of numerous
california colleges and universities the
international association of chiefs of
police united states department of
energy central training academy and
other organizations which provide police
training
i am well aware of the important role
properly processed information has in
achieving operational success
my practical experience ranges from
utilizing intelligence data for
pre-planned events such as the 1984
summer olympic games and the 1987
pan-american games to directing complex
undercover narcotics operations in the
service of high-risk warrants
this experience has caused me to greatly
appreciate the value of appropriate
intelligence as a member of the tactical
expert advisory panel for the us
department of the treasury i reviewed
numerous documents interviews video
tapes and other information related to
the attempted service of search and
arrest warrants at the branch davidian
compound outside of waco texas by agents
of the bureau of alcohol tobacco and
firearms on february 28 1993
the results of my independent review are
included
as mr moulton indicated one of the
appendices to the treasury report
although i identified and discussed a
number of deficiencies including those
related to the intelligence function by
far the most significant was the
identification of a failure on the part
of command personnel to properly direct
and control most phases of the operation
however i ultimately concluded that had
the operation not been compromised by
the media unwittingly or otherwise there
was a reasonable expectation that it
would have succeeded
with specific reference to the
intelligent aspects of the operation i
think it's important for all of us to
understand that intelligence is a
support function it doesn't exist in and
of itself it is a support function that
assists planners and command personnel
in making appropriate tactical decisions
and tactical choices
the relationship that exists between
intelligence and operational success was
well recognized from the beginning by
atf planners confirmation of that
concern is reflected by the various
sources planners utilize to obtain
pertinent information
these sources fell within accepted
intelligence categories and they are as
many of you know human imagery and
electronically and consisted
of the following and for sake of time i
won't read all of these but just
selectively
interviews of former cult members
interviews of neighbors ups employees
criminal records checks court documents
so on and so forth again demonstrating
an appreciation for the importance of
intelligence
importantly planners took into account
their assigned objective which was of
course affecting search and arrest
warrants at the compound and established
perceived requirements for example in
order to obtain the most relevant
information planners prepared a list of
38 questions to ask of former cult
members responses to these questions
establish critical information such as
the location of firearms the threat of
mass suicide and the self-sustaining
capabilities of the cult this
information along with that from other
sources prompted planners to select what
they believed to be the best tactical
alternative and as we all know now that
was a dynamic warrant service which
relies upon surprise speed and diversion
updated information was provided by an
undercover person by undercover
personnel residing in the house across
from the compound while establishment of
the house was an essential element of
the operation did not realize its full
potential because of a lack of initial
direction and control and of course this
coupled with the lack of an established
system of analyzing data received from
all sources resulted in the
dissemination of some information that
were these are incorrect or partially
correct
other cause i'm sorry other issues of
significance both related and unrelated
to intelligence activities are discussed
within my independent report
there are undoubtedly those within the
field of academia and we've heard from
some of them today and even some within
the field of law enforcement who believe
that planners should have consulted with
so-called cult experts psychologists and
sociologists before before deciding to
serve warrants at the compound in my
opinion for planners to have done so
would have accomplished little or
nothing of significance under the
circumstances consulting with outside
experts would not only have breached
operation security during the critical
planning stage but would have in no way
enhance the recognized elements of
surprise speed and diversion necessary
to dynamically serve search and arrest
warrants at the compound and please
don't misunderstand i'm not saying that
law enforcement should not take
advantage of available resources i'm
saying that circumstances will dictate
what resources should be accessed
for example had they chosen to contain
the compound in order the surrender of
david koresh and his followers
consultation with outside experts would
have been logical
however they chose not to do so
because of the threat of mass suicide
and reasons we've already discussed
as already mentioned i believe all noted
deficiencies were identified and related
within the treasury report to their
credit the department of the treasury
accepted the report as an extensive
objective review of batf's involvement
and the new administration of the atf
implemented many of the recommendations
included in the report
others are planned for future
implementation in so doing both entities
ensured that the loss of four agents and
the wounding of 20 others was not in
vain
lastly as an american citizen and former
law enforcement officer i've grown
increasingly disturbed
at the seemingly unending attacks
against the dedicated men and women of
the bureau of alcohol tobacco and
firearms who because of initial orders
to the contrary when they were unable to
defend themselves verbally
these attacks have been made through the
media by various groups with motives
that are all too apparent
unfortunately it's been my
observation that the direction of
congressional hearings thus far has only
added to the lack of understanding and
ill will that has existed since february
28 1993 and further eroded public
confidence in federal law enforcement
and of course by association all law
enforcement suggestions that the atf be
disbanded and or its duties and
responsibilities transferred to other
already overburdened federal agencies
are in my opinion unnecessary and
ill-advised especially at a time when
violent firearms related crime is
proliferating at an almost unprecedented
rate and if i might digress just for a
brief moment i think it's significant
that the international association of
chiefs of police
which is the organ of law enforcement in
this country at their 100th annual
convention
passed a resolution opposing the merger
of atf with the fbi
anyone who has read or even skimmed
through the treasury report cannot help
but recognize a tremendous effort that
was expended by the department of the
treasury members of the waco review
staff and individual members of the
expert panel to identify deficiencies
and organization structure and
performance of the batf the personnel
changes that occurred as a result of the
review were unparalleled within my
experience
i don't know what more anyone could
expect or have them do
as i mentioned in my statement before
the joint house subcommittee hearings in
july of this year atf agents are sworn
to enforce the laws of our country laws
enacted by congress
that is what they were doing on february
28 1993 and that is what they are trying
desperately to do to this day despite
the adversity created by repeated
attacks against their agency i've had
the opportunity to work with agents of
the atf throughout my career and i've
always found them to be dedicated
professionals who do a difficult and
unpopular job very well
i encourage you i encourage you to
objectively review the investigative
work that has already been done
and look at the positive changes that
have already been implemented by atf i
believe this review will reflect the
need for no further action on a part of
congress thank you very much for the
opportunity to enter the state thanks to
both of you uh mr moulton as project
director you were instrumental in
putting together the treasury review
of waco
and an important part of that was
picking uh
experts to assist you and one of whom of
course is mr coleman that's correct and
uh we've appreciated the testimony that
both of you have had here today
and uh
you know i have to say also that one of
my concerns was the immediate
resort to the planned use of force
to me any dynamic entry should have been
a last
resort
not an early resort at waco the tactical
planters did not give sufficient time
and effort into
considering and analyzing the
alternatives to a raid
and i'd have to say that the treasury
review agrees with that sentiment as
well
because the review concludes that quote
the agency's failure to gather
information needed to assess the chances
of such alternatives succeeding
made its uh rejection of them and its
choice of raid option far too premature
so i was
very interested in that report
mr mullen in light of your colleagues
comments that atf should not be
disbanded or moved
do you agree with that do you have an
opinion or two on that
my response is that that atf absolutely
should not be disbanded or moved based
on what happened in waco two and a half
years ago uh you know what i think that
there are interesting arguments to be
made in terms of efficiencies in federal
law enforcement on the one hand versus
problems inherent in putting all federal
law enforcement authority in one or just
several sources
but one thing that is clear atf i think
should not be judged on what happened uh
on april 28th
in waco or near waco texas atf and my
experience as a prosecutor
is a wonderful law enforcement
organization if you go and talk we heard
a lot earlier about local law
enforcement and the cop on the beat if
you go talk to the cop on the beat i
think anywhere in this country and ask
them what law enforcement agency in the
federal system they most effectively
work with they'll tell you nine times
out of ten that it's atf atf does a lot
of things very well
there were
in the operation waco a number of very
serious problems we tried to identify
them as best we could in the report my
understanding is that
most of the problems we identified if
not all of them have been a directly
directly addressed by the new management
at atf so the one thing i would urge i
don't have a final opinion for you but i
would urge that
any decision about moving federal law
enforcement responsibilities around
particularly those involving atf that
will be based on what atf does today
based on uh on its area of expertise
potential losses from such a move and
not be based on a single tragic event uh
of now two and a half years ago well
thank you mr coleman your statement was
excellent uh both of you were were
excellent here today i think you've
added a lot to this so let's turn to
senator biden thank you very much mr
moulton uh
your review concluded that atf's
inquiranda koresh and the davidians
was consistent with the agency's
congressional mandate
to enforce federal firearms laws isn't
that correct that's correct senator
biden and in fact didn't the review
conclude that atf would have been remiss
and irresponsible if it had not sought
to enforce the law against corrections
followers that's correct atf was
presented with evidence from a local
sheriff's department
and ups delivery driver of a potential
serious uh long-standing violations of
federal firearms and explosives laws in
addition it had reason to believe uh
that the corrections as followers might
pose a danger not only to themselves but
but to the surrounding community and had
atf
uh not followed up on those uh
those concerns raised by local law
enforcement i think we might be having
hearings today asking why they didn't
now let me ask you which raises the
third and final question i have because
i've read your report and um and your
testimony is self-explanatory
um
a lot of people
have the notion
i shouldn't say a lot of people okay
a lot in terms of absolute numbers a
small number in terms of percentage of
the american population
have the notion
that uh
atf and the fbi have been running around
and infiltrating organizations targeting
religious groups targeting folks
and that what happened in waco was they
did just that they had this guy david
correction a bulletin board or something
in the atf offices and they had
the fbi had this and they said you know
we got to figure a way to get this son
of a gun
isn't the way it actually happened
and that's worth reiterating
that local officials
picked up the phone and called atf and
said i think we got a problem here
that's absolutely correct senator the
as far as we were able to determine
david koresha was not someone known to
atf at all prior to
may of 1992 at which time the mclennan
county sheriff's department
called atf and said we have some
information here from a ups delivery
driver as well as information we've
developed ourselves interviewing
neighbors etc that is of concern to us
we think it raises
issues of federal firearms violations
it's beyond our ability to handle it
would you please come in and help us i
don't think that gets to whether or not
uh um
uh
um
i i don't think that goes to whether or
not they made mistakes but i think it
goes to
one of the central
central
themes out there among the
conspiratorial folks
left and right and center not many in
the center but left and right who see
everything as some great conspiracy
since i've been in washington which has
been a while now
i've become convinced that few
conspiracies are probably true because i
find people are usually pretty stupid
and to keep a conspiracy going you got
to have a lot of very bright people who
are able to keep secrets and i've not
found that in washington or wilmington
um you know i i i always find it fast
seriously when you think about these
conspiracy theories they rest upon a
notion that there's this network of
people who can keep a secret my lord i
mean i was in the intelligence committee
we couldn't even keep the intelligence
committee did administrations couldn't
even keep secrets about you know
backfire bombers and whether or not what
they were doing i mean we couldn't keep
secrets about stealth bombers uh and the
idea that everybody's out there we got
this conspiracy i mean i listen to the
rush limbaugh's of the world and you can
i shouldn't say that i don't know what
he said on that um but
conspiracy
theories and it's very important i think
to establish
this wasn't big brother
sitting up in washington going now let's
look across the map out here oklahoma
there's another one of those groups out
there let's target them
local people called federal officials
who were local i expect
and said we got a problem can you come
and help us right that's right atf
behaved exactly as we would want atf to
behave up through the time or up until
the time let's assume they didn't even
behave let's assume they didn't even
behave well all i want to establish for
the record let's not confuse it
is real simple
nobody in washington
nobody in atf nobody involved with atf
had an idea that you know
those branch davidians are dangerous
people
koresh is a dangerous guy we've got to
be aggressive and go after them
that's correct this this investigation
was begun at the request of the local
law enforcement not based on any uh
effort or desire to target koresh and uh
and his followers
hold on a second
to
please
now there's been claims that atf has
been
my time is up
uh senator hatch asked if i would
continue and then after that
as mrs feinstein to take over i only
have one question
it's probably
i'm going to read mr coleman from
page six of your statement
not the whole paragraph just two
sentences out of the paragraph as an
american citizen and former law
enforcement officer
i'm going i've grown increasingly
disturbed by the seemingly on ending
attacks against the dedicated men and
women of the
bureau of atf who because of the initial
orders the contrary one were unable to
verbally defend themselves and then the
last sentence unfortunately the
direction congressional hearings have
taken thus far
has only added to the lack of
understanding and ill will that has
existed since february 28 93 and further
eroded public competence in law and
federal law enforcement by association
all law enforcement
uh are you suggesting here in your
opening statement that
congress and the critics of the atf
are responsible for the crisis of law
enforcement today
and of course i understand your desire
to defend atf
but to what extent do you think that
there is a crisis in confidence and to
what extent does atf have a role in that
crisis
i think we're looking uh here senator a
situation where from the very inception
there have been a tremendous amount of
misinformation disseminated
some inten intentionally some
unwittingly
some
purely because of the lack of factual
data that was available at the beginning
and this of course was disseminated
understandably through the media
the
the house hearings i think did little to
clarify
some of the misconceptions that the
american people have about what really
occurred
and what was disturbing to me was that i
donated a week of my life to come to
washington to help la some of those
fears during the house hearings and i
was asked one question during a six hour
period
and tactical questions on the other hand
we're asked of a well-intentioned young
woman joyce sparks
uh who has no knowledge of tactics who
knows the social worker aspect but
certainly nothing having to do with what
was tactically done and why it was done
and why dynamic entry was selected
dynamic entry
is a simple procedure in terms of
definition it's not a military attack
it's not a military symbol it doesn't
come from the military it's nothing more
than an unexpected vigorous
entry and because it's unexpected of
course it relies upon surprise speed and
diversion in terms of the misleading
statements there are all kinds of
organizations out there that have
utilized the media
do you
feel well no i think your answer is
legitimate but we're short on time uh do
you think that congress by having
hearings is somewhat responsible for the
crisis of confidence no absolutely not i
think the hearings are justified and
they're necessary well then
then the second part of my question is
[Music]
does atf have any responsibility
for the price for the crisis of
confidence that you talk about
and i and i talk about it as well atf
has responsibility and they're
accountable for their actions and i
think they've stood up they have been
counted and what i'm saying is that
when these hearings conclude
there is has been enough investigation
to look at what transpired and to learn
from them and there are tremendous
amount of learning points from what
happened i teach them i emphasize to
local law enforcement and state law
enforcement what needs to be done to
correct some of the deficiencies not
within atf but within law enforcement as
a whole because what atf did
is probably no different than what many
local law enforcement agencies would do
in terms of approach in terms of what
intelligence information they had they
had faulty intelligence information and
based on that they made some mistaken
judgments i think that they wouldn't
have made otherwise i think you've
answered my question i'd just like to
say again what i said this morning i
start out with a presumption
that law enforcement officials are good
until proven otherwise just like i hope
the public will start out with a
presumption that members of congress are
good until proven otherwise but i do
believe that there's a serious
management and cultural problems that
need to be addressed these hearings
partly address that but these are very
fundamental problems
the militarization of
domestic law enforcement is a problem
and i think we have to deal with that
i'm done could i comment on that please
yes of course you can i mean as long as
many of you have alluded to the fact
that that law enforcement has become too
militaristic i think we all know that
organizationally law enforcement the
united states is paramilitary it's
paramilitary in terms of structure and
organization but i'm sure that what you
are talking about when you say that law
enforcement is becoming militaristic is
that you're referring to
characterization
of
people that are working specialized
tactical assignments such as special
response teams swat teams things of that
nature because of the photos
because of the photos that you showed
earlier uh during the hearings
and
the reason that this image occurs is
because of the functional equipment that
swat teams the tactical units have to
utilize to protect the members of the
community and themselves and i know
you're not proposing that protective
gear such as
helmets which some members of the house
during the hearings characterized as
darth vader helmets those are protective
ballistic helmets they serve a
legitimate life-saving function vest the
weaponry that's utilized
is utilized for good reason because of
the propensity toward violence and the
types of weaponry that law enforcement
is encountering today and if what we're
seeing is because these are similar to
weapons and equipment that are being
utilized by the military
that we shouldn't do this any longer
that we should go back to the six shot
revolver and go up and knock on the door
of a compound that contains the type of
weaponry that uh existed outside of waco
texas i think is ludicrous
let me clarify mr
chairman
i'm not talking about weapons
or equipment i'm talking about
an attitude that puts tactical
over the life-saving efforts that i
think have been the tradition
and the significance of local law
enforcement i think it's still a
tradition
it's still a tradition law enforcement
goes into an operation and utilizes
those resources that are available i
think what senator grassley's referring
to is that there were mistakes here you
both admit that and
and
basically they occurred because of the
misuse of
of well they didn't have an intelligence
the correct intelligence for one reason
didn't have a appropriate
instructions and and frankly these
mistakes were made everybody admits that
the question is
what can we do to make sure that doesn't
happen again and and we are concerned
about
paramilitary or military operations that
should be used as a last resort not a
first resort
and i think you make some very very
telling points here today
that i think are very important to this
committee and to those who are
considering law enforcement thank you
we've all watched television and swat
teams and we've seen them uh adulated
for the sacrifices they made well i've
watched the hrt
i've gone down and seen them in action
these are people who risk their lives
all the time for us they don't get any
publicity
most people haven't even heard of them
vis-a-vis swat teams
but the fact of the matter is they they
have done heroic things
to protect americans all over the world
and uh because there have been some
mistakes here uh uh you know they're
they're uh
you know they're under strict scrutiny
by many who haven't understood
the missions or the goals that they uh
they they live for and
and some of them
risk their lives for so
uh you i think have done a very good job
of helping us to understand some of
those so we really appreciate it senator
feinstein will finish with you
i thank you mr chairman
mr coleman i think one of the strengths
and one of the reasons that americans
can
trust law enforcement more because of
these hearings
is because they're bringing to light the
fact that the fbi and the atf are making
changes in procedures
based on problems encountered in
missions and incidents that they've
uh taken play that that they have been
involved in
i think that's a big strength let me ask
you a question if you were the commander
would you have used tanks
are you referring to the fbi involvement
or the i i'm referring to the use of
tanks at the branch davidian
headquarters and my question to you is
if you were the commander would you have
used tanks given the knowledge that the
individual that made that decision had
at the time yes i would have and i think
it's important to note
that there was a lot of intelligence
information that was valid that came in
to the the decision-making process
and a lot of it had to do with the open
terrain surrounding the compound if
there had been any other
piece of equipment that could have been
used whether it had been a fire truck a
dump truck anything that would have
stopped the caliber of weapon that that
senator biden demonstrated earlier
during the hearings a 50 caliber bullet
in other words they would have used
the use of of the type of armor that
they used was selected because it had
the ability to stop the projectiles that
were being utilized there was no attempt
i don't believe at least nothing that i
was able to uncover in in the review
that
that anyone approach this with the
intent of being perceived as utilizing
all the military
fire power all the military armor that
they could possibly muster they tried to
approach it in as logical a manner as
any law enforcement agency could but
when it was determined there's no cover
that's why they use the armor i'm
limited in time and i appreciate it i
wanted to get your view i'd like to now
go to mr moulton if i might
and go to your page six of your of your
comments
and let's talk about the intelligence
because i think
um your written comments mr moulton
which i i have reviewed i think are very
helpful in looking at this
um
and
then i'll go to you mr coleman and
perhaps you'll tell me what was right
about the intelligence let's talk for a
moment about what was wrong
you point out the following on page six
that the planners believe that koresh
never left the compound
when in fact he did
that atf failed to provide the agents
in the undercover house with enough
technical support
that
raid planners misunderstood the nature
and certainty of the intelligence
concerning his movements therefore they
devoted insufficient effort to
developing a plan to lure him away from
the comp compound
you say they believe that all the
weapons were kept under lock and key
when they weren't that all of the men in
the compound would be out on a
construction site at 10 a.m in the day
they weren't
that the women in the compound would be
unarmed they weren't
and that the raid was planned for 10 am
rather than a predawn time which might
have taken them at surpri by surprise
you go on to say that the intelligence
gathering effort failed by leaving
potentially unresources potentially
important resources untapped
um
would you expand on that please
well or just on the last point or
the
the the written statement uh captures
what we said in the report which was
that there were fundamental problems
in terms of really all three aspects of
successful intelligence operations one
in terms of the development of adequate
and reliable information
two in terms of the dissemination of
that information to the relevant
decision makers
and three in terms of ensuring that the
decision makers understood both the
meaning and the limitations of the
information they had
in this case the people principally
gathering tactical intelligence those in
the undercover house across from the
compound uh were inadequately supervised
their information they did gather was
not centrally processed and analyzed the
tactical planners as a result believed
they had hard information which was not
hard information i stopped you right at
this point when uh mr rodriguez came out
and said
they know what's going to happen
what needs central supervision about
that it seems to me that means
your you know the surprise element is
blown yeah we concluded if i can answer
the quote
the question we concluded that um
that the information provided by the
undercover agent robert rodriguez was
more than adequate to give the decision
makers enough information to stop the
raid um they and they should have they
understood that surprise was lost and
they failed to stop the raid uh despite
that understanding that's not to say
that the situation couldn't have been
improved one of the problems that we
pointed out in the report was pointed
out by several of our of our experts was
that robert rodriguez was debriefed over
the telephone in a hurried manner uh he
had no control agent no one to sit down
and calmly assess his information
having said that that in other words
that his information could have been
better processed and understood
we nonetheless concluded that he gave
plenty of information sufficient to stop
the raid
mr chairman may i just ask mr coleman
what he believes was right about the
intelligence sure thank you very much
please go ahead yes ma'am uh as i
indicated earlier there were some
positive things about the intelligence
function
of course it's difficult to discuss them
without
first indicating that the the major
problem was a lack of supervision or
direction and control of that operation
for example the establishment of the
undercover house was extremely positive
and the oversight provided by washington
uh atf personnel indicating that they
wanted someone to make contact with
people in the compound and if possible
to make contact specifically with david
cares so that they could assess what was
going on from a first-hand perspective
those are all positive things the
information that these eight gentlemen
gathered
was incredible based upon the lack of
direction they received they referred to
their past experience what they thought
planners would want to know
and they transmitted that information to
the best of their ability they thought
getting to planners in real time when in
fact because of a
failure to have a central processing
system that information was not timely
nor was it entirely accurate
and based upon that false information
planners made their selections they
looked at calling koresh out they looked
at
the
possibility of enticing him through
subterfuge out of the compound but
because of the information they thought
was coming on a 24-hour basis to them
they did not select those alternatives
they didn't go directly to the dynamic
entry they looked at all tactical
options beforehand and as they
established the plan to do these things
intelligence came in that prompted them
to change their mind and so again it's
not that there was not some positive
things about the intelligence gathering
mechanism it's the lack of proper
processing or analyzing evaluating and
then dissemination in a timely manner
that caused the problems
thank you very much both of you thank
you senator feinstein and thanks to both
of you we appreciate having your
testimony here today i think it's been
very helpful to the committee and and to
everybody who's concerned about this
matter so thank you very much thank you
mr chairman
now
i'm running out of time for this morning
because i have to be at this caucus
meeting but let me just say i'm going to
go ahead with the next three witnesses
and let them make their statements
before lunch and then we'll recess uh
furniture
till
an appropriate time
but with the appearance of the next
panel i feel that it's important to
emphasize that the line agents are not
to be blamed for the tragedy
but rather are to be commended for their
service and heroism
they remain victims
in the aftermath of waco with their
physical scars and painful memories
so i don't blame these line uh officers
agents nor should anybody else
our next panel consists of some of these
agents jerry petrilli
chief
jeff brzezowski
and roger guthrie
agent petrilli was the uh
dallas srt team leader for the raid
agent brozzowski was one of the
undercover agents who lived in the
undercover house risked his life for us
and agent guthrie was one of the forward
observers
all three of whom risked their lives in
different ways each of these three
agents contributed to or relied on
the intelligence gathering and
information collection that was done in
preparation of the raid
in different areas each of these agents
will describe how intelligence and
information was gathered and how
surveillance was done
in its entirety their testimony will
demonstrate problems with the methods of
gathering intelligence and information
during the waco investigation
in each of their areas of participation
and what it meant in the ultimate
execution of atf's plan
now i hope you can limit yourselves to
five minutes each if you can't we'll
understand but but i'd like you to if
you can
and we appreciate having you here like
i've said you folks are heroes to me
and i think to others who who really
know
uh how you risk your lives for us
and uh and and do it uh repetitively but
especially in this particular case we'll
start with you mr petrelli first
chairman hatch and distinguished
committee members my name is jerry
petrilli and this statement is being
made regarding the events leading up to
the attempted service of search and
arrest warrants at the branch davidian
compound at mount carmel on february 28
1993 and the subsequent events that took
place
i would first like to say that it is an
honor to speak before this committee and
in some part to represent the fine
agents of the bureau of atf and
specifically the 106 special agents who
came under fire on february 28 1993
but most importantly to pay tribute to
four of our special agents who can no
longer voice opinions express their
views or state the facts
i have been a special agent with atf for
over 19 years serving in new york los
angeles albuquerque new mexico and
currently in washington dc as the
special agent in charge of the tactical
response branch which has oversight of
the special response team program
at the time of this action i was
assigned to albuquerque new mexico as
the resident agent in charge and was
also the team leader of the dallas
division special response team
during my years with atf i have received
tactical training in numerous
disciplines from organizations which
include the national tactical offices
association the international
association of chiefs of police los
angeles county sheriff's department los
angeles police department dallas police
department and many many others
in preparation for the service of the
warrants on february 28 1993
i attended four planning meetings in the
houston and waco texas area starting in
december of 1992.
at these meetings i interacted with a
number of colleagues in the tactical
planning process and in addition spent
countless hours at the albuquerque
office and at my home on this assignment
it should be noted that all srt work is
voluntary and collateral to our regular
duties
during the days prior to the service of
the warrants i participated in
mission-specific training at fort hood
texas along with all of the other
participants in the warrant service
during this training i presented the
plan to the dallas team which was
predominantly responsible for securing
the second floor and the three towers an
area believed to be occupied by women
and children
in addition we had agents from the team
clearing a building to the north
providing security to a forward observer
team and clearing vehicles
during this training refinements in the
plan were constantly interjected keeping
in mind the safety of the children as a
paramount concern
late on the afternoon of friday february
26th we learned of a newspaper article
being released that evening regarding
the lack of law enforcement action in
regards to the activities of the branch
davidians
as a result of this article and a
concern that it would cause a heightened
alertness by the branch davidians the
operation was moved up from monday march
1st to sunday february 28th
on the morning of february 28th i
traveled from fort hood to a staging
area in waco and at approximately nine
am asex cereben the tactical commander
of the operation announced that the
branch davidians knew we were coming
that no preparations were being made by
them
but that we must go quickly i then
proceeded with last minute preparations
for the team and we departed the staging
area in cattle trailers and route to the
branch davidian compound
at approximately 9 45 a.m as we turned
into the compound i was riding in the
first cattle trailer which stopped at
the far end of the structure i was in
the third row of special agents exiting
the vehicle and after taking
approximately four or five steps i
realized that we were taking rounds from
the compound i continued across the open
area behind other vehicles until i came
to an open area leading to the front
door
i turned in this area heading towards
the front door when i felt a large
concussion which at the time i believed
was from a shotgun round hitting me i
continued a few steps forward and placed
myself down behind a fence line and
returned fire with my handgun
at some time into the firefight i took
the time to examine myself and found
that i had been hit in the right arm
wrist and hand and in the upper left arm
in addition i saw holes across the chest
area of my load-bearing vest but felt no
injury
i was continually pinned down in this
area by gunfire from the branch
davidians for the next hour and 52
minutes
during this time i spent excuse me
during this time i believe i was shot at
with m16s ar-15s
ak-47s and a 50-caliber weapon
i also attempted to no avail to organize
a rescue of special agent king who was
pinned down in the center of the
compound
only after a ceasefire was negotiated
were four very brave special agents able
to rescue special agent king before he
bled to death from his wounds
when the ceasefire was finally
negotiated i started down the driveway
with other agents when it was pointed
out to me that an agent was lying on top
of the roof where the new orleans team
had been
i turned and went back with other agents
following and climbed the ladder and
rolled over an agent and verified that
he was dead
i then saw another agent on the downward
slope of the roof and did the same
i then assisted in removing our dead
special agents and left the property and
walked to awaiting medical transport to
the hillcrest hospital
at the hospital i was examined and the
doctor determined that my wounds were
from a fragmentation grenade
a few weeks later my vest was returned
to me
and i found a 5.56 millimeter round in
the chest pocket area which was stopped
by a tool in the pocket of my best
i would like to cl i would like to close
by continuing with my tribute to our
four special agents who can no longer
voice opinions express their views or
state the facts because on february 28
1993
while attempting to serve lawful
warrants for violations of laws passed
by the united states congress and signed
by the president of the united states
and entrusted to the bureau of atf for
enforcement
they were murdered
by members of the branch davidian who
choose to chose to violently oppose this
lawful action
the branch davidians didn't take the 45
minutes of advanced knowledge of this
activity to flee from law enforcement as
most criminals would
they didn't choose to hide or destroy
evidence as many criminals would do
they didn't choose to contact law
enforcement through their attorney who
was present in the compound as some
criminals would do
instead they chose to create an ambush
for law enforcement which resulted in
four special agents dying
it left three widows and two children
without a father and it left many
parents relatives friends and loved ones
to grieve to this day
in addition the choice left over 30
other special agents wounded an entire
bureau and a nation affected to this day
my statement is dedicated to the memory
of conway blue ted todd mckeon rob
williams and steve willis
thank you agent petrelli we'll now turn
to you mr brzezowski
chairman hatch and distinguished
committee members
my name is jeff berzowski i'm a special
agent with the bureau of alcohol tobacco
firearms assigned to the austin texas
field office
i've been employed as a special agent
with atf for seven years prior to this i
was employed as a criminal investigator
with the u.s customs service for
approximately one year
in december of 1992 i was assigned to
assist in the investigation of vernon
howe also known as david koresh
it was at this time that a decision was
made by atf supervisors to set up a
surveillance post near the compound
initially i was assigned the task of
gaining the cooperation and approval of
a neighboring landowner to allow atf to
use a vacant house on his property for
surveillance
in early january 1993 i was one of seven
atf agents assigned to participate in
what was supposed to be a two-week
surveillance operation in which i would
live and work in the house across the
road from the davidian compound
this assignment required that the other
agents and i take on the identity of
college students
in order to explain our living in the
house
this house was located approximately 250
yards away from the compound and was a
few miles from the texas state technical
college
during those first two weeks we operated
in eight-hour shifts agents watched the
compound 24 hours a day and documented
their observations
during this time agents watched the
compound took photographs and videotaped
some of the activity at the compound
among the subjects of the surveillance
were the vehicles individuals and
structures associated with the compound
from this vantage point across the road
agents could see only the front and some
of either side of the compound during a
typical daytime shift agents would see
periodic movement of compound residents
for instance several men might be seen
going to and working on the structure
next to the compound known as the pit
routinely women were seen carrying
buckets into a field and dumping their
contents
although there were several vehicles at
the compound they were rare they would
rarely leave with the exception of the
car which was driven by a compound
member who was a contract mail carrier
at night there was even less activity
observed agents might watch for hours
without seeing any movement whatsoever
it appeared from surveillance that the
guard shack was not manned and there
were no armed sentries or patrols at the
compound
in late january in 1993 i learned that
our assignment the house was to be
extended the focus of the operation was
to be directed at infiltrating the
compound rather than merely observing it
from this point on we were instructed to
summarize the activities observed at the
compound we were to document in detail
only those activities which were
inconsistent with the routine noted by
previous surveillance
over the next several weeks at the
instruction of our supervisors we
initiated contacts with davidian members
in an effort to get inside the compound
one day in early february 1993 these
efforts were successful when agent
rodriguez was invited inside the
compound
later that same day i was also invited
inside
over the next several weeks agent
rodriguez had approximately seven
occasions to enter the compound and i
had one other occasion to enter i was
also invited to shoot guns with koresh
on february 28 1993 in the hours leading
up to the planned raid i was assigned to
transport a team of atf forward
observers to a position near the
compound i was present in the
surveillance house on the morning of the
raid when agent rodriguez alerted atf
supervisors that the raid had been
compromised
after decision was made to go forward
with the raid i was assigned to the
residence next door to the surveillance
house in this house lived a family who
worked at the ranch on which their house
sat
at about 9 30 a.m on sunday february 28
atf agents attempted to serve the search
and arrest warrants at the compound
at the time the trailers pulled in i
heard what sounded like machine gun and
heavy weapon fire at the compound
i moved the family to a closet in the
back of their house to protect them from
gunfire we were now receiving from the
compound
following the ceasefire and withdraw of
atf agents family was moved to safety
myself and six other atf agents
maintained our position in the
surveillance house in the hours that
followed i helped to transport davidian
children safely from the area these were
the children caress released shortly
after the ceasefire while early
negotiations were underway
from march 1993 until may of 1993 i was
assigned to the atf intelligence unit
located at the atf command post waco
texas
i would like to conclude by saying that
during my career i've had the occasion
to be involved into the most significant
law enforcement investigations of our
times being the branch davidian and
oklahoma city bombing investigation
i have witnessed firsthand the tragic
loss of human life as a direct result of
the actions of criminals with extremist
views who have the unlawful weaponry to
carry out their deadly agenda
during these two incidents and many
other investigations of violent
criminals i hope in some small way i
have made this country a safer place for
my family and yours to live i'd be
pleased to answer any questions the
committee may have thank you agent
brazoski uh
agent guthrie we'll turn to you now
chairman hatch and distinguished
committee members my name is roger
guthrie and i'm a special agent with the
bureau of alcohol alcohol tobacco and
firearms
i've been employed as an atf special
agent for approximately 12 years
prior to this i served in the united
states army as a member of the first
ranger battalion
i'm currently assigned to detroit field
division
as the firearms instructor coordinator
and as a special response team team
leader
i've had extensive training in srt type
operations and as a forward observer
also commonly referred to as a sniper
observer
dating back to 1978.
i'd like to take this time to thank each
of you for allowing me the opportunity
to speak
to you today i'm prepared to read a
brief statement
that is a synopsis of my involvement in
the operation conducted near waco texas
in february of 1993.
atf special response teams formerly
known as the entry control teams have
been in existence since 1988.
the srts consist of special agents who
volunteer for this arduous duty
and who are then hand selected to attend
the atf basic training program
the srts are used for such tasks as high
risk warrant service
search warrant situations
witness protection and security for high
risk undercover operations
though often misunderstood tactical
teams such as atf srts
are trained equipped and utilized to
minimize the danger to all persons
involved while maximizing the chance
of having a successful operation
to sum it up tactical teams save lives
all well organized tactical teams employ
the use of specially trained individuals
who are trained to move into an
operational area
and provide decision makers with
real-time intelligence
they also had the capability to provide
precise covering fire
through the use of specially equipped
weapon systems
these individuals may be referred to as
snipers
counter snipers
marksmen
counter snipers or forward observers
whatever their name their job is highly
specialized and significantly important
to the successful completion of any
tactical operation
sniper observers by the virtue of their
enhanced observational capabilities
and surgically precise shooting skills
also save lives
atf ford observers are very well trained
in all aspects of sniper operations they
complete a two-week training school in
addition to their atf basic srt school
this training is conducted at
fort mcclellan alabama which has
excellent facilities that are conducive
to training atf forward observers and
all their necessary disciplines
my involvement in the investigation of
david crash began as a result of my
participation in the atf ford observer
program after reviewing intelligence
related documents materials
and aerial photographs of the branch
davidian compound i made recommendations
as the placement of snipers
and observers around the compound to
support a dynamic entry or to support a
siege of that location whatever whatever
was later decided upon
the forward observer program was
relatively new to atf at this time
the raid planners had not yet received
formal instruction and training in how
to fully utilize all the capabilities of
forward observers
this primarily is include their ability
to gather real-time intelligence
in february of 1993 i was told to report
to fort hood texas and prepare for the
branch davidian operation
my partner larry crystal and i conducted
rehearsals with other forward observers
at fort hood
and also with the srt teams that have
been gathered there
we conducted a drive-by reconnaissance
of the branch
branch davidian compound several days
prior to the scheduled date of the raid
we made recommendations to the raid
planners relating to the placement
insertion time and command and control
of the ford observer teams during
rehearsals conducted at fort hood
other forward observers participating in
the operation voiced similar
recommendations during this time period
on the morning of february 28 1993 my
partner and i occupied a position at the
rear of the compound prior to the
arrival of the srt teams at the front of
the compound
as the srt teams exited the trailers a
tremendous amount of gunfire erupted
from within the compound
during the initial gun battle
we fired at individuals identified as a
threat to ourselves and to other agents
we remain in this position until a
ceasefire was negotiated and all the
agents were extracted from the area
we then occupied and alternate
the agents were extracted from the area
we then occupied an alternate position
at the rear of the davidian compound
at approximately 5 30 pm on the day of
the raid after being ordered to leave
the area
my partner and i and several other
individuals were involved in the second
gun battle with three members of the
branch davidians
this was
this occurred in a field northwest of
the compound
as a result one individual was killed
one was captured and a third individual
escaped and was captured
several days later
during during the following days my
partner and i assisted the fbi the
hostage rescue team in setting up the
sniper observer positions at the rear of
the branch davidian property
i remained on site in waco for
approximately 10 days following the
initial raid and then returned to
detroit
i returned to waco on april 19 1993
with the rest of the detroit srt team
and remained on site for an additional
three weeks prior returning to my field
division
in reflecting on the day of the raid i
now feel that david kresh did not have a
right to resist the efforts of atf
agents discharging their duties on that
day
david cress could have
and indeed should have argued the
validity of that warrant in court
not by and not by ambushing federal
agents assigned to execute the warrant
david
david koresh orchestrated a cowardly and
deadly ambush directed at atf special
agents
within a short time four agents were
dead
and another 20 plus agents were wounded
for 51 days thereafter david koresh
could have peaceably surrendered at any
time
instead he again chose a cowardly
solution by using women and children as
his shields against law enforcement
authorities
over 80 men women and children died
because david koresh in his last
cowardly act of defiance caused a
compound to be said ablaze and then
committed suicide
in the aftermath of waco i feel that atf
continues to produce excellent results
in the war against violent crime
atf has an excellent reputation among
state and local law enforcement agencies
i'm very proud of that
reputation that we have
and this is in terms of
genuine assistance and cooperation that
is lent by atf
the laws we are charged with enforcing
are controversial and often invoke an
emotional response from our citizenry
we do not have the luxury of choosing
which laws we will enforce and which
laws we will ignore
more important more importantly we could
not
ignore violators because their
investigation and or arrest would be too
difficult
too dangerous or too controversial
many positive changes have resulted in
the way we conduct business because of
the lessons that we learned at waco
i'm confident that these changes have
resulted in an atf that is better
equipped
trained and organized to carry out our
mission today than we were in february
of 1993.
thank you well thanks to all three of
you uh
if it's all right we have caucuses to go
to so what i'd like to do is defer
questioning until we get back
after those caucuses are through that'll
give you a chance to have some lunch
and we'll report back here then if you
can all three be in your seats here at 2
30.
we have a vote at 2 15 but i think we
can vote
right up front and get right here by 2
30 and then we'll start asking
uh questions but we appreciate the
testimony of each of you here today
mr chairman yes i'd just like to explain
the panel i have to be in the foreign
relations committee at 2 30 if i'm i
will be a little late coming back it's
not a lack of interest in what the
panelizers say i do have questions i
would not ask you to hold the panel if
you're finished but i do have questions
if i'm able to get back well thank you
we appreciate the testimony of all three
of you we appreciate the service that
you give and we'll look forward to
having some questions for you at 2 30
with that we'll recess till 3 30. thank
you
yes
um
tomorrow this committee will hear from
fbi director louis free along with
several hostage and negotiation
specialists you can see the final
portion of this hearing later this
morning at 3 35 eastern time
voting is definitely important so you
have a voice c-span
the political network of record
next the senate judiciary committee
looks into the march 1993 incident at
the branch davidian compound in waco
texas witnesses testifying during this
final portion of tuesday's hearing
include ron noble undersecretary of the
treasury john mcgah director of the
bureau of alcohol tobacco and firearms
and atf special agents who participated
in the raid the house judiciary
committee held similar hearings in july
yesterday was the first of two days of
hearings before the senate judiciary
committee which is chaired by orrin
hatch of utah this portion of the
hearing runs an hour and 40 minutes
we're uh
we'll begin our afternoon sessions here
uh
i just have a few questions for you i
appreciate your testimony very much
mr petrilli let me just ask you
a couple of things you indicated that
the statement you gave to the waco
review team
in that statement you said that you
quote
harbored reservations regarding the
quality and timeliness of the
intelligence provided in the
investigation
unquote could you elaborate on that
statement for us
yes i felt that
at the time that we were doing these
preparations for these warrants
that
we didn't have a good control system for
all of the intelligence which today we
have certainly improved that
tremendously
but at the time as a planner uh
of the operation
i didn't feel that all of the
information was getting to us that was
being properly processed
and that it could have been handled
better and and obviously later on
through the review uh that proved out to
be true
and i i very glad to say that today that
system would not exist well as a team
leader uh
uh you were one of the planners of the
atf raid yes sir now how can how can a
good tactical plan
uh be based on shoddy intelligence work
well it shouldn't be sir
and
and that was your disadvantage you had
bad intelligence absolutely uh i think
that
the fact is that the plan was relatively
good uh
not only did we think it was good but
the team members thought it was good and
many of the experts have said that it
had a reasonable chance of success
what needed changes if
if you can help the committee would
ensure what changes if you had your way
would ensure
that the failure to adequately perform
intelligence collection and analysis
will not reoccur
in future incidents such as this
actually i think the changes that are
necessary have have taken place in in
recent time now i think atf has done an
excellent job of improving their ability
to manage intelligence
they've created a number of systems
including an intelligence
response unit
that
can assist us on major cases
we've created other positions within our
divisions our intelligence uh
officers within divisions and within our
special response teams we've created
intelligence people so i really think
that we've done an awful lot to improve
that okay now the operational plan was
predicated on the assumption
that the branch davidians would be
separated from their weapons
yes sir that was that was the crux of it
there was no contingency in the
operational plan
in the events that the agents that you
agents were to be confronted with an
ambush right
there
that that's incorrect sir
there were some contingency plans
however those contingencies we admit uh
did not go far enough yeah they were
discussed uh but they did not go far
enough they were not adequate
contingency no i don't believe they were
we felt they were at the time
how could that have gone overlooked in
your opinion i think the the major
problem sir is that
in the history of law enforcement in the
united states
uh we've never encountered a group
that resisted
law enforcement to the degree that the
branch davidians did
we've certainly in law enforcement had
resistance to lawful warrants
but never have we encountered a group of
this size
that would resist us to the degree
that they did
it was not a question of three or four
or a dozen davidians that resisted this
many many i certainly can't answer the
exact number but
bullets came out of almost every window
in that structure at us throughout that
gunfight
and so law enforcement has never
encountered something like that
it was the first time that a religious
group
acted in this fashion i take it
well to this degree sarah for that
degree yes okay
mr berzowski uh
you explained the role and you're in
your opening testimony of the undercover
operation and house across the street
from the branch davidian complex at waco
the under cover operation was 24 hours
daily for only its first two weeks of
operation
then it was diminished uh to only a
morning to night schedule
finally 11 days before the operation was
to take place the entire operation was
shut down
now it's my understanding you correct me
if i'm wrong
that the most important intelligence
information is the information that is
closest in time to the raid
and how do you reconcile those two
notions
uh from my perspective as an agent there
we
were assigned to do the 24-hour
surveillance
we did that
for the first two weeks until it was the
emphasis was changed
towards the end of the
time when the warrant was going to be
executed we were to be removed
from the location
and uh
that that's what we were going to do
until they decided they needed an
undercover agent back in inside the
compound and then we did that i see were
the undercover agents briefed on the
tactical plan
uh
i did not attend any briefings
on the tactical plan
on the uh
night of the 27th
uh
mr agent cereben
informed me of my duties uh the
following day during the execution of
the warrant
no you weren't you did not attend were
there any offered
meetings on the tactical plan to you
folks
to the undercover agents no sir okay
that's what i wanted to establish
isn't it true that many of the
photographs that were taken from the
undercover
house were never even developed
that that's my understanding i i don't
have personal knowledge of that uh but
that's smart but if that's true what
kind of an impact would that have on the
planning of
of
the operation
uh
certainly i think it would be a good
idea
a good idea to develop would have helped
i'm sorry it would have been helpful if
you'd had that done or if they at least
looked at it when they're planning
operations
again i'm not the tactical planner but
if if we're producing some information
or intelligence uh taking the pictures
and videos and whatnot then certainly
they should be developed just makes
sense uh yes sir
now what are your thoughts on the
termination and reinstatement of the two
supervisors at waco
i put you on the spot i know but i'd
like to know what you think
that is a difficult question
i don't know
all the the
reasons for
what was transpired for the rulings
i assumed that the
proper decision was made to reinstate
them
okay that was a tough question yes sir
and you answered it very diplomatically
is what i'm saying yes sir all right
mr guthrie uh
tell us the importance of having
accurate and timely intelligence and
what happens if that process fails in in
operations like you're used to operating
in but especially in this branch
davidian operation
well the the need for developing
intelligence as as you ask
my colleague here earlier the closer the
time is to the
execution of the raid the more critical
the intelligence gathering can become
we call that basically gathering
real-time intelligence
my
specific area
prior my area of responsibility prior to
this raid would have been the collection
of real-time intelligence however
putting this in the right time
perspective our program involving the
ford observers
and their use in gathering real-time
intelligence was relatively new to atf
at the time
and
raid planners the individuals involved
in making the decisions as far as
planning at that time and not been
properly um trained in in the use of
that asset fully trained in the use of
that asset as to what we could benefit
the raid planners and gather real-time
intelligences prior to the raid i think
that
now if this would were to occur again
in any large-scale operation
our people have been
instructed and schooled into the
the use of that asset the forward
observers as their primary function is
gathering real-time intelligence and and
feeding that back to the individuals
making command decisions
involved in last-minute planning things
of that nature and it could have
impacted it it was just unfortunate at
the time that um they they were not
fully aware of the capabilities of
forward observers
do you feel that as the other two do
that changes have been effectuated and
have been implemented since this uh
debacle down there at waco
there's there's been a magnifice to
changes involving the um the interaction
between the forward observers
and individuals in command and control
of an operation
also the
the um
not only the gathering of the
intelligence with the use of the forward
observers but where that intelligence
goes to after after it's gathered and
i'm specifically referring to how it's
disseminated and analyzed there's been
several new
steps implemented
since waco to
analyze and disseminate the information
collected by the forward observers or
from for that matter for any of our
intelligence gathering resources
to
like i said disseminate analyze
disseminate the information of the chain
so it ensures that it reaches the
individuals in command and control the
operation
well
i just want to congratulate each of you
for the work that you've done for the
testimony you've brought here today
you folks
did the job on the ground you did what
you were asked to do
uh it was not your fault that that the
intelligence wasn't there that the
planning wasn't as good as it should
have been that some of the uh
some of the uh
basic procedures uh
that weren't implemented the way they
should have been implemented
but we appreciate having your testimony
today and i think it's been dramatic for
our folks out there and
in the rest of the country to see you
know just what it's like to be an agent
on the ground
without the appropriate backup the
appropriate intelligence the appropriate
planning
uh to have to go in and and face some of
these problems with as you've said
a group that's uh
that's that uh
certainly uh
nobody expected to be to be as uh
as uh tough and as uh
and and as vicious as really it turned
out to be
uh so i
basically uh just want to congratulate
you for being uh who you are and for
what you've done
and for trying to do your job
and you've been candid with us here
today you've acknowledged that there are
things that the agency needs to do and
frankly we're going to now go to the
next panel to see
see if the agency is actually doing what
needs to be done so we want to thank you
and
and we'll let you go
thanks a million thank you sir thank you
sir
uh let me just note for the record that
senator biden is in foreign relations
and he'll try and be back but uh he does
have that dual responsibility so he i
want everybody to know that that's why
he's not here right now but thank you so
much good to have you here
we're going to recess for uh just a few
minutes before we put our last panel on
so we'll recess for uh
for a few minutes thank you
i think we'll begin again we have
we have the honorable ronald mobile
under secretary for law enforcement the
u.s department of treasury here
thus far we have heard from
experts and agents
they have described problems in the
manner in which the investigation of
david koresh and the davidians was
performed
more pointedly they have discussed
pitfalls in the training of agents and
supervisors as well as organizational
problems
this is especially so in the area of
intelligence gathering and information
collection
we now turn to what corrective measures
are being taken by the department of
treasury and the bureau of alcohol
tobacco and firearms
this brings us to the fourth and final
panel of the day ron noble and john
mcgawe mr noble is the undersecretary
for enforcement
at treasury
accompanying the under secretary uh
uh when he gets here john magazine
director of the atf and at this time we
want to welcome
you mr noble we'll welcome mr mcgonn
when he gets here and we want to invite
you to share with us what steps have
been taken
to avoid another wacom
and what have you done to remedy the
errors elucidated by this tragedy that
we've heard of both in the house
hearings and today now you'll notice
that we haven't gone through all the
factual matters again the house did a
good job on that
and we don't see any reason to rehash
all of that but we are concerned
about what steps are being taken or have
been and will be taken uh to resolve
these type of problems so they don't
happen again
and so that's why your testimony is so
important here since you uh you lead
in treasury over atf and uh we're really
looking forward to hearing what you have
to say about it so we'll turn to you at
this time
thank you mr chairman
i have a longer statement that i would
like to submit for the record with the
chairman objection we'll put all full
statements on the record thank you
mr chairman as you uh indicated in your
opening remarks
four atf agents died on february 28 1993
in the branch davidian compound at waco
conway sela blue
todd w mckeon robert j williams and
stephen d willis
because of their deaths as well as the
deaths of the branch davidians in the
events that followed the importance of
how treasury and atf responded cannot be
overstated
for waco and its aftermath have drawn
the attention not only of this country
and this congress
but also the entire world
following the tragedy at waco at
treasury government worked the way it is
supposed to work
the treasury department immediately
conducted a full-scale review of the
events and the issues involved in the
atf raid at waco we made our review
public by publishing a report that has
come to be called the blue book
the report was candid comprehensive and
accurate
among other findings a review bluntly
exposed misstatements made by senior
agents and bureau officials concerning
what actually happened
following the report treasury and atf
have aggressively instituted reforms in
short we made mistakes
we identified them we aired them
publicly
and we responded to them comprehensively
today we can hope and already have
helped to restore confidence in this
country's law enforcement officials we
must recognize that atf has learned the
lessons of waco we must recognize that
steps have been taken to correct
internal organizational flaws we must
recognize that atf makes a singular and
vital contribution to federal law
enforcement
together we can shift the public focus
from a single tragic aberration to atf's
and other federal law enforcement
agencies
many daily successes that help preserve
the rule of law in our nation
indeed this administration will oppose
moving any part of atf out of treasury
major state and local law enforcement
agencies agree that atf plays and should
continue to play a leading role in the
federal government's fight against
violent crime
after the events at waco president
clinton directed that treasury and
justice conduct rigorous and thorough
examinations of what caused the loss of
law enforcement and civilian lives
secretary benson designated me to lead
the treasury department's review
and my fuller version of the oral
remarks what we found in the review have
been set forth clearly and completely
and with your permission i would like to
incorporate those by reference without
without question we'll do that
now let me talk about what has changed
since the report was released over two
years ago
i will focus on the changes made at and
by treasury when director mcgraw arrives
he will focus on the changes he has
spearheaded at atf
first
the department of the treasury ensured
that new leadership was put in place at
atf
two years ago atf gained a new director
when secretary benson
appointed john mcgaugh's director of atf
thereafter
john mcgaw and i'm sure that when you
hear from him again
you'll be impressed as i have been with
the numerous and significant changes he
has made to reform modernize and improve
ats intelligence function
but maga director maga also made
significant personnel changes
that were recommended and later approved
by the treasury department
led to a new associate director for law
enforcement
a new deputy associate director for law
enforcement a new special agent in
charge of the houston office
two new assistant special special agents
in charge in the houston office and a
new chief of intelligence
the waco report stated the principle
that supervisors should be removed from
positions of discretionary authority
when their judgment or integrity cannot
be trusted by those who have to rely on
those qualities and the changes made in
atf's leadership
this principle has been fully vindicated
second
i issued a directive in august 1993
requiring that the office of enforcement
be informed of any significant
operational matters that affect any of
the bureau's missions including major
high-risk law enforcement operations you
might recall from former director
stephen higgins testimony that in his
ten years as director of atf he was
never required to have an operation
approved by main treasury that now has
changed
third in march 1995 i instituted new
guidelines for sensitive undercover
operations atf customs irs criminal
investigation division and secret
service now have sensitive undercover
operations reviewed by a multi-agency
committee that includes representatives
from all treasury enforcement bureaus
and most significantly from the
department of justice's criminal
division as well
fourth
we've improved oversight including
formal and informal communication
between treasury and its law enforcement
bureaus
i established a weekly meeting between
the under secretary's office and the
heads of each of the treasury
enforcement bureaus and key offices the
bureau heads as we call them also meet
regularly with the deputy secretary and
with the secretary of the treasury to
discuss major events and initiatives
based on these reforms an operation of
the scope and complexity of the waco
raid would never be contemplated by one
treasury bureau alone
it would come to the attention of a
variety of law enforcement authorities
as well as my office well in advance of
the planned action
director mcgaw has emphasized and
reemphasized this point over the last
two years you might recall from previous
testimony that maine treasury first
learned about the planned raid near waco
texas on february 26 1993 the very day
that the world trade center bombing
occurred
fifth
i reactivated the treasury enforcement
council the treasury enforcement council
consists of all the bureau heads and
reviews policies and tackles problems
through cross bureau working groups it
is the counterpart of the justice
department's office of investigative
agency priorities the tech
recently completed an 11-month review of
the use of force guidelines for all
treasury enforcement bureaus
the final guidelines became the subject
of discussion with the justice
department and the two departments for
the first time arrived at a uniform set
of guidelines just recently
sixth we have dramatically improved
coordination among federal law
enforcement authorities attorney general
reno has instituted regular meetings for
all justice and treasury law enforcement
bureau heads
secretary rubin is the first treasury
secretary to participate in these
meetings with the attorney general
furthermore deputy attorney general
barelic deputy secretary summers and i
also meet and talk regularly to ensure
proper coordination
and cooperation
my office communicates regularly with
the justice
unibomber assaults white house attacks
the oklahoma city bombing investigation
and on other issues of mutual importance
now all of law enforcement has learned
from the events at waco not only atf not
only the fbi
treasury and atf have shared the painful
lessons learned at waco with the world
by circulating treasury's blue book to
the interpol offices of over 180
countries by giving presentations to law
enforcement groups in the u.s and
internationally
having discussed this matter with my
counterparts throughout the world for
almost three years i can assure you that
the tragedy at waco was an
extraordinarily unusual occurrence
indeed the aberrant errors at waco which
occurred almost three years ago should
not stand in the way of your full
support for this agency and its
implementation of the vital missions
that congress has defined for it
atf is a unique agency
agents who risk their lives each and
every day enforcing the law against the
country's most dangerous criminals
bombers and arsonists work side by side
with officials who are responsible for
enforcing regulatory and tax statutes
governing alcohol tobacco firearms and
explosives products
atf officials are dedicated to the fair
and efficient collection of nearly 14
billion dollars of revenue annually
treasury's philosophy of enforcement
whether it customs in the trade
compliance area or the financial crimes
enforcement network working with other
treasury bureaus in a financial
transactions area or atf in a firearms
explosive area is to try to deter
and prevent crime by combining civil and
criminal authorities and strategies in
innovative ways
the more prevention and deterrence
through education cooperative industry
agency strategies and targeted
regulatory enforcement less need for
launching criminal investigations
while this approach is not always
possible it is a crucial dimension the
way atf approaches firearms violations
and an important aspect of ats location
in the treasury department
finally as we evaluate atf we should
also focus on what it is doing today
and not simply on what happened almost
three years ago at waco mr chairman
members of the committee i look forward
to answering your questions well thank
you uh mr noble i noticed mr mcguz just
coming so i think we'll turn to him
before i ask any questions
uh welcome mr maga we're happy to have
you here and we look forward to
look forward to hearing your testimony
thank you please
please proceed
chairman hatch and distinguished
committee members
in my capacity
as the director of the bureau of alcohol
tobacco and firearms i'm pleased to come
before you today and i'm proud of the
valuable contributions made by atf as a
treasury bureau and i'm very honored to
represent the outstanding women and men
who compromise our comprise our
organization
atf agents continue to put their lives
on the line every day to protect the
american public from the most violent
and dangerous criminals
every day atf inspectors quietly and
efficiently oversee legitimate business
compliance with federal laws involving
industries of alcohol tobacco and
firearms along with explosives
and they collect 13 billion yearly in
revenue
i take all criticism of atf to heart let
me assure you
that if criticism is fair and accurate i
will move vigorously to make corrections
but if criticism is unfair or unfounded
i will defend our bureau with equal
effort
mr chairman i have prepared a long
statement and respectfully request to
submit it for the record in order to
keep these opening comments without
objection we'll do exactly that
as i like as i look back over my tenure
at atf two thoughts strike me
first mr chairman and members of the
committee waco was a terrible tragedy
grave mistakes were made that must never
occur again
i deeply regret the fact that these
mistakes have resulted in the loss of
life coupled with extreme pain and
suffering for many human beings
but please do not view atf solely within
the context of waco it would be unfair
to an agency with such a long history of
quality public service we must also
remember that this was the first time in
american history where law enforcement
was so attacked
we made serious mistakes we have learned
from them and we are sharing them with
all of law enforcement
secondly
all atf jurisdictions are controversial
ones large groups on both sides of every
issue whether it's alcohol whether it's
tobacco or whether it's firearms even
explosives in arson if family planning
clinics are involved
this body and the public should evaluate
with an open mind the negative rhetoric
in the false impressions conjured up by
those with special interests or special
agendas
i invite members of the committee and
their staffs to take the time to look at
the record there you will find the
outcome of the fine work that atf
typically does
every day
my long statement provides many examples
of this exemplary work of which i speak
when i came to atf i found an agency
still mourning the losses of four agents
that were killed by david koresh and his
followers at waco i found an agency
still trying to heal its wounds both
literally and figuratively
i saw it as my responsibility to provide
the leadership necessary to help atf
pass these times and to see that atf
emerge from the waco experience
vastly improved and more effective in
carrying out its dangerous law
enforcement missions i have worked
diligently to keep that commitment
from my experience with atf throughout
my years as a member of the secret
service i knew that the image of atf
personnel as sinister agents looking for
a fight was utterly at odds with the
character and disposition of the atf
personnel that i had interfaced with
mistakes are certainly made every day in
the field of human endeavors including
law enforcement
we can now entirely eliminate mistakes
but we must manage them reduce their
number and certainly minimize their
effects
in the aftermath of waco
we have re-examined completely
our way of doing things
we have moved to correct and improved
management
training operational systems and address
weaknesses identified in the treasury
department's waco review
although this treasury department's
review
were very stinging in their criticism
the reviews accurate unvarnished
findings have provided the framework for
making atf a stronger and more effective
organization
the waco administrative review
identified a number of systemic
weaknesses that contributed to some of
the poor decisions that were made during
the investigation and the subsequent
raid at waco
the first lesson we learned is that atf
cannot carry out alone every conceivable
tactical operation that we might
encounter
prior to waco we did not contemplate
that some operations might be larger or
more complex than adf atf is equipped to
handle
waco has taught us that we must be
prepared to seek help and assistance
from other agencies from experts from
other government and local law
enforcement agencies as well as private
individuals and organizations
to this end
secretary rubin attorney general reno or
under secretary noble have instituted
regular meetings of which i am a
participant
these meetings develop joint
coordination strategies for shooting
incident investigations undercover
operations policies on the use of force
large operational undertakings and many
other matters that invite that involve
the entire spectrum of law enforcement
the second lesson that became obvious is
that better coordination communication
and oversight is necessary between atf
and a treasury department
atf must timely inform the
undersecretary for enforcement of our
intentions and to seek his oversight in
significant matters atf was laid in
informing treasury of its intentions to
execute execute the search warrant at
the branch davidian compound
since waco the treasury office of
enforcement has instituted a policy
mandating all treasury bureaus to notify
the under secretary of sensitive and
significant matters and major
investigations at an early stage
within the context of our own
capabilities the waco experience has
taught us
other valuable lessons on the planning
the execution and the post raid aspects
of an operation
some of them are as follows
commanders must be chosen based on their
ability to handle the type of operation
involved and not based on their
territorial responsibilities
commanders must have clearly defined
duties and responsibilities
planners and commanders must have
accurate timely and coordinated
intelligence
planners and commanders commanders must
have training in a wide range
of tactical options
the incident commander must be located
at the command post where he or she can
have access
to all intelligence and operational
developments
plans must contain carefully
planned constituency
contingency strategy so that the
momentum for going forward does not take
control over rational decision making
there is also a clear need for greater
attention to operational security
throughout the entire organization
a media response team comprised of
senior agents with extensive experience
as public information officers must
handle press queries at the site of
crisis in the future
managers team leaders and public
information officers must receive crisis
management training
this course has been developed and has
been delivered to members of our
organization
a core of group agents from each of our
field divisions will be trained in
negotiating crucial situations
without elaborating more this is a book
showing the corrective actions the
issues and the corrective actions that
we have taken in your your committee
and members of your staff will have as
many copies of these as they like sir
as a result this book has been developed
as a result of not only
the treasury oversight
which was overseen closely by under
secretary noble but also by my personal
observations and examinations since
arriving here a little over two years
ago
it also identifies the specific steps we
have taken to correct some of the items
that we have discussed
let me summarize two or three of those
we have provided crisis management
training to headquarter staff all
special agents in charge and als all
super supervisors and team leaders
we are in the process of finalizing an
atf order to ensure that major
operations are supervised by a manager
who has the proper background and
training with the director's office
providing close oversight
we have initiated the position of a
headquarters program manager for our
intelligence division to serve as a
intelligence coordinator and as all know
that was one of the huge breakdowns in
waco a full-time intelligence officer's
position was established and implemented
in all of our field divisions throughout
the country so that they're constantly
thinking and talking and paying
attention to operational and security
intelligence
instead we establish a plan to form an
intelligence response team if it's a
fairly large unit and the intelligence
officer can't handle it a response team
will go out so that they are totally
committed to intelligence so that it is
accurate it is timely it is complete
we also participating in intelligence
information sharing meetings among
treasury and other federal and local law
enforcement units
atf's regulatory enforcement function uh
was not involved in our intelligence
gathering matters in the past they are
now
they have been a lot of proprietary
information and we have added a
regulatory enforcement personnel to our
intelligence division to provide
information such as serious violation
being committed by
federal firearms and explosives
licensees this will permit us to use our
resources better especially in firearms
trafficking and illegal sale and
movement of explosives
we have implemented an audit program to
ensure that our intelligence improvement
continue to be effective and we will
measure them and make adjustments as
necessary
the 24 regional special response teams
are being transitioned to five regional
teams there will no longer be 24 there
will be five
the srts will now have crisis
negotiators and emergency medical
technicians aboard
because of this control consolidation
approximately 150 personnel are being
returned to full-time investigative
duties
we are taking steps to improve
operational security
one of those were highly criticized in
the waco incidents we're improving our
technical capabilities ie secure radio
and telephone communications
we have implemented a new atf order
specifying undercover guidelines and
instituted an undercover review
committee with representation from atf
other treasury agents and justice
personnel that must review all sensitive
undercover operations and report to
under secretary noble
we have improved our ability to respond
accurately and effectively to the media
and to congress by improving our
training of public information officers
and our notification protocols
at times that notifications need to be
made
it is also clear that it is crucial for
law enforcement to develop an
understanding of particular groups or
particular organizations prior to
interfacing with them a plan is being
developed to see that briefings consoles
and consultations take place
when needed
in order for the changes made at atf to
be truly make a difference it was
determined that we also needed to be
completely revamped the way that we do
business on a broader scale
we needed to improve our organizational
structure both at headquarters and in
the field and to establish a guiding
vision a strategic plan if you will
that would give us
give
actions all of our actions content and
and constructive approach
the restructuring of headquarters staff
is completed
and the successful future of atf
obviously is dependent upon well-trained
and a professional force and to this end
a training and professional development
directorate has been established
in the face also of constant demands to
do more with less a science and
information technology directorate has
been created
this office will ensure that atf keeps
pace with science and technology
developments that can improve our
effectiveness
and in doing so coordinating that
development with the treasury
enforcement council and the department
of justice
the internal review process has been
strengthened to provide a strong
well-staffed inspection unit which
answers directly to me and conducts both
operational reviews and internal
investigations while at the same time
closely coordinating with the treasury
inspector general's office
the above changes were made without
creasing our headquarters personnel and
these changes have been in effect for
about one year
a five-year plan to restructure our
field divisions and districts is ready
for presentation under secretary noble
the plan improves the span of control
and reduces the number of senior senior
level management positions it all plays
also places our field personnel where
the work will be in the year 2000 to
2005.
atf did not have a strategy strategic
plan that defined its future its goals
for outstanding work to be done such as
atf does and for it to be recognized and
supported
it needs to be part of a defined mission
understandable to atf personnel approved
by the administration congress and the
public
we have already begun to radically alter
the way we do business these plans will
define our future as an agency committed
to ensuring a sound and safer america
through innovation and partnerships
attached to my written statement is an
outline of atf strategy for the future
mr the strategic plan
we will continue to improve through
innovation and through our continued
partnerships with our colleagues in
state local and federal enforcement
while this hearing is very important
process for publicly examining atf's
actions at waco two and a half years ago
it is critical in my opinion that we not
overlook the substantial changes made at
atf since that raid
we recognize that waco has contributed
to to the current level of public
mistrust we are hopeful that these
hearings will clear the air of any
misinformation surrounding waco and
allow us to move forward to focus on our
central mission
removing dangerous criminals from our
streets and neighborhoods
in closing there are two additional
points which i believe are particularly
critical not only to atf but the entire
law enforcement community and more
specifically the public that we serve
moreover they are imperative to the
preservation of our constitution and our
cherished way of life in america
i am speaking of the time-honored
systems of checks and balances
throughout government they must be
safeguarded to protect against abuse
they must be backed up by vigorous
congressional oversight like you're
hearing today sir and lastly it is
essential that the public trust its law
enforcers
trust is a matter of personal integrity
it's a matter of personal competency
trust is a matter of agency integrity
and a matter of agency competency
i pledge to you sir to evaluate and
maintain the highest elevate and
maintain the highest of these standards
within atf
thank you mr chairman for approving the
time necessary for me to make this
statement well i want to thank both of
you and we appreciate the suggestions
that you're making and the things that
you're doing to change
what goes on there we know mr noble in
your statement the all of the positive
changes as well mr mcgowan yours that
are currently in the process
which are occurring and have occurred at
atf
now do both of you feel that these
changes are going to
work and that they will prevent this
this type of uh
the tragedy from ever happening again
mr noble will take you first then mr
mcgonn yes mr chairman
i'm not confident in saying that uh we
can prevent
tragedies and i know that the chairman
didn't intend that but i am confident
that
we will reduce the likelihood of such
tragedies in the future and by
cooperation and coordination between
both the treasury and justice
departments not only the law enforcement
entities but the criminal division
oversight components i think we will be
able to take a very very big step
forward in ensuring that our congress
and the public
have confidence
that we are investigating people who
need to be investigated that we are
investigating them properly and that we
are not abusing the process of law or
the rule of law along the way and you
feel confident that these these changes
you're making are going to enable you to
do that without it without
hopefully without having any further
incidents like this yes mr chairman
mr god do you have anything to say about
that now i i believe senator that
with the
treasury waco review the lessons learned
in there the kinds of things that that
that we are in a process not in a
process we started them all that we're
working on an incident like this and
those kinds of mistakes will not occur
again to you mr noble mr fife in
testifying said that
in his opening statement said that some
of the problems
of what happened at what
at waco did not arise
because of a lack of rules
but really because the rules that were
on the books were ignored
while acknowledging that you've made
some very needed changes here
i'd like to explain what treasury has
done
or is doing to enforce existing policies
that might also help prevent these type
of
mistakes from ever being made again
well one of the first things i did was
to
articulate a policy in writing
to share that policy with the bureau
heads of the treasury department and to
share that policy with the bureau heads
and the
policy overseers
at the justice department
to institute regular meetings between
the treasury enforcement bureaus and the
under secretary for enforcement
and to make sure that
we have the best possible leaders in
place at the various bureaus and with
director mcgaw at atf and the other
directors we have at treasury we believe
we have that finally to make sure
that we engage in a proper dialogue with
our oversight committees in congress and
i know that we don't have an opportunity
to appear before you often but i found
in the past when we have that's further
benefited us in terms of our law
enforcement mission okay mr mcgowan i
understand that
one major change has to do with the
coordinating intelligence
in fact i think it's fair to say that
this was a focus
of change in atf
we heard testimony earlier today from
captain coleman that the national
response plan
included an intelligence coordinator
and that in
in fact
someone was designated to fill that role
is that right
that's that's correct and the change
that we've made since that period of
time sir is that we've put intelligence
personnel out in our field division so
that we're in the business of of
collecting operational intelligence all
the time that can can be helpful
um this is a
chart they're going to put up now
senator that talks about the different
things that we have done in the
intelligence area okay
the creation of that program manager so
that
they're constantly the intelligence
division was only created about 11
months before waco started it did atf
did not have an intelligence division
before that time so it was in it in its
infant stages
uh since that time it has grown up
rapidly uh to the 24 in the field
divisions
and they're constantly feeding
information back and forth to
headquarters
uh where is is within our jurisdictional
area and and of interest to us if it's
some other bureau or agency then we pass
it along to them
creation of special response teams if
it's a large operation one person can't
handle it
our operation in headquarters
is a round-the-clock kind of an
operation available
we have systems now that we didn't have
before that allows us to do link
analysis and where there's a lot of
facts and information coming in at one
time the system will sort it out and
help us make better decisions
uh we've enhanced our intelligence
training by working with the
intelligence communities all throughout
the federal and the locals to
take take advantage of of of training to
to upgrade our abilities there
we've improved the guidance to the to
our special agents by
giving them all kinds of uh
questionnaires and sample checklists
so that if they do have to find out some
information they have a checklist to go
by because they're not normally trained
as intelligence agents if that might be
the case
and improve timeliness all of those
kinds of things and the oversight is a
constant oversight
and so this like you say was the the one
of the huge criticisms and so the
intelligence division came from just a
a a headquarters eight hour a day kind
of an operation to now a nationwide one
sir
well as you know we have we have people
even on our committee who would like to
do away with atf some would like to move
it out of uh
out of uh
treasury into justice
others would like to break it down i
mean there are there are a lot of
different ideas i've got an open mind on
this i frankly appreciate the the
changes that have been made
and i think uh
you know i i i appreciate the candor
that you've had that everybody's had
here today that there were mistakes made
that shouldn't have happened the way it
did that you can understand why people
in our society are
skeptical about our law enforcement
because of a whole wide variety of
things so waco and ruby ridge just being
two of them
and when we see an officer furman who
who evidences racial prejudice
that says to people there must be a lot
of other officers like that at least in
the
in the
local police
and then they start saying well maybe
also in the federal
law enforcement areas as well
and you tend to because you've had this
series of mistakes you tend to get
blamed for everything
so i'm happy to see some of the changes
that you're making i think that should
calm the fears of a lot of people in our
society today
i'd be the last to say we shouldn't have
the srt or the hrt out there
watching over us when you really have
true
hostage taking and true
dramatic
very very violent situations
but and i think it's important people in
this country understand that those
people risked their lives for us
and that they're not a bunch of cowboys
just running around doing nothing but if
they don't have the right
the right planning the right
intelligence the right guidance the
right guidelines
then no matter how good they are they
can also
be part of a fiasco
and in this case we have two of them on
our hands that have caused the
diminishment of belief in law
enforcement in this country that really
alarms me so i think this hearing has
been very important
with regard to uh
to all the testimony that's been brought
but especially yours well we'll turn to
senator dewine and
see if he has any questions thank you mr
chairman i'll be very brief good
afternoon
apologize for coming in late going back
and forth between a judiciary committee
and intelligence committee at the same
time
we heard testimony earlier this morning
from dr
amerman
in regard to the issue of
psychological profile knowing who
we're dealing with
and
i asked the doctor some specific
questions about the quality of
information that the fbi had
that you had in regard to
waco
and if i could summarize the doctor's
statement it was that
during the actual siege
there were there was good information
there was a good psychological profile
there was good
summaries that were written
but the doctor felt that the information
simply was not used by the the the
policy makers
my question to you is really uh
takes off from that but has to do with a
much bigger picture
in regard to
the future
what kind of role do you see
that information
plane in any decision that you make in
the future particularly in when you're
dealing with
so-called religious
cult
groups
senator i i just let me just again i i
mean i've been totally clear let me just
if i could just summarize you know
what information is needed
you know how do you gather that
information who do you rely on for that
information it's that internal external
combination of the two and then
who's the consumer of that information
what do you do with it kind of a process
question
i'm used to this process because of my
many years
in in the secret service and doing the
kind of protective work that they do and
when i came to this organization i
wanted to make sure that we implemented
it into our program
i think it's tremendously important that
you not only consult the experts but you
hear what they have to say and you
listen
and that you apply some of the things
that they have to say
and so that what we have done is
set up a list what i want to be very
careful of is that we're not in a
position where we're gathering
information on groups unless we have a
reason to do it
so once so i don't what we have is a
list of people who are experts in
certain areas in in the different areas
that we might be dealing with whether
it's the motorcycle gangs or whether
it's certain militias or whether it's
other groups
and when needed when we're into a case
in the early stages we're going to be
consulting with them
and it's going to be a very vital part
as that case moves along
where you also heard them talk about
this morning is it's
very difficult sometimes to referee or
to
make a judgment on
the strong operational people who are
equipped to do the operational mode and
this
other advisory group or those who might
be negotiators
and that's why we have
an overall manager now
of every major case
so that that person can not only bring
the information to me and the other
assistant directors
to help make that decision but we will
have close oversight there and we
continue
to attend all kinds of conferences we
had a very good conference in the
international association chiefs of
police
two weeks ago that was attended by
i think over three or four hundred
law enforcement officers it was
sponsored by the michigan state police
and atf on militias and ohio made a
great presentation your bureau from the
bureau of criminal identification in
ohio made an outstanding presentation so
we're doing all of these kinds of things
but making sure that we don't infringe
upon people's rights and that we don't
uh bring uh religious or other groups
into these things unless there's some
reason do so in an atf's case it will be
guns or explosives and things like that
and i appreciate that very much and
my my question i guess
was more focused
on the issue of once you
have a target group in the sense that
there is a confrontation or such as
there was at waco or there is there are
hostages that are taken
um
in other words there's a specific group
that we know
you know at this point you have to deal
with
you know how you go about
doing the psychological profiles
and what you do with that with that
information
as you re
review
reviewed
waco
would you and you may have already
covered this uh
well i was not here and i apologize if
you did but
could you review for me what your
assessment is
of
your department's
use of that type information during the
sequence of events
did you have the information
did you know who these people were did
you do the profile on them what'd you do
with the information
when you look back on it now uh
taking a one to ten
we did about a three or four instead of
being up around nine or ten
we did talk to uh some some former
branch davidians
we did confirm some of the information
that they told us
we didn't delve far enough into it we
didn't have somebody day-to-day
permanently thinking about intelligence
dealing with intelligence
coordinating it with everything else
that we were doing so it didn't get fed
in
uh at the proper times during the
investigation the planning stages
in order to make it valuable for us one
of the points that dr abram made this
morning was that sometimes
there's a reluctance to reach outside of
the internal organization
whether it's the fbi or atf or
cedarville police department whoever it
might be
[Music]
particularly when you're dealing with an
area where
there might not be the expertise within
the organization i think the doctor was
referring to the situation where you
have a religious cult there may not be
you may not necessarily have a lot of
experience in dealing with a group such
as that but there may be an expert
somewhere who
could add something to that is that is
that a
problem that's not a problem for us
that's not a problem for us now
uh before waco there had never been an
attack on law enforcement officers like
that
i don't think we had the
awareness to realize is that we needed
more outside help and consultation and
advice and sometimes you
it's there but you don't hear it and i
think it's taught us uh that
right now if we had a situation come up
with a particular group it's it's my
confidence that uh stu allen our chief
for intelligence division yet within the
hour would be able to have an expert in
that particular area to sit down and
start talking with and maybe even get
them to the scene good director thank
you very much
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
dewine senator biden i i yielded the
senator
i don't know
thank you very much senator and thank
you mr chairman
um mr mcgaw i know atf is often under
fire from a lot of different individuals
and
interest groups
but i do want to say this i think
from local law enforcement particularly
in most of california you do enjoy a
very good working relationship and i for
one appreciate that and i have
heard many compliments and uh
i want to so indicate to you
um
i want to
ask a couple of questions of you we
heard earlier today
from roger guthrie regarding the forward
observer program
had has this program been changed since
waco
and if so in what way and i mean
particularly
in a way that allows forward observers
uh to contribute more toward
intelligence efforts
yes it has been improved that not only
the entire program has been contr
improved as you talk about waco and you
look at the mistakes that were made at
waco it's because the information from
all areas was at least current
information was not going to the
planners
we didn't involve
the forward observers uh as completely
as we should have we didn't have them uh
doing the surveys and the kinds of
things that should have been done
uh which would have given us a huge
amount of information that that may have
totally altered the way we went about
our uh did you happen to hear mr mull
was it molten this morning
i hand you his uh
yes mr moulton's uh if you read his
comments
on the initial flaws of intelligence
gathering
i've not only read his opinion from the
book but i've we've talked to him a
couple of times and i was briefed on
what he said this morning yes ma'am
because i think he pointed out you know
where everybody thought the guns were
under lock and key they weren't that
women were
unarmed they weren't that men would be
out in the fields they weren't
so that uh koresh
could have been uh
in some way
convinced to leave the premises or or at
least
uh encountered off the premises because
he did leave the premises i mean these
are sort of things that tell me that
basic intelligence was sorely lacking
basic and basic organization was sorely
lacking too because the intelligence
information was there if you talk to the
15 or 20 people
the information was there but we had
nobody centralizing it we had nobody
specifically responsible every moment of
every day for collecting intelligence
evaluating it analyzing it and then
passing it to those who needed to know
that that function just didn't exist as
i was explaining uh earlier that
atf did not even have an intelligence
division until about 11 months before
this event
and so it was very early in its stages
and and so we've made huge uh progress
there uh and this chart over here so
indicates so that you you never again
will have a situation
where uh intelligence is not coming in
and being fresh and being properly
analyzed and properly disturbed
distributed
now let me ask you this question i know
they had uh heavy weapons that the 50
caliber for example i've been told you
can fire it from the hill and it can hit
the white house and then its bullets are
seven inches long
so i mean that's serious artillery
and that may have conditioned
uh
the reasons why
fire trucks weren't at the ready
uh when the final attack was taken
but ambulances as well
henceforth
even if you were in that situation seems
to me there can be some accommodations
made by which emergency personnel and
vehicles are protected
in that kind of situation
clearly we have to do a better job of
that and in all of our response teams
now we're going to have people trained
uh in medical and and emergency
techniques right on the team itself
to include um the backup that you're
talking about
mr noble yes
senator you raise a very
very important uh point and and i don't
have an answer to it but the conflict
you understand i'm sure
and that is you really need them ready
and able to provide the kind of
assistance that might be called for
on the other hand you know from what
you've investigated in the waco matter
that
even after the fire started
the people inside the compound were
shooting
so you have a firefighter or a member of
an ambulance a company or crew
and you have to make the determination
do i send her or them in now or do i
send them in later but you definitely
have to have them close enough so that
when you decide it's safe to send them
in they can provide the service that's
required your command station was a mile
away
was where was the command post
again
i i just wanted to for the record make
it absolutely clear one great thing that
atf did in this
[Music]
tragedy was after 21 of its agents were
wounded and four were killed it turned
over complete operation to the fbi so in
terms of where their post was positioned
uh during the siege i don't have that
factual information i'm sure louis free
would provide it with it tomorrow
because
i i think that's one of the vulnerable
points now that there wasn't the command
post that was um insulated against that
kind of attack behind which you could
have had the nut
the equipment that was necessary to
successfully carry out
uh what is euphemistically uh termed a
dynamic entry
in the early stages the the command post
which was the building that we had used
for our
surveillance and observation in the
weeks prior to it
was not was not armored at all it was
about three to four hundred yards away
had an installation like you're talking
about had some armor had some protection
and you could put the vehicles behind it
the other problem you run into in that
area which we're going to deal with
properly the next time is how do you do
that in a remote area without drawing so
much attention to it they're difficult
task but the point you make is very
valid ones
mr noble
when atf originally informed treasury
about the proposed raid treasury
refused to allow the raid to go forward
only after atf director assured treasury
that the raid would go forward only if
the conditions were right
was the hold on the raid lifted
in retrospect we know more about those
conditions
that david koresh was tipped off and
ready and no one was working in the pit
and lives were lost
given treasuries concerned about the
weapons and the children
what kind of discussion took place
what exactly would constitute right
conditions
and was there a method in place to allow
treasury to confirm the conditions were
right on the day of the raid
you know there there's not a day that
goes by and i've heard people say this
before and i've always wondered whether
it's true and not until waco happened to
me do i know that it can be true
there's not a day that goes by that i
don't wonder and question myself about
whether there was better advice i could
have given on february 26 1993 that
would have prevented the raid from going
forward
all i did on that day and i want to
remind you not to defend myself but to
put it in context
the first time this memo was brought to
my attention was a couple of hours after
the world trade center bombing had
occurred
same friday
when i'm thinking about agents who will
one day be under my responsibility
secret service agents in the world trade
center customs agents in the world trade
center we hadn't gotten a report back
yet whether many were killed some were
killed none were killed
that was what i was focusing on and
during that moment
a memo came across my desk
that raised questions for me because i
had been in philadelphia when move
occurred
and it talked about this raid plan near
waco texas that might draw some media
attention and i
was thinking that if they seized machine
guns or
rifles or grenades
it probably wouldn't come to anyone's
attention at main treasury
so whoever thought that this would
attract the attention of the secretary
of deputy secretary because of the
the results of the raid you know was
probably not watching tv and recognizing
that the world trade center had just
been bombed
the questions i asked and
encouraged the acting assistant
secretary to follow through on were
questions that led to a temporary hold
or a stoppage being placed on the raid
why are we going forward with this raid
what are the objectives that are
intended what are the harms we're trying
to avoid
what alternatives do we have
what provisions have been made to ensure
that people aren't going to be
unnecessarily put at risk i don't
remember all the questions but just sort
of common sense questions
that a reasonable person would ask and
we were told that this investigation had
been underway for almost a year
that atf had received intelligence from
a variety of sources that this was a
very dangerous person who once before
david kresh had used arms and armed
assailants to overthrow
the previous leader of the davidian
compound that they had talked about
going
uh
engaging in a mass suicide if anyone
ever learned about this operation that
an undercover agent had been placed
inside the compound on previous
occasions
and would be able to alert atf if
anything had gone awry
questions along those lines and
ultimately the director of atf a person
had been a director for 10 years was
personally involved giving treasury
personal assurances and one thing i've
learned since then is you can't manage
a field operation from headquarters if
you're atf and you certainly ought not
to manage a field operation if you're in
the civilian oversight component you
should just simply ask
those questions
that are thoughtful reasonable questions
assure yourself that every question or
doubt you have has been addressed and
then let the people who are trained
uh and empowered to do the right thing
do the right thing and here what i just
want to highlight and it's something you
alluded to in your earlier remarks
there were three conditions which were
supposed to be present which the entire
operation success depended on
the men being in the pit
the arms being
locked in the arms room and the women
and children being separated from the
arms and from the men in the pit those
three conditions were supposed to be
present
when they arrived
at location one of the agents later told
an interviewer that it was eerily silent
no one was outside
no one thought about asking the
questions
are the three conditions which are
supposed to be present present do we see
anyone outside if they had asked that
question they would have said wait a
minute no one's outside if they couple
that with what director mcgosh said was
there were media vehicles driving back
and forth a media vehicle had emptied
and a neighbor was asked questions by
the people inside in addition a postal
vehicle was seen racing into the
compound finally the undercover agent
came out and said that crash had said
while looking out the window they know
we're coming
i mean atf the national guard are coming
the undercover agent said to atf they
know we're coming
when the agents were rallied at the
staging area sixty one agents later
reported that the
deputy raid commander said they know
we're coming come on let's hurry up
forty five minutes elapsed between that
call to vehicles and the vehicles
arrived at the compound
any law enforcement officer who you talk
to manager will tell you in light of
that information a rational law
enforcement officer ought to have called
the raid off what director mcgosh
pointed out on previous occasions is our
raid commander deputy raid commander
especially deputy ray commander were so
overloaded with so many responsibilities
that the questions he asked were
was there any call to arms he asked the
undercover agent the answer to that was
no
was there any visible sighting of arms
the answer that question was no was
there any visible posting of centuries
centuries the answer to that question
was no he got three negative answers and
therefore said everything must be okay
but he never contemplated but people
before atf
i encountered the videos that waco
probably never contemplated was that
people would actually lie in wait in an
ambush for agents if they had thought
about the possibility of an ambush
ambush then the negatives wouldn't have
given them any comfort and they could
have called off the raid
so i believe the treasury department the
acting assistant uh secretary for
enforcement was courageous to have
stopped the raid but he was also
courageous to have let it go forward
assuming that the people who were
empowered with the decision to make
decisions
at the location of the raid would make
the right decisions
thank you very much thank you thank you
senator feinstein senator biden
thank you very
much gentlemen uh it was a fairly
extensive and self-critical report that
treasury did
as i understand it this whole project
was monitored by the officer inspector
general is that correct correct what did
the inspector general conclude about how
diligent you were in your
self-analysis of treasury the inspector
general submitted a letter which is part
of the treasury department report saying
that the report was comprehensive candid
uh in its findings
the uh mr mcgraw
what has been done
there's a number of improvements that
you've put in place but what has been
done
uh what improvements are being made to
uh
to the quality
of the special response teams that
handle
operations like this i mean what have
you done to ensure the quality
what we've done first of all sir is
reduce the 24 units to five
and give them five regions of the
country
uh and we have increased their training
we have
in the process of increasing their
training
we also are
making the the five units more complete
in terms of having negotiators trained
negotiators on those teams
and also medical personnel on those
teams
what i want to get away from in this
bureau is
the fact that we use the srts when they
were 24 we used them in my view
sometimes when we didn't need to use
them in order to keep them active now
that's my comment it's not the agent's
personnel it's mine and a two-year
observation
what i want to do is to change that
culture if you speak if you say that
that we use those teams and we make
forced entries to make arrests as a last
resort not as anywhere in between
i want you to be able to show your
supervisors that there is no other
alternative
our number of forced entries in arrest
have
reduced a lot in the last year and a
half but the arrests haven't reduced
there's all kinds of ways to and you
have to go through all kinds of
of
stories and situations before i want
those teams used
the five will be in regions and be able
to respond very quickly if there's a
need we have developed
a checklist if you will
which
we can
have available to the committee
which is put together by not only our
bureau but other law enforcement input
to it each supervisor
has to go down that checklist and only
if that checklist reaches a certain
number are they allowed to even consider
activating the srt team
then they call it srt team supervisor
and they talk about the issues and what
have you done
up until now that makes you believe that
we have to be activated
what i want also is our our agents as we
head to 24 srt teams
they were getting all the training for
arrests
and the agents working the cases were
turning them over to the srt teams to
make the arrests i want the agents to
better train so these five srt teams
will be pretty much full-time but when
they're not operational which will be a
great deal of the time they will be back
in the field divisions training the
street agents bringing their level
uh of expertise up in terms of safety
firearm safety uh arrest and search and
seizure those kinds of things
one last question
what have you been doing what have you
done to ensure that
the best commanders
are in charge of
major crisis incidents as they come up
and to be sure that they're up to task
you've got these five teams
are the teams called out geograph based
on geography yes sir based on how about
the commanders
the commanders are no longer called out
on geography by geography they were
before if you were the special agent in
charge of that area
that became your responsibility
now what we're doing is giving all of
our special agents crisis management
training and more training in those
areas but we're going to identify
three or four or five
that will respond to this situation
specifically trained to do that to
oversee the entire operation
are you
what have you been doing you you heard
the testimony this morning it's my last
question
you heard the testimony this morning
from
professor and not within another
cameraman
professor amberman
and uh one of the uh most delicate it
seems to me
crises to deal with
in this country
because of the first amendment
because of freedom of religion and our
are
i think necessary
uh
an overwhelming adherence to being
careful we don't interfere with the free
practice the practice of religion
um uh
have you
in any way increase the
your uh your inquiry your background
your training the
the uh uh the um uh the uh
let me back up the fbi have done a lot
of work over the years of the fbi on
organized crime in the mafia
uh they not only
deal with the mafia in terms of how to
infiltrate the mafia
they deal with the uh the mafia and
understanding the codes of silence the
what a made person is and so on and so
forth i mean they've studied and spent a
lot of time and effort dealing with
trying to figure out the mentality that
permeates
that
are you doing that with uh
depending on the potential groups you're
likely to have to deal with uh
neo-nazi groups uh
[Music]
quasi or religious groups that may go
off the edge
i mean is there tell me about what
you're doing to learn more and to
to be better equipped to deal with
what is a uh
may or may not be a mounting problem
i'm very concerned about what you are
senator in terms of
of interfering with people's rights and
religion so what we have done
is we have developed a list
of people
that are expertise
in almost
any area that we might be involved in
and as soon as we develop a case because
of explosives or firearms violations or
something is a violation of atf
then we involve that individual as that
case progresses
so that as we move forward we clearly
understand
but to assess
to assemble that information prior to
uh some kind of violation we have we
have chosen not not to do that
but our our list our availability to
people who are
experts in that area for instance if you
take uh because of the the waco uh we're
you know we're very up-to-date if you
take uh
certain militias who have committed uh
crimes of of
firearms and explosives or arson um
we'll we'll be pretty up to date on that
unit and that group
but to
to go out and target any particular
group
for intelligence and information we're
not doing it
i've obviously not been articulate
enough of my question i'm not talking
about who you target
i'm talking about as you sit down there
and think of the panoply of problems you
may face
the groups that uh
for example there is no such cult that
i'm aware of in the united states but
assume
that japanese cult that used the siricon
gas in in
uh in tokyo
assume
i mean are you doing
preparatory work to learn as much as you
can
about the way in which these various
not individual organizations not david
koresh versus uh
some group uh that
of snake charmers or something uh um i'm
not suggesting any group particularly
but
those the professor said
there are disciplines in sociology that
are broken down now to try to determine
even within
the discipline of sociology relating to
the practice of religion and
fringe religious practices and she laid
out how they've broken it down are you
all just sitting there thinking uh you
know a gun is a gun as a gun
and whoever has the gun we just got to
go get the gun if they don't legally
have the gun are you doing something
you are as we might say your agency
depends upon the answer in part
yes we we are are doing a lot in that
area especially where it's in the public
uh spectrum anyway in terms of the
the colleges the universities around the
country the medical professions any of
that that's in the public spectrum we
are collecting
any of it that
other federal law enforcement
units collect we share that information
back and forth so that we are
that we are informed
mr noble yes and we're also
it's very important for for atf too and
i know that you're aware of this to
carve out an area in which it has
expertise but to share that expertise
with other entities so what the justice
department through the fbi and the
treasury department to the atf have done
is we've been concerned with these
groups
that have predilection or desire to arm
themselves
through all unlawful means or to gather
unlawful arms and to try to think about
how they approach the arming of
themselves how they're able to amass
weapons without law enforcement becoming
aware of it how do they meet how do they
gather how do they communicate with one
another we know that internet is being
used quite frequently and sharing
information on how to build bombs and
how to perpetrate arsons and so forth
and also we're thinking about the
treasury department has one
success as of late to speak about how
can we address the harms
that these groups might be desiring
without a violent confrontation there
was a group in in montana that had
amassed a whole slew of
illegal firearms automatic weapons
uh
uh tank uh vehicles and so forth and
what the irs did was the irs contacted
them and said you are
at risk
of losing your tax-exempt status
unless you get rid of these weapons in
this armament and it worked
and we didn't go in with a raid and no
one was killed and no one was put at
risk so we are thinking about it but
we're trying to do it in an effective
fashion without
uh running into unnecessary conflict
with other entities that also have
jurisdictional concerns in this area
if jim jones hadn't gone to guyana and
he happened to be in
selbyville delaware or happened to be
because neither one of you are being
responsive to my question
one of the criticisms of you all is that
you don't understand the mentality and
the reason why
the people who are acting illegally act
the way they do you didn't understand
the argument the criticism goes you
didn't understand how a david koresh's
mind worked you didn't understand how
i'm not saying that that's right or
wrong but that's one of the criticisms
one of the criticisms is that you did
not take enough time to learn how
these
people think quote unquote these people
had a jim jones been in uh in southern
california or in the desert
that the senator from
california just saved for california
with his cult instead of having kool-aid
had they had these
and you went in to get kids out people
would be saying wait a minute you should
have known they were all going to drink
kool-aid
you should have known they're all going
to kill themselves what i'm trying to
figure out is you all trying to figure
out what makes people act the way they
do
they talk about cult mentalities they
talk about the way in which these groups
interact i don't know whether it's a
bunch of hokum or not
i don't know where these sociologists
know what they're talking about or these
psychologists know what they're talking
about or these psychiatrists know but do
you know
do you know
seems to me it'd be something you'd be
sitting down thinking about because
law-abiding citizens unless they're
organized crime they don't get together
and amass all these weapons
people either see god coming on the
second coming or people who drink
kool-aid laced with uh um arsenic
they're they're the folks that do this
stuff
and what are you doing to figure out how
they think
senator
i'm trying to be responsive to your
question i may not give you an answer
that that is acceptable but
we have the answer would be we have
contacted the sociology department at
harvard and yale and stanford we have a
group of people sitting down figuring i
can give you the answer that's the right
answer
that's the right answer
perhaps i could approach it slightly
differently and i'm sorry that you're
upset because i didn't understand that
was a thrust of your
question what are you doing to trying to
figure out how these groups they're
mounting what are you doing to try to
figure out what makes the psychology of
the group work together senator with all
due respect do you know how many groups
that are out there amassing firearms or
thinking about crazy sorts of criminal
activities that they could be engaged in
there are so many groups that all we did
was spend our time investigating these
groups would be writing
okay this is the last time i'll try it
okay and then you're on your own
last time i'll try
they all have an organizing principle
and it's not a gun
the organizing rationale is they either
think the government's coming to take
over and take their guns they think that
america has lost its uh um uh notion of
free enterprise they think that we uh
there's too many homosexuals in america
they think that the lord has not looked
upon us there's an organizing principle
other than the amassing of the guns
that's not the organizing principle that
gets those folks all to the side they're
going to all hang out in a compound in
waco not a place you go for vacation
sir in terms of atf
if it's a
a group that is
violating one of our jurisdictions we
spend a great deal of time
learning and being informed about them
okay if they don't have any of our
violations where we learned about them
is trading information back and forth
between other federal units i got who
are working with i appreciate it sorry i
it's an obviously an ad hoc
determination you make when you find out
a group's broken law then you try to
find out what the organizing principle
in psychology is so you don't make a
mistake again of not knowing not that
you could be clairvoyant so you have a
better guess as to whether or not a
screw ball like koresh is going to set
everybody on fire you heard people
testify your critics say if you'd really
taken the time to know you could have
figured out that koresh is likely to do
what he did i think that's incredible
monday morning quarterbacking i don't
know how you could have done that but
you have people saying that so if you
you've answered my question it's an ad
hoc judgment once you realize the law is
being violated then you try to figure
out what motivates those folks so you
know whether to negotiate or break down
the door
right
that's
very well put i wish i thought of it
earlier
well that's the problem not you didn't
think of that earlier if that's all
you're doing that's the problem
senator
and i know you've been so supportive but
there is nothing that concerns american
citizens more than the thought that a
firearms agency
whose responsibility is to enforce the
firearms laws investigating them for
things beyond that i know the way you
phrased it it's perfect
but with all due respect atf on this one
case with waco with david koresh said
before the raid
that if they didn't do something one of
the risks was that david corrections
followers would engage in a mass suicide
they predicted it when they first said
it when the raid first happened between
february 28th and april 19
expert after expert criticized atf and
said false they just made it up what was
the basis of that observation was it
just that you're all instinctually good
or is it because you had experts in the
area say people who gather like this are
people who may put themselves away like
this what was the basis of that original
judgment that you happen to be right
about and other people didn't think you
were right about where the best
information came from sir was the
davidians themselves former davidians
and that's where the best information
and that's where
the atf personnel drew their conclusions
from that time that answers the question
thank you very much thank you mister
well thank you thank you
senator biden i i i i want to say to you
that it's always easier to
look at things in retrospect
we can always find lots of fault
uh after the fact
and uh a lot of people have with regard
to this
i think what senator biden is
is saying among other things
is that
when we get into these situations we've
got to presume a lot of things we've got
to go beyond what seems to be normal
and just
you know do our very very best to be
able to be prepared for the worst and in
this particular case there were some
failures
and naturally we're looking at it in
retrospect and
and it's clear that they were failures
and it's easy to criticize
it's very tough
to be a law enforcement official
it's very tough
for law enforcement agencies to know
exactly what's going to happen in
advance
and in this particular case there's been
there are lots of mistakes the purpose
of these hearings isn't necessarily to
rehash those you've been through enough
of that
we know what the facts are you know what
the facts are uh you've admitted there
were mistakes
the fbi admits there are mistakes
purpose of these hearings is to see if
we can alleviate them in the future
and if we can you know do what's right
to
have everybody in our country respect
and support law enforcement
and or at least most everybody in our
country that
thinks clearly so that's what we're
trying to do mr chairman yeah i say one
thing sure
i think and and i think i sense the
frustration of mr noble because if you
want to look across this country at all
of the potential threats that are out
there
you couldn't count them below a thousand
certainly real potential threats
and i think this is in a very difficult
area something brand new
which is
fanaticism and religion together
that
creates uh whether it's fundamentalist
islamists
islamics
or the branch davidians or the people's
temple or the move i think we're going
to have more and more of these as time
goes on and i think what the committee
is interested in and rightly so
is seeing that the right apparatus is in
effect to be able to handle it and i am
very heartened
by the changes that have been made
uh and by the fact that i think now not
to in any way stultify you or prevent
decisions from being made but have a
process that is broadly that expands
that goes out that that really seeks
information you mentioned the branch
davidians were the best source
well
you never really know
the motive
someone talking to law enforcement from
a group like this
either
so i think it's all it's very difficult
for you
but i think what what we want to know is
that
there are the procedures and the process
in place so that it's the best command
situation the best decision making that
can possibly make be made at a given
point
i would just
add to that senator i appreciate your
comments
uh one of the things we've been
grappling with at the treasury
department is
how do we as a federal government as
federal law enforcement components
approach these very difficult
issues and i know one thing that this
committee and other committees have been
concerned about is that we don't go
about duplicating
items that already exist so the the
justice department the fbi has a
tremendous behavioral science
scientist component the atf and treasury
works with that component one of the
reviewers from the treasury department's
review said that the treasury department
should have a national national response
team well there's already a hostage
response team what we're trying to do is
work collectively with entities that
already exist to make them better and in
addition to that reach out for experts
who might have information about a
particular group if that particular
group is suspected of violence can i can
i just say one thing i think it's a big
mistake to leave everything in an hrt or
an srt or any anything like that there
has to be a command responsibility
absolutely and i think the key is
probably bringing in people who are
specially trained and not leaving it up
to the local people right and i think
one thing
the treasury department what we have
done and i think it's apparent in this
review and it's apparent in other
reviews in this review we brought in
three independent reviewers we brought
in six tactical operations experts in
the forward-looking review dr ammerman
is someone that the federal government
brought in to look at this problem
uh one of the things we have to do and i
don't know how we can do it in a
systematic fashion but we have to do is
to figure out if there are experts who
we can draw on as matters arise i think
that's your point as well but there has
to be an integration between the
behavioral scientists the psychologists
and the tactical operations experts as
well and it has to be done collectively
as a federal government not each
department having its own that was my
point thank you that's good you've got
to do all of these things in a way that
doesn't lead to oppression by the
federal government that's probably
behind some of the irritations that some
of those on the right are so concerned
about and some of them on the far left
are concerned about so
you really have a tough job i think if
there's anything comes through to us
it is that you're doing
you you're in a position where it's very
very difficult
and the american people need to know it
mr chairman yeah
i think mr noble just very much
clarified what i was trying to get at
let me put it another way one last
chance and as you know
you are a friend i
am adamantly opposed to the merging
of atf i am adamantly opposed to you
being
put into the fbi or any other place
but i am trying i thought i was helping
you make your case i obviously made it
harder for you to make your case let me
try it one more time
yes or no question i assume the same
thing occurred
again you get a call tomorrow there is a
group whatever they call themselves
the uh um uh the the i'm afraid to say
something because there may be such a
thing right that's right but uh you know
uh um you know uh
the exam do followers of the lord okay
god i hope there's no situation oh my
goodness okay
now
and they are holed up
in their compound
and it turns out they have a a
significant stash of weapons you have
overwhelming evidence to know that
in addition to going to internally
within atf to try to figure out assuming
you have no informant you've gotten the
call from the local folks saying by the
way
a guy just delivered 17 barrels of
napalm
to this place and i just delivered it
you have no other information
who are you going to call
are in addition to your internal
expertise are you going to call the
justice department and say who do you
have that knows anything or deals with
this group that aligns themselves with
the third book of the bible that says
such and such
who are you going to bring in
who are you going to look to you're
going to look you're going to pick up
the phone and call the leading experts
in the nation who know what makes these
folks tick or might know what they take
how do you go about it now i apologize i
i thought i explained that when you were
here but it must have been before you
came in
we have a list
of experts in almost every area that we
can think of that the department of
justice can think of that the behavioral
sciences throughout the universities can
think of as experts should something
like that occur tonight
within the hour
our intelligence division chief and some
of our personnel can be communicating
with that individual we're prepared to
bring them into the investigation in
terms of advising us along the way
and and that's the way that that i have
to approach it i i in in these
controversial jurisdictions that we have
if i was collecting information just
based on groups
this body would i would be the first one
to be calling you up asking the chairman
the old days i would call you up now i'd
ask the chairman to call you up um uh
because that is not appropriate you've
answered the question
um and i think it's very important for
folks to know
that you are not merely
an outfit that has the tactical
capability of going and arresting people
that you sit down and think through and
you go to all the available experts in
what is a mounting body of
evidence that
gives profiles to i mean you go the fbi
and you have he and i i don't know
whether he has i expect get a death a
death a death
threat
on a telephone the fbi sits and listens
to the voice they have a protocol that
is there to determine whether or not it
should be taken sir they're not always
right but they try like hell
it gives people some solace to know that
they are amassing as much information on
behavioral
reactions of certain groups of people
and certain profiles
that's the only point that i wanted to
make for you and i have now assured that
you will probably be merged
notwithstanding uh my support for you um
i'm joking that's a joke that's a joke
the hearings have gone well mr chairman
i should have
let well enough alone
um and not raise the issue except that i
think it has to be raised and i think it
has to be on the record that people know
that there are sources you look to
beyond your own agency that don't
require you to be merged into another
agency to acquire that capability
well in fact they have panels that meet
monthly to discuss all these kind of
things between all the federal units and
it really has expanded since since well
there's a lot of coordination what
you're saying
thank you senator bye no i want to thank
both of you for appearing i think this
has been a good hearing today
uh tomorrow it may be a little more
dramatic
but the fact of the matter is is that
i'm pleased that we're moving ahead
trying to correct difficulties and doing
what's right in law enforcement and the
american people can feel good about it i
i i personally believe
so with that we'll recess until 9 00 a.m
when i will try and start tomorrow
morning if we can thanks so much
[Music]
yes
oh yeah
today this committee will hear from fbi
director lewis free along with several
hostage and negotiation specialists
today on washington journal our
newspaper roundtable guests are virginia
lieutenant